thank you
i don't hear anything from the index
funds where are they
it's really
it's really big
it really feels good to get back and
be doing this in person we've it's been
three years
and uh
it's a lot better
seeing actual
shareholders owners partners
and uh
[Applause]
we
we uh
charlie charlie and i are now a
combined
uh fifa round for fractions
uh the two of us are 190 years old and
uh
and
i really think you're entitled
if you're the owner of a company
and you've got
two guys 98 and
running the company you're entitled to
actually see him in person i mean
it shouldn't be too much to
ask that i mean for example if we had a
we had a manager someplace that was
98 i might
want to send somebody by occasionally to
see whether he was cutting about paper
dolls or something
so
so uh
uh we probably do things that are a lot
more foolish than cutting out paper
dolls but but uh
but we're having a lot of fun doing it
and uh
and we really have a lot of fun
uh
when you come visit us
actually
uh
we had
to go back
a few years
we've had a couple uh
a couple of managers that
uh that
suffered from dementia probably many
more but i mean i'm just a couple of
known ones actually
and and uh
uh
there was one fellow
that charlie and i really loved
and uh uh he ran a business for us
charlie was out in california charlie
would see him occasionally and i i
didn't see him but
everything seemed fine and
and then we found out
that he'd really been suffering uh
from dementia for
quite a while and
uh
and it really was a wonderful friend of
both of ours but
but the business had done fine so that's
become our
our test really is that
for new businesses
we try to find something that guy with
alzheimer's can run actually and
and you don't have as much competition
for businesses like that
the guy sitting there cutting out paper
dolls and you know that's our man
i'd like to introduce
two fellows who really work at berkshire
uh
on charlie's left
greg abel who
who runs all the
operations outside
[Music]
and
next to him is i
i ran the insurance business for about
15 15 years on unsuccessfully and then
fortunately the fellow on the far left
came in one day and i've written about
it but he came in on a saturday and
and i was opening the mail and
and uh
he said that
that
he'd be happy to run our insurance
business i said have you ever run an
insurance business and
he said no and as i
mentioned well
you know i never won one either so i'm
not doing so hot so
give it a try and uh
you know he
transformed berkshire hathaway and uh
energy jane is here with us
[Applause]
uh what we'll do today
and i have to remind myself from time to
time that
the people here of course saw that movie
and everything but of course we're
webcasting that so i'll probably make
some references to the movie or
something that'll
puzzle
millions of people out there but you'll
get it so
uh
we're going to
talked for
uh
a little while about
what's happened uh
uh
in the last quarter and
bring up a few other things that you
might be interested in
and
we will then
whenever that's
finished
we'll go on to
questions and we will
take the questions until noon
we'll break for an hour that's
uh
midwest time for those of you are
watching in other time zones we'll go on
till noon and uh
we'll break for an hour
and then
charlie and i will come back and
we'll take more questions
until 3 30 and then we'll
convene the shareholders meeting at 3 45
we'll take a break for 15 minutes
and uh and then we'll do the
shareholders meeting and
when that's done we'll uh
uh
we'll all uh go our various ways
uh i do want to report incidentally that
uh
you've been doing your part in terms of
the
room we have adjacent
to this uh
uh
location
uh where we've been yesterday for five
hours
from noon to five we had twelve thousand
uh shareholders
come and just
spend money on everything we could think
of to solve them
we we brought in
we brought in 11 tons
of seized candy
and
uh if we don't sell out charlie and i
get the rest so uh
but uh
uh
you did your part she's he sold or he
set a record yesterday for the friday
afternoon meeting and and it's uh
it's pretty heartening yeah
incidentally
i've got a box of c's candy here and uh
it's very it's it's sort of interesting
uh
on this
on this uh cover which i hope you can
see
um
there's a picture of a woman
who was born in 1854
and
today
she probably gets her picture seen
more often
than just about any
any woman in america in terms of uh
uh a commercial product or something of
the sort so we've got our picture up in
over 200 stores
and uh
on every box of candy
that's mary c born in 1854. a lot of
people think this is me and drag but
that is not true i mean
there's a certain resemblance but uh
it's just not
these rumors are started by our
competitors don't pay anything
so
we will that's our schedule for the day
and what we will do
we like to give all
we like to give shareholders
owners
partners
we like to give everybody the same
information at the same time and
preferably do it when stock markets
aren't open it seems to us that that's
everybody ought to be on the same
playing field
it's very interesting
uh
we don't know how many shareholders
we've got they've changed the
rules over time
uh
uh as to
uh registered holders and getting stock
certificates and all that sort of thing
so
we can't keep track of it like
50 or 75 years ago where we had an
actual shareholders list but we're told
we're told by the
people who mail out
our information
ah
it's a firm in like new jersey but uh
uh
let's see
broadridge
and they pretty well do this for
very significant
percentage of american corporations so
they they actually mail things out for
us and
they bill us
for three and a half million
uh accounts
uh and
uh
i'll take their word for it i mean the
more accounts they bill is for we pay it
by the account so you know
some days i feel like i'd like to count
but that that is a
that is a lot of
a lot of people
that trust us
and
they
rightly in my view overwhelmingly
feel that they're our partners
and some of them
will like
reading financial information
they've given us
that we give you uh
but
most a a great many of them just say
you know we've saved this money
and we trust you and charlie
and that's a great motivator this trust
and uh you know take care of it and
and i'm not going to learn accounting
and try to read all those statements or
anything of sort but we do believe that
for those who do
use the information we release they
should all get it at the same time
and we have a few
institutions that even though
in the third paragraph of my letter
every year
i um
i uh refer to the fact that
uh
we want to have
everybody get the same information and
that we don't feel that
anybody's entitled to special meetings
we can't hold three million special
meetings with our
partners and
uh
but we like the fact that everybody gets
the same deal
everybody gets the same information
up this
morning
on the internet we put up
our 10-q
for the
quarter
and
i'd like to
take a few
through a few
comments on that and
a few other comments and then we'll get
to the question when we get to the
questions we will
alternate
between those mailed in by shareholders
which
uh
becky quick at cnbc
and
people have helped her
sort of curated
get what they think are the most
interesting questions from shareholders
they're not they're not from the
from cnbc itself they are from
shareholders owners
and we'll alternate the ones from send
in versus the ones that come here and we
don't get the questions ahead of time
and
we enjoy getting surprised by
and i'd say almost all questions and
and we will
keep doing that like i say with a break
for lunch
uh until 3 30 when we'll have the
meeting so
uh
i would like to uh
start by
putting up
the
first slide
and
which is q1
and there we have it that's what we
published this morning
and
they're really no great surprises
uh
in in terms of the quarter i mean there
are always some companies that are doing
very well there are some companies that
aren't for one reason or another and
uh
in the end as you can see
we prefer to use something called
operating earnings now
that is after depreciation and interest
and
taxes
unlike other companies that
prefer to tell you anything about what
they earned
uh we
have but we do separate out capital
gains now
over time as i've said
over the next 20 years i would expect
this net to have more capital gains than
not but
you know who knows i hope you you know i
i'll report you in 20 years whether
that's happened or not
but
uh
as you can see we made about
seven billion dollars
in the first quarter and
and that's real seven billion i mean
we
basically
have i in
in cash when the uh
when the quarter's over that isn't true
every quarter exactly but but uh
uh
we uh
we are talking about
seven billion of
real money uh
in that and
those managers who
the people here saw in the movie
uh
they're the people that
that work with your money
to uh
accomplish
uh
what charlie and i never thought would
never really planned or anything to
happen but it just
sort of uh
came about
uh
was sort of putting one foot
uh in front of the other uh
now obviously
the last two years in particular
including the first quarter
all kinds of
unusual things
happen in our various businesses i mean
that uh
when we
had the meeting
uh two years ago
in the may of
roughly the start of may of
uh
we didn't know what was going to happen
with the pandemic we didn't know what
was going to happen
with the economy and uh
and everybody that thought they did
gotten all kinds of surprises since but
here we are in 2000
22 and and berkshire
like i say had seven
billion of operating earnings and
we've got lots and lots and lots of
companies got 360 000 people out there
that have taken your savings
and
go to work every day
they have jobs we deliver products
and you put up the money for it and you
deserve to
uh
you took
you took the risks
and uh
we feel very good about how things have
turned out
and we want to keep feeling good
and
we have a
extreme
aversion
uh
to
incurring any
permanent loss
with your
funds you know
if if i went broke it wouldn't really
make any difference i mean it just uh
i'd keep
doing what i
do i
forgot a way to read a paper and
watch a little tv and
and think about things and talk to
charlie
but the idea of losing
permanently
other people's money
uh people who trust us
uh
really
really uh
that's just the future i don't want to
have it as charlie says
charlie says all i want to know is where
i'll die so i'll never go there and uh
um
that seems pretty sound
[Music]
in case you missed charlie says his work
so far and
the uh
and we we would die psychologically
uh
if we lost a lot of other people's money
we wouldn't take it in the first place
be crazy to take
take people's money and lose it if
you're gonna feel terrible
about doing it so the one thing
i can tell you about bird traffic i
can't predict what earnings will be and
i can't predict what the stock will do
and i can't
we don't know we don't know what the
economy will do and all of that sort of
thing
but we do know
that we wake up every morning and the
we want to be safer
in terms of your eventual investment
uh not whether you make the most money
or anything we do not want you to get a
terrible result uh because you've uh
decided to become our partner and uh
that's a pleasure to live by now
uh
let's see what we have here
on uh
q2
it gives some
indication of that because we
this is kind of interesting
i wrote
i wrote a letter to
our owners and it was stated february
26th
and
that was a saturday
released
but i write the letter all through the
year in my mind i mean that uh
i don't uh
uh
no we don't have a anybody sits out and
writes out the letter or anything like
that i mean it's this is a letter
between
partners and i write the letter all here
in my head i'm i'm writing next year's
letter uh
i don't write out the words but i have
things i want to
tell my partners
my sister's a partner
and uh i'm writing to her in my head
my older sister died not
too long ago but i used to be writing to
both of them in effect
and i want to tell her
you know
what i think and
and
about the business and what i think she
ought to think about it and so on
uh
so the letter's dated february
26th and i said not much is going on
uh
and
actually uh
we might
we might jump over to q3
uh
if we will uh
uh so i said i sent out a letter on
february 26 but it that wasn't written
on february 26th and i said
basically nothing much is happening
around here and i said we've
re-purchased some shares
and
we we just aren't seeing anything
uh
between january 1st and february 18th as
you can see
we spent 2.2 billion dollars
uh
which is
half the quarter
and also
uh
probably
30 trading days in there and we sold
so
basically we didn't do anything
and then
uh in the next
uh three weeks or thereabouts we spent
40 billion
and uh
instantly when they say we spent 40
billion there's there's one fellow in
the office that does this all i mean he
buys all the stocks he buys the
government he doesn't have an assistant
or anything i just uh but he spent 41
billion at uh
yeah and
uh
he literally i mean it
and he does other things for me too he
puts together totals
he he just does what he needs to do and
he's worked in other jobs at berkshire
long ago but but he likes
he likes doing what he does and
he does it very well and we don't have a
department for that as you can see it
fell off after that and
uh we did also in the first
in the first
quarter we spent about three point
one or 3.2 billion somewhere in that for
repurchasing shares
and uh
um
we didn't
you know
we talked about that in the annual
report and uh
mr charlie would say it would it was
keeping us out of bars i mean you know
that that
gave us something to do
uh
and it and it
we never do anything that we don't think
adds to the value of berkshire hathaway
though so we only repurchase the shares
when
that is the most attractive thing to do
we haven't repurchased any shares at all
in april
uh
and uh
so it's
people who are looking for all these
uh
prints in the you know put footprints in
the woods and all that is what we're
doing
we're just doing it day by day as it
comes along and i think this table kind
of
illustrates that that we spent
40 billion in a hurry there between
three weeks and
and uh
now we're
back somewhat in our more lethargic
uh move but that anything could change
berkshire but the one thing that won't
change
going back to q2
i feel
uh
is we will always have a lot of cash on
hand
and when i say cash
i don't mean commercial paper when 2008
and 2009
financial panty came along
we didn't own anybody's commercial paper
we didn't have money market funds we
didn't we
have
treasury bills and uh
as i may get into a little later i'll
explain you why
uh
we would
we believe in having cash and uh
there
have been a few times in history and
will be more times in history where
where if you don't have it
you know you don't get to play the next
day i mean it uh
it's just uh
uh
it's like oxygen you know it's there all
the time but if it disappears for a few
minutes
it's all over so
we
our cash was down on march 31st because
as you saw we spent
that large sum
there in that brief period during the
quarter 40 billion
uh we've
committed to buy allegheny court
for something over 11 billion and uh but
we will always
have
a lot of cash we won't
we don't
some of our companies have bank lines i
don't know why they have the bank lines
we're better than the banks and we will
give them the money if they need it but
but you know the local banker's been
calling on them and
they need something to do everybody else
has bank lines so
it's harmless
uh but there's no reason for any of our
subsidiaries
uh that bangladesh when berkshire is
stronger than the banks that
uh i didn't hear exactly what i don't
know whether that was a
banker screaming her
i don't i don't really like to torture
him i don't like to torture anybody i
mean
but but uh
and i'm all for banks and we'll talk
about that a little later in fact
we might we might even talk about it
right now just for a minute
money's kind of an interesting thing
people seem to like to talk to me about
it i mean they don't they don't ask me
how to dance or anything like that but
they do ask about money and so
uh if we'll put up
uh
20-1
it's a
it's a photo of a
20 bill
and
it says at the top
federal reserve notes now federal
reserve no we we've done all kinds of
things with money in this country it's
amazing country only a couple hundred
years old
the number of different experience we've
made with banks and everything but we
finally just
decided to let the federal reserve do
the issuing of money
and uh
the
down in the lower left-hand corner
incidentally i think rosie rios
uh who signed this note i think she
signed more
more uh lewis currency than
than any other person in history
so if you see rosie you know you cozy up
to her i mean this is a woman who has
issued a lot of currency uh
but it says
it says
this note is legal tender
for all debts public and private
and that makes it money
you
you can go in
go into our candy store and if you offer
us enough bushels of wheat we'll
probably give you a box of candy
but but
money
is the only thing that
the irs is going to take from you that
you can you're going to offer them all
kinds of
uh you can offer them paintings you're
going to offer them all whatever but
this is what settles debts in the united
states
and i thought
that
they'll hear a lot about various kinds
of money this is the only kind of money
you're going to see
uh in my opinion
uh
throughout your
lifetime or even throughout
charlie's lifetime i mean this is uh
uh
it's very interesting because it it just
says
that um
settle all legal tender for all that's
public and private and nothing else says
that except i thought you might be
interested in seeing
uh
another twenty dollar bill on this one i
own
uh
and
on that
it's got the same guy's picture andrew
jackson and everything
uh
and that's a twenty dollar bill
and that one dollar bill
was issued during my lifetime
and it was done by a
bank
that berkshire ended up owning so you'll
see the illinois national bank and
buster rockford
and uh
we bought that bank
back in 1969
and if you look down at the bottom of
that one and signed by a fellow named
eugene abeg
and we bought it from eugene abec so we
we still have some 20 dollar bills
that came in sheets and we can cut them
out like paper dolls
and
there are money uh the illinois national
bank
issued money
but
just remember
the united states government
in effect said that this became
exchangeable for lawful money in the
united states that that's what money is
it may turn out that it
becomes
worth dramatically less
than purchasing power
it can become almost like paper money as
it has in many countries
but
that is all
when people tell you that they're
issuing new forms of money
this is the only thing
that will pay bills
under some circumstances and there were
there were days
a few days in 2008
and we came
very close
to having a repeat
in
march
from 2020
and
we had plenty of money
on march 20th
uh
but
we were not very very far away from
having something that might have been a
repeat
of 2008 or even worse
and we have a bookstore here
uh
but the bookworm that's in the other
room and they've got a book
called trillion dollar triage
and for those of you who actually like
to read about this sort of thing it's a
marvelous account
of what took place day by day
with the federal reserve
and the treasury
and
believe me
uh
if the federal reserve hadn't done what
they did
at least in my view
uh
in a very very very short period of time
things could have stopped
uh
and and uh
and i
tipped my head a couple years ago to
jay paul for
acting
as he did
so you have to act with speed
i mean
the old days when you had runs on banks
uh
back in the
19th century
you know a line formed
you know and the bank would go broke
but the fellow would pay out as slowly
as possible
you know hoping
something would happen the wells fargo
trucker
stagecoach would pull up a bunch of gold
or something and you'd sweet talk the
people into the line disbursing
uh
in omaha
in august of 1931
uh four state banks so-called state
banks they had a vote in that day
they closed and the national banks
didn't
but they were all broke as of that day
if they
no bank can pay off in one day all of
its liabilities but the federal reserve
is the only one that's good at that time
but i will tell you this berkshire
hathaway will be there
at that time we we run it
on the basis that
if
things just behave
slightly
very
if
hank paulson
george h.w bush or no george w bush i'm
sorry
and uh
then bernanke and a few people hadn't
taken action
we were
at that point where the line was
formed except it comes on electronic
funds they push buttons and
and uh
it's all over
uh
very fast uh if there's a run on the
bank
remember if you ever buy a bank and
there's two banks in town hire a few
extras and have them go over and start
standing in line at the other guy's bank
and there's only one problem with that
after a while somebody will stand in
front of your bank you know and then
both of you are gone but the federal
reserve is not gone
and the federal reserve
in the united states
can do
whatever is necessary they've got all
kinds of rules about
you can do this or that and this and
that and uh
and one time in the 1980s
paul volcker was a very honest man said
to me and
i said you know what are the limits of
of what you can do and he's
he
he was a very unusual guy and huge
looked down at me
said
we can do our whatever we
need to do
and and that's true and that's what
that's what happened in 2009 and that's
what happened in 2020
and
you'll hope it happens again next time
but you want to be
we want berkshire hathaway to
to be there and uh
uh in a position
to operate when
the
uh
if if the economy stops
and that can always happen that can
always happen some of those cheery words
um
let's see if we
i think
i think we can actually
might be a good idea
to start with some questions as i
said we will have
the questions
alternate
between
cnbc becky quick
and those are questions that have come
in from shareholders and they can be
directed to
any of the four of us
up here
and
and then we will
go
alternate and go around
the room here and we've got
we've got the auditorium
broken into
10 or 11
uh
sections
charlie and i one time figured out
about a form and
said
officers of the company
broken down by age and we we just put
all of us uh there's an answer to that
question but the uh but we'll have it
broken down by categories around here
and uh uh we'll keep alternating
and uh
we will uh
break for lunch
at uh
at noon and reconvene at one so let's
start off and
uh
becky will you lead the way
uh thanks warren the first question
comes from jack cesaleski and he says in
the
annual letter that you wrote in february
26 you mentioned that charlie and you
saw little that excites us in the market
yet around march 10th the deal for
allegheny was announced and then later
the occidental announcement then did the
disclosure of the hp investment his
question is what changed from the time
you dated the letter to the time the
investments were announced did the name
suddenly become interesting in the space
of a month and a half
or half a month well
charlie you want to give your version
i'll give my version my version would be
we found some things we preferred owning
to
treasury bills
and as usual charlie's given the total
answer but i'll talk longer and say less
uh
we um
actually the
uh
the letters dated february 26th where we
were confessing our
inability to find anything
uh which was a saturday but the day
before that
uh february 25th
i got a um
email
uh
actually
my
assistant
uh
uh debbie bosonic gets it because i
can't figure out quite how to
handle the machinery but so she she she
brought it in
and uh actually she puts a bunch on the
edge of her desk and i collect them
occasionally
and
there was a
a note
just a few lines long
from
a fellow that
that was a friend of mine and and that
worked for
berkshire than many years ago
and it's on february 25th day before the
and he said uh
he now become ceo of
allegheny corp i'd been following
allegheny court for 60 years i you know
i
but their annual reports i had four big
file doors full of it because it was an
interesting company and all companies
interested me
so
i i knew
i knew a lot about like any corvo from
and uh uh joe said you know this is my
first
annual reporter ceo
and
i just wanted to send it along to you
just like you
write for your sisters he says i write
this
i write this report as if i'm writing to
you
and
i sent a note back to joe
and i said
you know i'm going to read it
over the weekend or whatever i said do
them on it which was true i mean i look
forward to reading it and i said by the
way
i'm going to be in
new york on
on
march 7th and and uh
um
you know
come to get together uh i'd like to see
you
and i've got i think i may have said i
got an idea well i didn't have that idea
the day before i mean it just
this this thing happened to come in on
friday the 26th and
and
i knew i'd buy
allegheny the price and
and
if he hadn't sent me the no it never
would have
occurred to me to write him and say why
don't we get together on
on
on march 7th or anything of the sort it
would it just wouldn't have happened
except for the fact that joe
uh
wanted to send me along this annual
report that he just written so
that's that's the orderly and
uh decision making progress i didn't
call up investment packers and say you
know will you prepare me a report on
this and you know what's your advice and
listen i knew we'd buy allegania
at the price
we offered and
if it was of interest allegheny fine if
it wasn't but otherwise if that email
hadn't been sent we we would not have
made an offer for allegheny so
uh that uh give credit to the fact that
joe uh
had written the annual report and if he
centered
a week earlier
uh
well i was you know i wasn't gonna make
a special trip to new york but i wanted
to sit down with them and and tell them
what berkshire would do
but that explains 11 billion
and uh
what happened was that
a few stocks got very interesting to us
and we also
spent a lot of money at
what happened
the market
and this is
really important to understand
and
in the last couple of years
our market is probably it's always been
a combination of a casino and
uh
and when i talk about wall street i'm
talking about the whole capital
formation market
uh
but the and trading market etc but the
market
has been
extraordinary
sometimes it's
it's quite
investment oriented kind of like it
always you read about in the books and
everything uh
what
what capital markets are supposed to do
and you study it in school and all that
and other times it's it's it's
almost totally
uh a casino and uh it's a gambling
parlor and
that existed
to an extraordinary degree
uh
in the last couple years encouraged by
wall street because the money is in
the money is turn is in turning over
stocks i mean people say how wonderful
you've done if you bought berkshire in
in
1965 or something and held it but your
broker would starve to death i mean
it's
wall street makes money on
on
one way or another
catching the crumbs to fall off a table
of capitalism and
and and and and
and an incredible economy that
nobody could have ever dreamed of a
couple hundred years ago
but
that they don't make money unless people
do things
and that they get a piece of them
and
it's
it's uh
and they make a lot more money when
people are gambling than when they're
investing i mean
it's much better to have somebody that's
going to
trade 20 times a day
and
got all excited about just like paying
pulling the handle on the slot machine
you know that's who you
yeah you may not say that you would want
that person you'd like the other kind of
person too maybe but that's where you
make the money
and
the degree to which the market got
dominated by that is
showing on a
on a slide somewhere i have here
somewhere
yeah here's
on oxy
one
if you'll put up the oxy one
that shows
how we bought
what became
what we bought in two
weeks uh
they're about
of occidental petroleum
and you'll say well how can you buy 14
of a company
in two weeks
and it's more extreme than that
because if you look at the occidental
proxy
you'll see that
the standard names
blackrock
index funds
uh
state street index funds basically
vanguard index funds
and then one other firm dodging cox
if you take those four entities and
they're they're not they're not going to
buy and sell stock they may have got
their own little
rules so they've they owned 40 percent
of the
company roughly
those
four firms
and they didn't do anything during this
period so now you're down to sixty
percent
of the occidental petroleum company
that's even available or say well
occidental's been around for years and
years and years
big company and all kinds of things
and
with 60 of the stock outstanding
uh
i go in and tell mark millard this
fellow that
is um
30 feet away from miersel and i say in
the morning to him
you know
buy 20 and take blocks or whatever it
may be
and in two weeks
he buys fourteen percent of the fort
sixty percent
that's not investment i mean you're not
buying from it but
i find it just incredible
you wouldn't be able to do that with
berkshire i mean you can't
literally buy
you can say you want to buy 14 of the
company it's going to take you
a long long time
but
overwhelmingly
large companies
in america
uh
all of them
they became
they became poker chips and
people
were
buying and selling like three-day calls
or two-day calls and
the
the more people
times people pull the handle on the
machine the more
money the machine makes i mean it's very
clear
and
overwhelmingly i mean where did people
go the investors just
were sitting around
and
there weren't very many and the money
was being made
essentially by a bunch of people
gambling on things and that enabled us
in a two-week period
to buy 14
percent of a
of a business that's been around for
decades
and you'd try to imagine trying to buy
14 of the farms in two weeks
in this country or 14 of the apartment
houses or 14 of the auto dealerships or
just anything
uh
when already 40 were locked up some
other place
it is
it it defies anything that charlie and i
have seen and we've seen a lot uh but
i've never seen that percentage of the
american public
essentially it was a gambling borrower
and
and the people
that were making money were people that
worked with gamblers
and then
it defined very significantly
uh
a few weeks ago you can you can feel it
if you're if you're uh
if you're around
it uh
so
uh
when somebody
asks a very good question is
why weren't you doing anything on
february 20th and why were you doing it
on
uh
starting well in the case of occidental
on february 28th
uh
uh you know
it's because
things developed in a way
and in the case of occidental
specifically
uh
they'd had a
an analyst
uh
presentation of some
i don't know whether it's a quarterly
one or what it was exactly but i read it
over a weekend
and that was the weekend when the annual
report came on
i read it over a weekend
and what vicky olive was saying
ain't nothing but sense
and i decided that
that
it was a good place to put
berkshire's money and then i found out
in the ensuing two weeks
it was there in black and white there
was nothing mysterious about it but
but vicki was
was saying what
uh the company had gone through and
where it was now and what they put doing
the money and she'll do what she says
she doesn't know the price of oil
next year nobody does but
um we decided it made sense and
and
two weeks later we had
14 of them
of the company and and
we
also already had a preferred stock and
warrants
uh
and the story of the preferred stock is
we paid 10 billion at per second north
we paid 10 billion for it
and at the end of the march quarter of
we valued that 10 billion
uh for our
10 kill we valued it at
five and a half billion so we had a four
and a half billion
loss
and it would have uh
you know
the world changed oil sold for minus 37
a barrel
one day and uh
uh
now it's quite apparent i think that
that
we want
we're very happy we should be very happy
that
we can produce
11 million barrels
a day or something of the sort in the
united states rather than
being able to produce none
and having to find 11 million barrels a
day somewhere else in the world to take
care of
keeping the american industrial machine
working charlie have you got any
comments on that instant
something this crazy could have happened
well it happened
it's almost a mania
of speculation that we now have
we have computers
with algorithms trading against other
computers
we got
people know nothing about stocks being
advised by stock brokers who know even
less
i understand the commission though yeah
it's just it's just an incredible crazy
situation
and
it's weird that we ever got a system
where
all this
equivalent of the casino activity is all
mixed up with a lot of legitimate
long-term investment
i don't think any wise country would
have wanted
this outcome
why would you want
your
country's stocks to trade on a casino
basis to people who are just like the
people who play craps and
roulette in the casino
i think it's crazy but it happened
and it's respectable
not with me but with other people
yeah
and
look at look at what
the country i mean they formed the new
york stock exchange in 1792 under a
buttonwood tree
and
it really didn't seem like that was the
eureka moment in america but
just look what's happened
using the system
uh
for less than you know well
you know
three of my lifetimes i mean
it's unbelievable so
it
it's worked now maybe it's worked in
spite of itself maybe maybe with the
country but one way or another
america has worked
in an incredible map nobody could have
dreamt it nobody
uh you know they'd have hauled you away
if you said
you know in three lifetimes
you know that
that uh
you know this place where we're meeting
i mean uh
uh
it
became a state in 1867 that but
in
1789 and
he'd asked
ben franklin or somebody that was
walking out of the
constitutional convention you know is it
what do you think the prospects are for
nebraska
it's just it's unbelievable it's been
accomplished and it's been accomplished
uh
the people who encouraged the gambling
they would like to say it's been
accomplished because of the
of uh we've got these liquid markets and
all these wonderful things charlie would
probably say it's in spite of that who
knows
but uh the uh
hey
the answer is that uh
uh well there isn't an answer uh
the
uh
my wife
when they got married
april 19 1952
we got in my head's car
and we started driving west and we ended
up would do all over the west but one
night
we ended up in las vegas
and uh
there were three fellows out there
uh
eddie barrick and sam zigman
jackie going
and all three of these guys were from
omaha
and they'd bought
little pieces of the flamingo
bugsy signal that had his
career ended rather
abruptly uh a few years earlier
was a stray bullet undoubtedly
but
in fact there were probably five or six
spray bullets but in any event uh bugsy
was gone
and uh some people including three guys
from omaha
were in the group sam siegmund
lived about
two blocks from where i lived now and he
was stan lipsey's uncle stan lipsy ran
those of you follow berkshire and the
buffalo news and a partner for 40 or 50
years later on so all kinds of things
intersect but i walked into this
casino-aged
flamingo it's kind of a motel
arrangement
and i was
21 of them
and my bride was 19 and
i looked around the room
and
there were all of these people
and they were better dressed then it was
a more dignified group than perhaps
currently but
they had flown thousands of miles in
some cases
uh
you know in
in
planes that weren't as fast as the
current ones and were more expensive
probably on a per mile
basis adjusted and they'd gone to great
lengths
to come out
to do something that was mathematically
unintelligent they knew it was
unintelligent and i mean they couldn't
do it fast enough in terms of rolling
the dice you know and
trying to determine whether they were
hot or whatever they may be
and i looked around at that group
everybody there knew that they were
doing something was
mathematically dumb and they'd come
thousands of miles to do it and they
were
uh and
i said to them
my wife i said you know i'm going to get
rich i mean how can you miss
if people are willing to do this you
know this is this is
a land of opportunity well it's the way
it still is uh
you know and
the flamingo go to be much bigger and
and
and in omaha we're very proud of
jackie and things he only died a year
here two of us became
sort of the
uh the leader a spiritual leader
of vegas and
like i say sam segments
uh nephew
went on to save my
and charlie's investment that we made in
blue chip in the buffalo news
it's a very accidental society that
occurs but
there is nothing stranger
than
what has happened in
finance
on the other hand if you go back
perhaps the greatest
chapter
ever written
on on
the operation
of markets
particularly the stock market
is in a book
that
probably one of the most famous books in
economic history the general theory
written by john maynard keynes i think
is 1936
and i don't know whether this chapter i
think it's chapter 12 but whatever it is
he describes
what market's all about in 1936 and he
describes
something
in
beautiful prose
uh
that
explains why
uh the whole country
in march of this year was sitting around
trading occidental in some
crazy way that enabled us to buy
a quarter of what wasn't owned by
uh four other institutions that weren't
going to solve we're able to buy a
quarter of it
and
we could have bought a lot more i mean
it was it
you just wondered if there was anybody
that really
was thinking about investment if
going back to investing i mean investing
is laying out money now with the hope of
getting back more later on it's really
laying out purchasing power now without
getting more purchasing power back but
that's the reason you and you know
that's the way you learn in the
textbooks you defer consumption now so
you can consume more later on so they
can take care of your family but all
these things
about how
investment takes place
and that is what happens with farms i
mean that uh
somebody buys a farm and they
generally they hope to leave it with
their kids or they got it from their
parents and i mean they don't sit there
every day and
you know get quotes
15 times a day and say you know i'd like
to get a call i'd like to sell a put
you know on on a guy's farm next to me
and you can have a call on mine and then
i'll have something called a straddle or
a strangle or whatever it may be and
you know they just
they they they go about making the farm
worth
more money and
and they do the same thing if they got
an auto dealership and they do the same
thing you know if they've they've got an
apartment house they look for
for
proven track tenants all those kind of
things
and
um
what would it be 40 trillion at least
you know of
of the ownership of all of the american
business
people
and traders poker chips are
pulling the handle and
and they've got
they've got systems set up so that
if you want to buy a three-day call
on a stock
you can you can do it and they make more
money selling you calls and if you buy
stocks so they teach you about calls
nobody's going around selling calls on
farms or anything of the sort
but that's
that's why markets do crazy things and
occasionally
uh berkshire
uh gets a chance to do something
uh
and it's
it's
it's not because we're smart
it's because we're the only thing i'd
say we qualify on and sometimes i wonder
about that but i think we're sane you
know i mean that and and that's the main
main requirement in this business
and
anybody
charlie well i don't think we've ever
had anything quite like what we have now
in terms of
the volumes of pure gambling activities
that go on daily
and the people lathering the gamblers up
so they can brook them
and
it's not pretty
i don't find it
gets any glory for capitalism or
anything
anymore there's a bunch of people
throwing dice at the table what good
does that do the rest of the world
it's a great way to become rich don't
just figure out ways to insert yourself
into the system somehow
and
you know
jobs to some extent self-select
and
many years ago and and i've got all
kinds of friends in wall street not as
many as i had before i hadn't started
talking this way an hour or so but
but i really do i mean
people make
they let make lots of decisions in life
and the truth is that overall
the american system has worked extremely
well
it may be very unfair
in many ways
but it has produced incredible
difference in the goods and services
available to me
versus what
my grandfather had available you know
i do not want to go back to
pre-air conditioning and
and people pouring whiskey down me
whether while they drill my teeth or
something short or any i mean this this
is a lot better world
and
well i think we've made more
be because of the crazy gambling
i think it's made it easier for us net
over the decades we've been operating
well i mean
we've depended on it
yeah
i mean we depend on mispriced
businesses through a mechanism where
we're not responsible for the mispricing
of them and
overall
we we learned something a long time ago
that doesn't doesn't take a high iq
doesn't take anything it just takes the
right attitude
we may talk more about that later but i
think we ought to prove that we've got
an audience here by going to section one
good morning
my name is ole pollem i live in hanover
germany
this is my first time in omaha
my question is on berkshire buying
entire companies
outside the u.s
there were a few iska probably the first
one
luis in germany
my question is
would you only answer calls from them if
you're interested in
or would you
proactively
approach them if they would like to sell
their company
um
i would
we actually
made a few trips i think i made them and
maybe charlie won't you know i want them
we tried to stir up interest and all
that sort of thing
in berkshire
around the world with probably that 20
or 25 years ago uh
uh
during that period
that i showed you that burst of action
we had
we probably spent
we probably
would probably spend at least 5 billion
of that
uh
yeah it'd be pretty
in the area five billion of it we bought
the
three german securities
we bought two
ah
well we bought we bought one
japan we we rounded up on some some of
the holdings we already had there and uh
we would
we would love them
to buy but we
they don't think of us
as quickly there i mean i don't have
somebody that's going to send me an
email
about a company that i've been following
for 60 years and
and i know i can see him in new york and
you know i can name a number to him and
if he likes and take it to his board and
so on and
uh
it just doesn't happen that way we
haven't had that experience
in
well anywhere outside the united states
now you can say with 40 trillion here
you know
we should be able to find something here
a little closer to home uh but we don't
have any bias against doing we there's
there's uh
there are companies
you know we'd buy in 10 minutes if we
had somebody on the other end that could
do business in 10 minutes
it's much more complicated in certain
countries than in the united states
uh
to purchase businesses and uh
[Music]
there's certain rules but i would say
this
you know we got a call
whatever it was
many years ago on the uh
on on on
our
company in germany and and actually the
two
two fellows that run it are
probably here in the audience that
saw them yesterday and they're marvelous
and they run the business and
and
you know
they they they're just trustworthy as
all the pictures were up on the on on
the movie we showed uh
uh
uh before the meeting started here
you know we we
we
we have so much trouble finding good
ideas that we can't afford to ignore any
but they do have to be sizeable now i
mean there's there really isn't
there isn't a lot a lot of i love the
i love the operation we've bought in
germany and it's just a pleasure to be
associated with the
with with the
people there
i just wish we could add another zero to
all the figures it was a much larger
deal and it's not going to have an
economic impact on
berkshire but they love it they care
you can see it you can feel it
and
that's the kind of business we'd like to
have
and we're very happy we've got it in
berkshire but
we can't do it
one debt of
louis at a time
and we would never never
sell an operation like that
ever uh
uh i'm looking at you greg uh the
the
uh
you know but if we
if we get a call tomorrow
uh
and
we could make a deal
that involved
10 or 20 billion dollars it was in
germany or france or britain or japan or
name a whole country would do it
we bought the
interest in the
five leading trading companies in
japan
uh
a couple years ago and
and i rounded them up a little bit but i
told them originally we weren't going to
buy a lot with
we weren't going to change our positions
materially without their okay so
we actually i think
rounded the 5.85
based on the latest figures we had then
of all five of them
and that
put a good many
hundreds of millions or maybe a billion
or two
to work uh
so
we
will you know president kennedy said
well
pay any prize climb any hills you know
whatever it may be to find businesses
but
we actually prefer it when they fall
into our lap like getting a
letter from somebody and
and yeah from for a couple of years and
you know what you pay for the business
and you know if the
if the board of directors that company
regards it as attractive that
they'll be happy to buy and they know
you're going to show up at the closing
and that
you're not going to pile
debt on it or change things or
they've got an answer
uh
and then you have to see if they've got
the question in their mind is is
what's the best thing for
uh for allegheny corp and
in that case
we had 11 billion dollars less at the
end of the day at the end of the dinner
uh than we had at the start of the day
so it's opportunity can be any place
and
we do have
a terrific operation for example in in
israel made that just
terrific and and
and it's reason it's it's pretty good
size
uh
would be like to have another one like
it yeah i just don't know what the other
one is
charlie
well but think in the scheme of things
imagine buying in 60 billion dollars
worth of our own stock
we like the businesses
we like the price we're paying
no overhead
no cost no no
nothing just there's more interest in
what we already own
isn't that we're totally wasting our
time
yeah and if you look at it
there are you can read hundreds of
thousands maybe millions of words
written on stock repurchases and what
this is and what that is and all this
kind of
it's not very complicated
if you had a partner in a lemonade stand
and they wanted to
sell out
sell their interests or two partners and
want to want to sell their interest i
mean
and
the business had the money to buy it our
little lemonade stand and and they were
offering at a price that was
good for the other two people that are
going to remain
you'd buy them you'd buy it now
the thing that's fascinating to me
is
what you can accomplish
and still people don't pay any attention
to it
we owned
in 1998
it was more than 20 years ago
uh
we owned
about 150 million
i don't know whether they split whatever
it is if they've split adjusted but we
owned 150 million shares of american
express
uh
i think we bought our last share in 1998
or something like that
and we then owned
11.2 percent of the america's press
company wonderful company
and since then
they've sent us a check
every quarter is a dividend
so we've taken some cash a little bit as
they went along
and now we own
of american express
that's what's happened because they've
repurchased shares
that happens to work out extremely well
if they overpaid for the stock and
all that
doesn't solve every problem but it's a
wonderful thing
if you've got an asset you like
and they take your ownership and
interest up and like i say we we've gone
from 11.2
to 20
if you're using your american express
card
or whatever it may be twenty percent of
whatever earnings
our attribute level our interest and
they used to be eleven
point two percent and we've done it
without putting up any money
now imagine
imagine if you owned a farm
and you had
640 acres
and
you farmed it every year
and you made a little money on it
and
enjoyed farming and somehow
20 or so years later
it had turned into
1100 or 1200 acres i mean you'd say you
know how long has this been going on you
know why
what could possibly be you know is this
an american or whatever it may be i mean
is it you know sensible use to meet its
cost to capital blah blah blah blah blah
blah
and that if you do it at the right price
there's nothing better than buying in
your own business we own
i mentioned that use apple as an example
uh
of how our interest in apple
you know
every time a
company that earns
a hundred billion a year and now it
means that
our interest and it goes up a tenth of a
percent
you know we've added another 100 million
to earnings well i think i mean it takes
a lot of work
100 million earnings and
uh you know in the first quarter of the
they just reported
uh they're on a fiscal year but they
just reported their march quarter and
you know they earned more money and they
had
fewer shares outstanding and we actually
bought a little more apple
uh
in the first quarter so
we decided we wanted on
a greater interest
and on top of that we knew that we would
own an even greater interest if uh
they kept buying in their shares which
we didn't have any insider information
or anything but
certainly
would seem the way to bet and uh
you know
we feel better because we bought the
shares we bought in the market and we
feel
just just as good as the fact
by the fact they use their cash
to buy out some of the other people
it is the simplest thing in the world
and then i read all the stuff it is
unbelievable
uh i know people can't
figure out something that
you know if they owned a farm and the
guy next to him at a farm and somehow
you were getting more of his farmholds
without putting up any money while you
farm your own farm that
at least
if you know you're
using some of the earnings for that
you'd feel very good about it
but uh have you got any explanation for
it charlie
well i have
another thing that interests me in the
presidency we get all these
suggestions from index funds
a letter saying we the chairman and the
president of the chief executive of of
azer are the same person
and that they have some professor
somewhere that thinks that
american business would work better if
at a separate
if one could again sweat him in two and
have each half work
and
to me it's the most ridiculous criticism
i've ever heard it like
it would like odessas would come back
from winning the battle in troy and so
forth and some guy was saying i don't
like the way you were holding your spear
when you won that battle
that's some guy that's never run any
business it doesn't know anything
i don't think too much of this activity
[Music]
well let's see
somewhere in here
i may find it at some point but oh here
it is
uh
we wrote
we wrote in the annual report
that in the third paragraph
of a nine page report we said we're
going to treat everybody the same
you know
maybe a crazy concept we have but but we
really feel that somebody that gave us
our
their savings in
or 1970 or 1980
and just left them with us
and trusted us we feel that they're
entitled to the same
sort of respect and attention
that uh
somebody that
was accumulating like crazy assets under
management gets paid based on assets
under management that that
knows that they just need to have
policies that essentially are
popular in washington the only problem
the only threat they have really is that
washington sometimes says that you're
getting too damn big and we're going to
do something about you so they they try
to be very sure that they're doing
things that
people will share so
anyway i say well we're going to treat
you all alike we've got three million
people or shareholders out there we're
going to treat you all alike
and
on march 25th
uh
about a month after i wrote that letter
it's in the third paragraph you'd think
that they would get that far
that they they
they had
101 million b shares
now somebody ought to read to the third
paragraph but anyway we got a letter and
says we would like to meet
with you in advance of berkshire
hathaway's 2022 annual meeting of
shareholders to discuss berkshire
hathaway's
perspective uh on governance and
sustainability well i have written
probably more on that that's been
honestly written from by the guy that
runs the company but
why in hell would they think
that we should meet with them and not
you people all individually that come
here i mean
i i grew up in a very very very
republican household but i i feel like a
you know some raving populist or
something but i
i just can't imagine
uh
well anyway you've heard
and you know i
somebody something gets paid
to uh well there's a lot of people i'm
sure and public relations and they hire
advisors and advi because it looks
better if they have advisors to tell
them whether the chairman and the ceo
should be the same person or not and
those people get paid for it and then
they discuss it at the board meeting and
then
you know
in the end
believe me
if
if 90 of congress for some reason felt
it was better to have
the chairman of the ceo be the same
person the index funds would not be
writing those letters because all i have
to worry about is whether
for some reason people start wondering
why some
some
institution should have ten percent of
the votes in in every major corporation
in the country and
i like the idea of index funds
but
it is interesting to watch
where incentives
and bureaucracy and whatever it may be
lead people the guy that wrote me the
letter is probably a very nice guy i
haven't but you know that's his job and
uh
well anyway
they didn't get a special meeting and
you people are here and i we appreciate
the fact you're here
[Applause]
okay back to becky
this question's for ajit and greg it
comes from ben nall who's a shareholder
of 30 years he's a nebraska native and
he says he'll be attending the meeting
here today
bnsf and geico appear to be losing
ground to their two primary competitors
union pacific and progressive over the
past several years ups operating ratio
has been about 400 basis points better
than bnsfs and progressive has grown
faster while maintaining a lower
combined ratio than geico on an
operating basis ups precision scheduled
railroading and progressives telematics
appear to have jumped ahead of the
berkshire businesses he wants to know
what greg and ajit are doing to address
those business challenges
okay
thank you becky
let me just start by saying when we
think of bnsf we have an exceptional
franchise there and a great business
and
we do compete with other railways and
we're very well aware of how they
operate including their operating ratios
and and the metrics they operate to and
precision railroading and it's all part
of it
but what i would say
what i would share with is when i think
of bnsf we start with focusing on our
customer
understanding how we can best service
them and yes we want to do it in an
efficient effective way that delivers
great results back to our our
shareholders and and that will continue
to be our focus so yes we learn from all
the
uh metrics they report and how they
operate their their rail and we observe
it but i would put our team up right
beside them on on any operating day and
we're gonna we're gonna move our
our tra our rail cars as as well as any
other rail company in america and we're
gonna do it on behalf of our customers
so we're we're very proud but we're not
ignoring the fact that there's more to
be done
both operationally and and for our
customers so we'll continue to see
improvement there
we've got a great leadership team there
we've got a great employee group within
bnsf
and what i like is we're just going to
see long-term improvement there we have
a an exceptional intermodal franchise
out of the west it's it's
incredibly valuable to our shareholders
long-term our partners and that's what
our team has focused on building that
franchise out
so couldn't be more proud of where we're
at but we also know we have a a journey
ahead of us and we're going to continue
to get better and better greg if we
wherever the opportunity would you trade
our operation for theirs
never
and we love he knows a lot about it
fellow
we have a great we have a great
franchise and we have a great leadership
team running it so
well said charlie thank you
and i i just before i go to a gene and
greg
you know was
a major partner
uh for
20 years
uh
more or less since a little over that
since we
we bought the energy company and and
uh
his boss
was dave sokol and
and
the two of them i mean you know how to
run they knew how to run businesses i
mean
you know
it doesn't like
we don't
we we don't read what
other numbers are and all that but we we
uh we've got the perfect person
running in katy farmer we've got the
perfect person running
the nsf and yeah she'll do a great job
and
it
changing around the railroad
in various ways you know if you got 20
20 uh
one thousand or something miles of own
track and
all kinds of other it doesn't count
sightings double tracking and you've got
a lot of things to do from something
that
they started building
a couple hundred years ago and
and
you not quite a couple hundred but and
you can't
you can't move things around
easily and towns grow
you know when you came into omaha in
1862 well the railroad didn't even go
across the river i mean
that even though we'd become the a major
rail center for for the western the
opening to the west and
uh
it
we're going to be here 100 years from
now we will be an important a really
vital asset
of the country and it will be a very big
part very important part
of berkshire and
we will
take
what
is an incredible assemblage i think of
300 and some railroads or something i
get over time and
and
and uh you know
the trucks got laid
and the rocks laid out you know 150
years ago the world changes but you have
to we have to adapt to it but you don't
do it you don't put an order out to
change a thousand miles
now it's operated or anything of the
sort so we're running it
to have that asset
for berkshire shareholders and and
and
it will redundant
to the
down to the
to the um
the benefit of the
the country and we do it
well
no matter who ran it would be important
obviously enormously to the country and
the up will be here and and uh at that
time too and and
and uh
uh
it'll be a better railroad 100 years
from now than it is now
but i can't promise you what will happen
if
if if
we get flooding and something in the
next few months you know it it can
it can
wipe out a lot of the plans you have and
disrupt lots of lives and and disrupt
lots of shipments and
uh there's there are no magic wands and
in railroading to make great
great changes on the other hand you
ought to be working at it every day to
make it better
i forget how many bridges we have
but uh
some years ago
we were spending three or four billion
dollars a year on
capital expenditures a someone's i said
matt brown you know i said this is a lot
of money to spend you know keeping up
our railroad men
he said well we're gonna have to do that
more and so on and i said well
i said i can handle his phone not sure
charlie can i mean
i have to explain these numbers to him
so the next bridge they bought they
built they called the charles team
monger bridge so you can actually go see
our railroad has the charles d monger
bridge because
charlie charlie kind of was asking
similar questions
10 years ago
ajit
okay
thank you becky
there's no question that
the personal automobile insurance
business is a very competitive business
having said that both geico and
progressive are two very successful
competitors
in this segment
each one of them have their pluses and
minuses
but having said that there's no question
that more recently
progressive has done a much better job
than geico
as you point out both in terms of
margins and in terms of growth rate
there are a number of causes for that
but i think the biggest culprit as far
as geico is concerned and again you
rightly pointed out
is telematics
progressive has been on the telematics
bandwagon for i don't know more than 10
years probably closer to 20 years
geico until recently
wasn't involved in telematics and been
only the last two years that they've
made a very serious effort in terms of
making using telematics for segmentation
and for trying to match rate and risk
uh
it's a long journey but the journey has
started and the initial results have
promising
it'll take a while but my hope and
expectation is that
hopefully in the next year or two geico
will be in a position to catch up with
progressive in terms of telematics and
hopefully that will then translate into
both growth rate and margins
try you guys
it's very interesting i mean
the
the auto insurance industry is
is a fascinating one to study that in
that
the largest
auto insurance company now
and
we're talking
2022 and
uh
you know
i'd read ford
i mean it was 1903 you know or something
when
one
cars really got
started and
it wasn't too many years after that that
he
was turning out
two million cars a year imagine that you
know
one guy
that uh two million cars here's a lot of
cars so car insurance
uh became
very important
after hundreds of years of when
people thought about insurance it was
it was
it was ships of sea and
and uh
fire where they
have protective societies and
insurance is a product's been around a
long time
but auto insurance
uh
has been pretty much the same thing
since leo goodwin started geico in
in 1936
and
we came along with a good idea and lots
of big companies and all that but the
largest auto insurance company united
states
was started over
illinois but i didn't know anything
about insurance particularly
and it's a mutual company uh it's not
supposed to succeed in capitalism i mean
you know if you go to a business school
they teach you that only the
only because you have incentives and
compensation and
all kinds of things can companies
succeed
well
nobody's really gotten rich off state
farm they they sat there and they are
the largest insurance company
while
leo goodwin started 80 some years ago
and he probably wanted to get rich and
probably
probably uh
uh
a progressive
you know people wanted to get rich in
the travelers and
um
name off dozens and dozens of companies
and who wins
you know a mutual company in terms of
present size they still are the largest
company they have
believe out berkshire they got the
largest net worth by far i think they've
got 140 billion or something like that a
net worth
you know and progressive this
had a
very very very smart guy running it for
a very long period of time they've got
very smart people running it now
but but they have a net worth that's
one-sixth out of
what some people over in illinois that
nobody knows the name of
have after years they've had the time to
solve the same product and they
advertise like we spent two billion
dollars a year telling people the same
thing we've been telling them for
70 or 80 years you know
the policy doesn't change but when we
get all through state farms still
doing more business than anybody and it
it shouldn't exist under capitalism you
know
if you went there with a plan
to start a state farm today and have it
compete with progressive
you know
who would put up the capital i mean the
mutual company that you're not going to
get the profits from
it doesn't make any sense at all except
they've got 140 billion or something
like that of net worth
and
progressive i don't know what their net
worth is but
must be somewhere around
20 or so billion and i haven't looked
for a long time
their net worth in the first
incidentally i mean they
they
are very very very disciplined and
underwriting and of course
on the investment side
their net worth dropped in the first
quarter because they
they own a lot of bonds and they say
well
they would probably everybody insurance
business
would say that well we own bonds because
that's what people do
and here's half the business where you
do what people do and the other time
other half the business you spend all
kinds of time trying to analyze in every
and every county and every
every single
every single way you can segregate and
properly rape business and all of that
and uh
you know basically
uh
peter lewis
sat in my office 40 years ago yeah 40
years ago and
he's smart as hell and and you know this
guy was clearly going to be the a major
competitor of
berkshires and
and he knew insurance backwards and
forwards and and
very bright and everything but
he just
ignored the investment side
and that was
as important as
the underwriting side and and it is
interesting how organizations function
and uh
and have
what i would say are to some extent
blind spots
and of course charlie and i know we've
got all kinds of blind spots ourselves i
mean so we have to be kind of careful
criticizing other people for having them
but
it is
it
the the auto insurance business ought to
be
studied in business school because it
essentially refutes
so many of the things they're presently
teaching so
that's my suggestion today to business
schools okay
and thanks to g
you couldn't
ajit is responsible
for adding more value
to berkshire
than the total net worth
of progressiveness that's not to knock
progressive i'm just saying one guy
okay station two
hello warden and charlie it is great to
see you both and the wonderful berkshire
managers our thanks for everything that
you do
my name is rajiv agarwal and i am from
new jersey
my question is on market timing
you have always said that it is
impossible to time the markets yet if
you look at your track record you have
had amazing timings with some of your
key decisions
you got out of the stock markets in 1969
70.
you got back in 72 70 to 74 when the
markets were really cheap you did the
same thing in 87 99 2000 and today we
are sitting on a significant amount of
cash when the markets are going down my
question is
how do you time the big market moves so
well
uh
we'd like to offer you a job first
i was ticket
the uh
the interesting thing is
uh you know obviously
we have the faintest idea what the stock
market is going to do
when it opens on monday we never have
had we have never made
charlie and i
i don't think
in all the time we've worked together
and i'll tell you something later on
maybe about how
learning takes place but we have we have
never
uh
i don't think we've ever made a decision
that where either one of us
has
either said or been thinking
we should buy or sell based on what the
market is going to do no or
or for that matter
on on what the economy is going to do we
don't know
and the interesting thing is
uh
some sometimes i get some credit
someplace
for the fact that you know how wonderful
it was that
we were optimistic in
2008 and when everybody was down on
stocks and all that sort of thing
you know
we we we spent a big percentage of our
net worth at a very dumb time
and
i i shouldn't say we it's i
we spent about 15 or 16 billion dollars
which was a lot bigger to us then than
it is now
we spent in the last
few weeks
a period of three or four weeks
between
wrigley and
goldman sachs and general
at a terrible time
as it turned out i mean
i didn't think i didn't know it was
going to be a good time or a bad time
but it was a really dumb time
and i
wrote an article for the new york times
and by american and all these things
well
if i'd
had any sense of timing
and waited six months
until i think the law was in march
and in fact um i think i was on cnbc
maybe that day or something but
but uh
i totally missed
that opportunity i totally missed
you know in march of
of
2000 2020
uh
we
we have not been
good at timing we've
we've been reasonably good
at figuring out when we were getting
enough for our money and we hadn't had
no idea when we bought anything well we
always hoped it would go down for a
while so we could buy more and we hoped
even after we were done buying and ran
out of money that if it was cheap the
company would keep buying in effect
taking our interest up i mean
that's stuff you could you could learn
it in fourth grade
but
it's not what's taught in school and i
mean
so
never give us any credit
well actually give us all the credit i
mean go out and tell everybody how smart
we are but we aren't
they
we
[Music]
we haven't ever timed anything
we've never figured out
insights into the
economy when i was
when i was
about 11 years old march march 12th i
guess 1942 you know at march 11th
you know
i bought stock when the dow was 90.
it was 101 in the morning it was 99 at
the end of the day i think and uh you
know now it's
34 000 or
maybe it's a thousand less than it was
on thursday
but
i just
you know it's one decision
that
it's a good thing to own american
business
and
and you know if
the harvard endowment had come to see me
and
it's 11 year old
you know or
general motors pension fund or something
and they said well no but we have to
have a balance and we have to maybe have
sixty percent
and then we have to sit around every
three months and listen to a bunch of
managers
it was just done better if they'd just
taken some darts and
throwing them and
and just said
we're gonna be in america
50 years from now 100 years from now and
we'll do better than sex than
we will in bonds
it's it's it's amazing
how
hard people
make what a simple game as it is but of
course if
if they told everybody what a simple
game it was then
90 of the income or more of
of the people that
were speaking
uh
would disappear so there's really a
little too much of us to expect
of human nature that
people will explain why they really
aren't adding any value to what you can
do by yourself or actually you're
you
know i hate to use the example but it
you can't have monkeys throwing
throwing darts at them
at the page and
you know
take away the management fees and
everything i'll
i'll i'll i'll bet on the monkeys but
not
i don't consider them a superior species
and i don't want them to move next door
instead of my next-door neighbor or
anything but that is the way it's just
the way it has to be
charles you haven't cheerful to say
well frequently in
well the wealth advisory business the
way it used to be
you you go to your investment advisor
and say
what should i
do to protect myself for the future
and he says
why don't
you give me fifty thousand dollars in
your net worth now
that's my contribution to your future
it's a peculiar business
yeah it's a great place to go rich it's
still if you have
if you're if you have
a uh dishonored daughter that
that
really wants to make money
per point of iq and per erg of energy
and all of that
tell them go to
go to wall street i mean don't have
manner to the priesthood or anything i
mean
if that's what they
it self-selects
and
uh
it always will be the case i mean no
reason to spare about humanity because
they
behave
in their self-interest they may not
actually be behaving in their
self-interest over time but they uh
uh
you know are they happier who the hell
knows but
but if they just want to make money
but uh
well
people here in the auditorium saw
saw a little session from the solomon
uh
solomon uh
uh episode
and
jerry corrigan was then
the head of the new york fed
and
that same committee was grilling him
and they said
mr cor they were they were giving him a
hard time
and they said
uh
who was the highest they said something
does affect that who's the highest paid
or
uh guy at solomon last year and then
and uh i said well
he uh
yeah
and he named him he said
maybe he named him and
he said he got i forget why there's 20
million last year and we're talking 1991
now too he said they got 20 million
and uh
the guy says well how old is he
and he said well i think he's
corrigan's and somebody affected
he's he's um you know 26 or something
like that
and then corrigan couldn't resist saying
and he can't even throw a football
and the truth was you know now there's a
lot more money in throwing a football
out than there used to be that uh
uh
you know
one of my heroes was ted williamson
you know i think he was making
20 or 25 000 a year and
uh
you know just imagine today
some guy that bets 230 or 240 you know
and
he makes it to the bigs i mean
the money flows in and of course
those people
should sit down and thank the fact that
that the stadium that
could hold 30 or 40 000 people and was
the source of revenue for the people to
pay their paychecks
that stadium went from 30 to 40 000
because somebody
first invented television and they came
up with cable television and they came
up with pay and all that sort of thing
and nobody knows the names of those
people but capitalism is very very very
peculiar
in how it dishes out
rewards and
for a while it was better to be in wall
street than
be it
220 or 230 hit here and in the
in the bags
and uh
and
you know it is
now
reversed because
of the development of tv etc so
it's a crazy world
rewards
seem very very very very
capricious and they are
and they don't seem
any theologian or
or even to charlie and me in our spare
time and the whole thing seems kind of
crazy
but it's worked awfully well
and
even the people
who
don't take advantage get shortchanged by
the system are doing far far better than
if the system hadn't gotten changed
doesn't mean that it
doesn't mean that you
necessarily shouldn't work for change
but
you should recognize the limitations
of what you can do with humans i'll put
it that way
okay
charlie is there any
way you'd like to close the sermon
well i do think we have a very
interesting phenomenon
and
i would argue that in a lot of the
wealth advisory business
people are charging for
skill
and delivering closet and exercise
closet
indexing
in other words
nobody can stand being that different
from the crowd and results they're
afraid they'll lose their fees
so everybody does the same thing
it's it's mildly ridiculous
the world is mildly ridiculous
yeah
but as charlie pointed out in the movie
which
only people hear so i mean
that
before we were married
you know we tried to convince
uh
a couple young women that we were really
more attractive than we were i mean
you can't expect people not to behave
with their self-injured and that was
very important that
that uh
that
we didn't dispose all disclose all of
our weaknesses uh before the marriage so
we're trying to be a little better
yeah that may be we may fail a little
and
i don't know about you but i've slightly
improved since i was 17. well
[Applause]
well
that's that's a really interesting point
because
if
the fortune has just showered you with
all kinds of good things you ought to be
a better person in the second half of
your life than the first half i mean i
just really should not be asking too
much of people if they've if they've won
the ovarian lottery at all you know
they're born in the united states and
all kinds of good things have happened
to
uh
and you've had a chance
to see how stupid you were
in all kinds of things you did you know
why not have the second half of your
life
be better than the first half i mean is
it
and
i would say
working from a very low base but i mean
i
i'm not nearly
by any intelligence test or ability to
do anything
you know i haven't learned anything but
you do learn certain things only by
interacting with people
and you don't know when you're
two years old no matter how much you're
picking up
all kinds of
of knowledge from the world the learning
machine that's going on in a
two-year-old's head is just unbelievable
but
it's not the same
as having
30 or 40 years of experience with
actually how the human animal behaves
which is the you really
you know you're learning all the time
about it but that should make you
a better person
in the second half of your life in the
first segment i would say that
if you say you're a
better person in the second half and
i've got a reason to say it in the first
half you know forget about the first
half
enjoy the second half and
uh
i think both charlie and i've had the
luxury of
well they're living a long time so we
get to play what we would regard as the
the hopeful and respectable second half
ah
and
we have had enough sense
to
figure out well we figured out what
makes us happy
and we've gotten
somewhat more sensitive to what can make
other people unhappy and all that sort
of thing and
and i'd rather be judged by the second
half of my life than the first half
and so would charlie yeah of course
okay i'm very i don't even look at what
i did when i was young because it would
embarrass me
okay
uh any of you wish to quit charlie on
specifics can do so later
[Music]
[Laughter]
becky
uh this question is uh there's two part
question it's for warren and ajit on the
first player and for greg on the second
it comes from roger kleffman he says
several years ago mr buffett was quoted
that a nuclear attack is the greatest
risk to berkshire hathaway insurance
given the present circumstances
what would the fallout be on berkshire
hathaway insurance if a nuclear event
occurred in the populated world
and then secondly for greg
has berkshire hathaway energy suffered
any physical or cyber attacks and
irrespective of that has any special
hardening of security been put into
place
yeah
well the first half
every day since
since uh
august of 1945 every day
uh
and accelerating dramatically when a
second
large country
had the ability to
kill millions of people which has
been magnified by
the incredible factor that
through this that that
there is a risk
every day
it's a very very tiny risk
but as a jeep one anybody
at this table could tell you
if you
if you roll well they had they had some
they had a pair of dice out of the
desert inn in las vegas for a while
under a glass thing and some guy thrown
32 passes in a row and
i don't know what maybe the odds are
eight million to one against that or
four million
four billion won against it but uh you
know if you
if you just keep rolling the dice
you know everything will happen i mean
if it
get
330 million americans out tomorrow every
american says heads or tails uh
and they do it every day
after 10 days you know
you've got
330 000 of them that are
called the flip 10 times in a row and if
you do the 10 more days you've still got
a bunch of people who've done it 20
times in a row and
they really think they
learned how to control the flip well the
answer is the world is flipping a coin
every day as to whether
people who can
literally
destroy the planet as we know it you
know
we'll do it and
and unfortunately
the major problem is with people that
have
large stocks of
nuclear weapons and and uh
icbms
when they talk about
using tactile
nuclear weapons because
somebody will be upset because they're
losing a war i mean
does anybody think that
somebody's willing to kill
you know
hundreds of thousands of people with the
tactile weapons i mean why do they stop
but you know if they're
it
it is a very very very very
dangerous world and uh
and
we don't have any way of no protecting
there's no way it's a big nuclear attack
uh i know a man who said i know what i'm
gonna do if there's nuclear war
i'm gonna crawl under the table and kiss
my ass goodbye
well
yeah and charlie is in charge of lost
control at berkshire
[Laughter]
hey yeah
that we have no solution for it no we
don't and and there isn't any solution
for it
and uh
you know it's extraordinary when you
think about it
uh
in august
of 1939
september 1st is you all know hitler
moved into poland but nobody really knew
that much about it here i mean you know
the news you got you got from the
newsreel you went to because the theater
was air-conditioned you know or
something so
so if i went to the movies uh
what you wanted to do in the summer
because it was air-conditioned in
in august of
well september first in the case of
the actual movement into poland but but
uh
you know there was a few people on the
screen and some guy with an
authoritative voice
telling you the german forces are just
moved into
uh poem and
a picture of a few tanks maybe and
it was over in a minute now of course
all day every day you see
people dying who you
very much empathize with it could be you
instead of them and and
it's just so different but
in august of 1939
there was a letter sent
uh
to president roosevelt
about a month ahead of time
and why did he get that letter
he got the letter because hitler was so
anti-semitic basically drove all the
all the jews
that could
see it coming
out of germany and among them were
some great scientists
and uh
it little leo's lord it was
i think obviously from hungary but
somehow he
he got driven out einstein got driven
out
and uh
leo's so hard
lands and eventually
in the united states
and
he writes a letter
to tell
the president united states
franklin d roosevelt
that that the
the uh
there's a bunch of uranium moving
different ways or
whatever it may be i don't know anything
about physics zero i don't know what the
off and on signing up but in any event i
know what the letter did because he
writes a letter
and says uh
you know something big may happen in
physics and
in america better get to it first
but then he asked the problem how do i
get it to roosevelt
huh leo's a large who's he the president
of the united states
so he figures if he gets einstein
to go sign it
the president will pay attention he's
right so he goes and gets einstein
and the two of them send the letter
and they sent it to roosevelt and
they wouldn't necessarily have been in
the united states if it
you know literally
had a different
great it hadn't had the crazy views
about about jews basically and so anyway
uh
that letter went
and
we developed
uh the atom bomb
before anybody else did it was a very
very
fortunate development that uh
that uh
uh
that leo's a lard and einstein happened
to
end up in the united states rather than
perhaps be someplace else who knows
but the accidents
of history and the act there's going to
be more accidents in connection with
atomic weapons we you know we've come
close for
various times i mean
we had geese flying over
you know somewhere up north and
norad gets a crazy signal and
we've had wrong training tray tapes
placed when i'm at you know we're in the
soviet union or some you know
it looks like things are going on and
it's we can't do anything about it and
that is
one risk
that
berkshire absolutely has
no interest in even though you can say
everybody in the world should have an
interest but it doesn't do us any good
the feeling
doesn't do us any good to think about it
tom but that doesn't stop the fact
that there are
two powers in the world but
through miscalculation
uh of the other's intentions through all
kinds of things you know
i've come close
in the past and charlie and i lived
through the britain through the uh
to the uh cuban missile crisis and
you know
we
we knew there was some chance
that uh the
weapons of mass destruction would be
used and believe me there
that uh
there's a lot there's a lot more bad
that can happen and
humanity
has not
uh
really
come up with a counter force
to uh
technology i mean
look back in the caveman ages if you
were
a sociopath or something you threw a
rock at the guy in the next cave you
know or something i mean it was sort of
proportional to
uh
and and we kept developing then there
was this breakthrough where
technology is
totally outrun humanity
and we'll see whether
what happens but
so far so good and
berkshire does not have an answer though
we don't we don't know
there's certain things we don't write
policies on because
we wouldn't be able to make good on them
anyway you know for that
and everybody would know we wouldn't be
able to make good on them so
we're not
we
you have that risk and there's nothing
berserk
can protect you against uh
and uh
we've been very lucky so far
aj ever get any questions in terms of
in in addition to all what warren has
said in terms of the chance of something
like this happening
the additional thing that concerns me
about a nuclear situation
is
my my lack of ability to really estimate
what our real exposure is in the event
of a nuclear
event
when you're talking about you know other
big exposures we have earthquake in
hurricane and cyber
i can with some reasonable degree of
accuracy have a point of view in terms
of how large our exposures can be and
how big our laws can be
when it comes to a nuclear thing
you know i
i sort of surrender i you know it's very
difficult for us to estimate how bad bad
can be
very many different lines of exposures
will be affected by it
and even though in almost all our
contracts we try and exclude nuclear as
a covered peril
nevertheless if something like that were
to happen
i'm
i'm fairly positive that the regulators
and the courts
will hold it against the insurers
and we will be
and they'll rewrite the contract and
we'll be required to pay for example one
thing which is already being talked
about
uh
we issue what are called fire policies
and these fire policies try and exclude
nuclear as a covered peril
but there are several regulators who
feel
that gee if it's a fire policy and
if the nuclear attack causes a fire then
how can you exclude fire and you better
include fire so you know debates like
that we will have to live with and
it will be very difficult for the
insurance industry
to fight back both the regulators of the
court systems in terms of what is
covered and what is not covered
and there won't be any regulators or
anybody else
so
we'll leave it to
a million years of reconstruction
[Laughter]
einstein said that
he said i know not what
the uh
weapons will be
for world war iii but i know the weapons
for world war four will be sticks and
stones you know that um
there's a lot of things you know
but
i mean it just
if you're worried about
about the effect of
uh nuclear attacks
uh
and you've got other things to worry
about than the value of your berkshire
i'll put it that way
and and uh
what other cheerful things
ah
station um
would you want me to touch on the cyber
oh yeah sure yeah i'll just touch on the
on the cyber because it was raised and
when you do think of berkshire and and
they use berkshire hathaway energy as a
reference but uh cyber risk and managing
that risk both at berkshire really falls
across all of our subsidiaries and it's
a it's a constant risk that's there
it's one of our greatest risks we're
always evaluating and trying to
literally defend against and if we use
berkshire hathaway energy as an example
we would
receive billions of attacks every day
against our various operating systems so
that's basically what our team
is in place for both they harden the
assets to deflect it and then evaluating
the underlying attacks we have you know
every second of the every second of the
day
and and by the way that would uh we'd
have a number of operating subsidiaries
that experience that but obviously it's
the rail and the energy and a few others
that we we spend a lot of time on a lot
of effort a lot of resources and the
good news is that uh today that through
to today our teams have done an
exceptional job we really haven't had a
significant event we've had some minor
events at small businesses but across
our major businesses across our major
operating systems
we've had the proper security protocol
in place to avoid events
but it again it never stops our team
would tell you that every day that's uh
a risk they recognize and a risk they're
addressing within the within the
businesses so a significant risk but a
significant priority for all of our
operating teams
yeah and i would
i would add one thing i think
greg knows way more about this than i do
but my impression from everything i've
seen
is that
you always have you know historically
the
the uh
the private industry has always said the
government can't do anything right and
and government always says that private
industry is just thinking about itself
all these things uh the truth is
i think from everything i've seen
is that the cooperation between
government and business
in terms of
trying
to minimize the threat of
of
cyber problems i think has been
magnificent you know basically
yeah an excellent point when it comes to
cyber the collaboration between a
variety of u.s agencies and our
individual businesses it's incredibly
strong
including down to the uh certain
agencies we'll submit uh
basically a lot of our operating data on
an on a daily basis where they're
helping us go through it to identify if
we have
a bad character a bad individual who's
maybe penetrated into our system so it's
a it's a strong collaboration and
warning absolutely right it's uh it's
very unique to see how both the industry
and the government's working so closely
but i think we both recognize it as such
a such a significant risk we have to
stay strongly aligned on
uh on the approach
it's a real partnership it's a real
point
and
and we can do better because the
government is helping us and the
government can do better because we're
helping them and there's no lack of will
on
either side and and
i uh
cyber
cyber i mean it blows your mind on sort
of another the nuclear is the because
the number
ones but it's a very very very low
probability you know
someday the sun will burn out too you
know but but uh
that uh
it is
there's really no place
for two
countries
with large
icbm
possibilities and who knows what else
and everything but
though
we haven't figured that out yet
you know
it's easy to go around and say this is a
solution or that's the solution but
but uh
you know if you have two people
with loaded guns
facing each other and
you know
and not everybody is likely to be
totally rational
oh
well we see so much irrational
irrationality
in where people's self-interest is
involved
you know they're doing all kinds of
things
to destroy themselves in terms of how
they live their lives
and
you know
it doesn't stop with
as you move up the ladder
and
you know people
people
some people do terrible things
and
just help to
very much hope that they aren't in a
position where they can do it all by
themselves
with the rest of the world as their
was their supposed prize
okay
uh if state
station three will precess
something about
motherhood and apple pie or something
like that
okay dear mr buffett and mr munger my
name is daphne i'm from nyc
and this is my fifth annual shareholders
meeting
we appreciate you coming we do sincerely
as you know for the past four
consecutive months
we've been going through inflation with
an inflation weight north of seven
percent for the first time since 1982.
you both have experienced this before
from 1970 to 1975.
at a time where your portfolio took
paper losses
and yet you made some of the best
investment choices of your life
reflecting on that
my question is
if you had to pick one stock
to bet on
[Music]
you kind of snuck up on us there for a
second
and be resilient in the inflation
which would you choose
and what specifically enables that stock
to do
very well and might
very likely be
a difficult market
well i'll tell something even better
than that one stock
maybe we'll get to one stock but the
best thing you can do is to be
exceptionally good at something
if you're the best
if you're the best doctor in town if
you're the best lawyer in town if you're
the best whatever it may be
uh
you know no matter whether people are
paying you with a zillion dollars or
paying good
they're going to they're going to give
you some of what they produce
in exchange for what you deliver
and
if you've got it
and if
if you're the one they pick out
uh to do any particular activity
sing or
play baseball or
or
be their lawyer whatever it may be
whatever abilities you have can't be
taken away from you they can't actually
be inflated away from you somebody else
will give you some of the wheat they
produce or the cotton or whatever it may
be
and they will trade you for the skill
you have
so the best investment
by far is anything
that develops yourself
and again not taxed you know
so
that's what i would do
i got some advice for you too
[Laughter]
when you have your own retirement
account
and your friendly advisor suggests you
put all the money into bit to bitcoin
just say no
[Applause]
yeah
nobody can take away from you the talent
you have
i mean
and the truth is
that the world will always
be willing they'll need to do something
and some people will not have skills
and they will
get less of the product of the society
uh
than
somebody who has other skills and
sometimes that has something to do with
education but a good bit of the time it
doesn't have anything to do with
education i mean it
uh but
to figure out
figure out what you'd like to be
and figure out how
and what you'd like to be is what you're
going to likely be
good at and you know that
the world will
will always need somebody on that tube
to tell us what's going on so you know
study becky quick or somebody and
figure out you know what makes her good
and
uh
and what you sort of sort of naturally
bring to the game i mean i could have
who's the guy that says you got to spend
ten thousand hours doing this or that
and then that uh
uh malcolm gladwell malcolm glad
gladwell you know would say just spend
ten thousand hours on something well i
could have
spent ten thousand hours trying to
become
a heavyweight boxer
but
i don't think i just felt very good at
the end of the ten thousand hours i mean
it
you stumble in
to what you really
like
doing what you're good at
what's
is useful to society
and then it doesn't make any difference
whether the dollar bill
you know is now worth in terms of the
purchasing power
a cent or a half a cent or a hundred
percent
uh
if you're the best doctor in town you
know you will
they'll bring you chickens i mean
whatever they may do but
they can't take it away from you
and my guess is
that
uh
if you've come to five meetings you know
you've got a very good future ahead of
you i mean that that shows
it self-selects i mean
so
uh
if you want to sell a piece of yourself
you know that we'll buy that as the best
investment we can make we'll take 10 of
your future earnings
and we'll give you a cash payment now
and
you know
we'll we'll have a terrific asset
and you can have 100 of your future
earnings and if you make it
develop your tan
maybe you'll be a great dancer people
people pay money to watch great dancers
we had fetisher and
the sister of delta came from omaha you
know their name was australis then but
but they could dance
and uh
adele
did whatever she did with him moved to
england and fedester went on to
do a whole bunch of other things and
ginger rogers had to do it all the same
backwards in high heels and she didn't
get paid as much because she was a woman
but you're going to do just fine i bet a
lot of money on you
okay
becky
this question is for warren and aji
and it comes from someone named modi in
israel
who writes my family and i are long-term
shareholders of berkshire and we plan to
hold it forever we like that the current
management thinks in the long term to
increase shareholder intrinsic value but
we aren't sure that at the time of the
management change the new management
will act the same way you do
they might take risks in the insurance
field where it's hard to find on the
balance sheet and that might take years
to realize
we would like to know how we can assess
the insurance risk today and in the
future or to know in time when you and
ajit are not here anymore
well i would say that
the
future for
a long time
is about as assured as you can have in
the world we don't have an answer for
the nuclear problem or anything but we
have a culture
that
a is worked
b
has
the shares and the shareholders
uh
that
will carry it a long way
and
um you know the first year let's say i
die tomorrow the first year
you know everybody says you know what's
going to happen are they going to spend
all they can do all these things
you've got the shares
held in a place that it can't happen
you've got a
board of directors that understands that
our culture is 99.9 percent of
up running the business they don't think
that
having meetings of the committees and
bringing in
outside experts or anything like that
mean the thing i mean it's a process
that
that the world has adopted and
and they've done it for reasons we
understand
but
berger is just plain different we are a
business
that exists for people that trust us
and
all we have to do to fulfill that trust
is
fairly simple things
we've got the people do it we've got
unbelievable resources to do it
and it isn't that difficult
as long as you've got the freedom
essentially to do it
and
the world will write stories a year
after so a year later what has happened
very
you know
the rail will be run the same way then
the big the big worry of course is that
somebody comes in
figures they can make
billions of
as a group or you know people that
sell the businesses and say it's better
to be private because you know it's
better to be pure this or something like
that well
you know we're a pure partnership that's
what we're pure
and uh we do have
what we think
is a special relationship with our
owners and uh
i don't think the relationship changes
and the ownership doesn't change that
much and
true there's nobody can take us over
for a long long time and by that point
we would hope that maybe the superiority
of
this culture
might be somewhat better understood
uh by the world and
we will be here we have the same culture
we'll be here a hundred years from now
so maybe
you know we haven't had nuclear exchange
or something but that berkshire
is built forever there is no finish
point
yeah nobody's waiting to retire or have
their options vested or thinking about
we don't have anybody that's thinking
about should i take another job it just
doesn't
you know they're doing what they
want to do in life and it isn't because
you know we're topping somebody else's
offer or that
that that head hunters come around and
say
we want this person or that person and
what will it take to get them well they
can't get them i mean but
now
that's uh
i don't know whether we could build it
again but we've got it
and we didn't know we were building it
exactly when we
took over one
you know we had a lousy textile i mean
it wasn't like charlie and i
sat down and he but didn't happen to be
in berkshire but he was my partner and
everything and so we we were metal
partners and we didn't sit down and work
out some plan
that said well we'll run the dumb
textile business for 20 years and then
we'll finally have to fold it and then
we'll do this and that and everything we
just kept putting one foot in front of
the other
and but we did
we didn't know we did know how we felt
about the running a public company
and one thing we wanted to do always
was we wanted to have people that were
in sync with us we didn't really want
that group i saw in the flamingo
uh you know in 1952
we wanted people who trusted us and we
started
my case in a partnership we started with
seven charlie started a partnership
this is the same thing it was we didn't
go to institutions
and we didn't pay fees to people to
bring in money or anything like that we
sat down with people
my case i handed them a little sheet of
paper and it said the ground rules and i
i wanted to be sure we were on the same
page i said you don't have to read the
partnership agreement i mean there's no
way in the world i would be taking
advantage of it it shouldn't be here if
you think i'd think
but
i do want you to
i do want you to be
on the same page and measuring
me by the same yardsticks i measure
myself and
and
those people stayed with me and they're
still
sure they're their children their
children's children their shareholders
berkshire but they're partners and
and uh
it really
it'd be hard to
do that
again but i would do it with whatever if
i were going to be in this field i would
try and do the same thing i would try to
find people to trust me
and uh
i don't want to be with
people that are saying how'd you do
versus the s p
you know last month or
you know what's your long short position
or anything like that i
i i sold securities for three years
and
it just
i just didn't want to be in that
position where essentially they thought
maybe that
i could do things that i couldn't do so
i finally found a way to
get a few people i mean i didn't
actually stumble into it but a few
people that
that
trusted me and
they just gave me their money
and
we've lived happily ever after so
it's it's uh
the new management's got them
well
and the management after them and the
management after them
they're just
excuse me
they're just custodians
of a
a culture
that's embedded
the owners believe in it
people that work there believe in it
and
we're not saying
others other things can't do better or
anything short we're just saying this is
what we've got and
we have got the directors we've got the
share ownership and all of that
too
uh and the size
that essentially
can
ward off any
attempts to change the culture and
you know
it's silly to talk about
about if our board members did this and
did that and they
and in the end
uh
obviously we're always going to follow
the law and we're a delaware company we
follow delaware law
but that doesn't mean
that we have to do what every other
delaware corporation does and how they
look at the delaware statute that we
will follow the law and then we'll
we'll run it
as a group of people who trust us
and we appreciate that trust
charlie
well i remember when you had a textile
mill
and it can i try to forget it
the textiles
aren't really just congealed electricity
the way modern technology works
and the tdva rates were 60
lower than the rates in new england
it was an absolutely hopeless hand
and you had the sense to hold it
well 25 years later
well you didn't pour more money into it
no that's right and no i
recogni recognizing reality when it's
really awful
and taking appropriate action just
involves
often just the most elementary good
sense
how only how can you run a textile mill
in new england when your competitors are
paying way lower power rates
i'll tell you another problem with it no
i mean the fellow that
i put in to run it
was a really good guy
and i mean he was a hundred percent
honest with me in every way
and it was he was a decent
human being any new textiles
and uh they've been a jerk it would have
been a lot easier
uh
i would have probably thought
differently about it but
we just stumbled along for a while and
then
you know we got lucky that
jack greenwald decided to silence
insurance company and we did this and
that
uh but i even bought a second textile
company in new hampshire
i mean i don't know how many seven or
eight years later i mean
i'm going to talk something about dumb
decisions maybe maybe after lunch we'll
do it a little and
it
it is incredible
how many dumb decisions we made charlie
and i bought that
and sandy goddessman we bought that
department store
and that was
and
we were working with our own money
why in the world did we think
and charlie flew to baltimore and i mean
we used to really work in those days
and and
there again we had wonderful people
lewis cohen
could have been a better guy
but
everybody in that business
had a different reference point
you know they wanted to expand their
company well who can blame them for that
and you know they were planning the
couple of new stores and each department
the shoe department said well we'll do
it better this time and all that kind of
thing
but the whole idea was crazy and
and uh
we got there for a little while and we
figured it out
finally and uh
we reverse course
yeah
but why the hell did we do in the first
place
well because we were stupid yeah okay
well
that's important to realize we paid six
dollars a share for that stock
and uh
uh if the department store has succeeded
it might be worth you know thirty
dollars a share now and we do
and it failed so
we
but we did other things and we merged it
into berkshire and we'll talk about that
a little later
uh
and you know
i don't know whether it's
150 000 a year an hour or something like
that from the six bucks so if it
succeeded we would have made it
we would have maybe made a few dollars
and because it failed we made hundreds
of thousands of dollars per share
but that's the way life is
you just keep going
and yeah keep learning that's just keep
learning keep learning deep learning
and you can say why would it take guys
that long to learn
and uh
we only got a few minutes
before
lunch we should
let's address that problem because i did
bring something along on that
it
there have been
well i started buying socks
when i was 11.
i've been reading every book in the
library on it i loved it
my dad loved you know it was his
business and i get to go down his office
and read the books down there
and i saved the money and
finally
by the time i was 11 i could buy a stock
and i could tell you at that time
i went to nerd stock exchange when i was
nine
my dad took us new york each kid to
new york once uh and he took me
i went to new york stock exchange and i
was in the orbit i could tell you how
the specialist system worked in the odd
lot arrangements and
i could tell you
history of finance and
all of these things and then i then i
started i got very interested in
technical analysis and charted socks and
then
all kinds of crazy things
hours and hours and hours and and uh
and
saved money to buy other stocks
tried shorting and
and
i just did everything
and then
when i was
either 19 or 20 and i can't remember
exactly where i did it or something
uh
i picked up a book
someplace
it wasn't a textbook at school but it
was in lincoln
nebraska and i uh
you know i looked at this book and i saw
one paragraph
and it told me i'd been doing everything
wrong
i i just had the whole approach wrong i
thought
i thought i was in the business of
trying to pick stocks that would go up
and
in one paragraph
i i saw that that was
totally foolish and i left
i brought something that
it it's really interesting
let's put up uh
let's put up uh what do we call this
chart
i don't think we
well here we are yeah
let's put up
illusion uh
illusion one
done yeah there we have it
you know
now if you look at that
some people will see
two faces
some people will say a base
and some people will look a long time
and only see two faces
but
the mind flips
from one side to another
and that's
another thing some name for it that uh
they call it ambiguous illusions or
something of the sort
uh
there's other things
that talk about aha moments or
or
in the old comic strip
with popeye wimpy would have a little
balloon over his head and the light bulb
would go on there's this point
where all of a sudden
you see something you haven't seen well
it took me
i had an illusion
that i was
looking at we'll say in that one
two phases go to the let's go to the uh
one labeled two
and if you're
if you're looking at it from
one side you look it looks like a
rabbit and if you look the other way it
looks like it you're looking at a duck
and
you know
the mind is a very funny place
and
i think people call it
an appreceptive mass
when you have all kinds of things going
on in your mind
and
they're gone for years and they sit
there and get lost
and then
all of a sudden
you see something different
than what you were seeing before and it
took me in stocks which i was intensely
interested and i had a decent iq and i
was
reading and thinking and
you know and
it was important to me to make some
money on it every i had every every
motivation in the world
and then i read a chapter i read a
paragraph actually in
chapter eight i think it was of the
intelligent investor
and it just it told me that
i wasn't looking at the duck i was
looking you know now it was the rabbit
whatever it may be
and
whether you call it a light bulb whether
you call it
you know a moment of truth whatever it
may be
and that's happened
that happened to me in lincoln i mean it
changed my life if i hadn't read that
book i don't know how long i would have
gone on
looking for head and shoulders
formations and 200-day moving averages
and the other ratios and on a zillion
things and i love that kind of stuff
except it wasn't it was the wrong stuff
i was looking at
and
i've had that happen
and charlie's had it happened i'm sure
it happens a few times in your life
and
all of a sudden
you see something important
that why in the hell didn't i see this
in the first place maybe it's a week ago
maybe it's a year ago maybe it's five
years ago maybe it's maybe it's learning
how to get along with people you know i
mean whether
actually it's
it's better to be you know
kind or not you know or whether i mean
they're just
learning how
to have
if you want the world to love you what
you have to do or whatever
it's
you know what when you see it but you
didn't see it for 10 years before and i
don't know whether charlie's got some
thoughts on that or not but that's
happened
in a few situations
in business where i've looked at a
company for
for a decade and
and then there's something
that
it just all gets rearranged
in your mind and you
you know you can say well why didn't i
see this five years ago or
but
usually
i've i've had it happen a few times
obviously and and everybody here has
and just in different areas their lives
and
you think how could i have been so
stupid well that's what charlie's when
he was in the law practice
uh he had a partner
roy tolls and he every smart guy that
would get in trouble
usually with
it was guys and usually it was women and
and
you know
they'd come into the office and they'd
look
you know down faced and everything and
they'd say it seemed like a good idea at
the time you know i mean and and their
lives unraveled you know in many cases
uh
so there's
there is that
a perceptive mass that's
sitting in there inside somehow
and every now and then it produces
some insight it's better actually if it
produces insight into your behavior
than whether it produces insight to make
money i mean that
and
some people never get it
and they wonder why they're you know
whether their kids hate them or whether
there's nobody in the world that would
give a damn whether they
live or die in fact they prefer they die
because then they've been courting them
for their art collection or whatever it
may be it's
it's just
charlie would say you know
you know just write your obituary and
reverse engineer it
and
not a
not a crazy idea but charlie i don't
know what do you know about appreceptive
masses which
electrical illusions well
i know that that's the way the brain
works
and that it's easy to get it wrong
and part of the trick is to
get so you correct your own mistakes
and we've done a lot of that
yeah pretty much brilliantly frequently
way too late
yeah we've done better with the mistakes
than we have with the good reasonably
good ideas well it's so easy to overdo a
good idea
that's what's going on now you have a
lot of good ideas that are being grossly
overdone
well
just tell me tell me about one that
hasn't been but tell me later when the
crowd isn't listening
and well that's why well look what
happened to robin hood
parents peak to its trough
wasn't that pretty obvious that
something like that was going to happen
tell me again what robinhood when they
came out and went public and
alerted everybody in all the short-term
gambling and big commissions and
hidden kickbacks and so on and so on
it was disgusting
yeah
and it said so last year and they got
mad at you and they sold a bunch of
their stock and they got the money and
yeah but now they're it's unraveling
god and god is getting just but a lot of
the insiders have
gotten no but they've gotten a lot of
money from it i mean
they were big sellers as i remember that
maybe but
yeah there's a there's been some justice
well
yeah i have to agree with that
well it's a good idea to go around
making enemies with people though that
that's
another question which we
we do
is it wise is it wise to criticize
people at all
probably not but i can't help it
[Applause]
well
and here's the smartest guy i know when
he's 98 he hasn't figured it out yet so
give up
enjoy well with that we'll go to lunch
and we'll try to come back wiser
at one o'clock and thank you thank you
thank you
[Applause]
okay let's reconvene
uh
i think we sold uh
boats so far i was told that a while a
little while ago out there so get them
while they last we won't have the first
one available for delivery
for about a year but
but
people are getting 10 off
whatever that means
uh who order one and i've ordered one
myself
and we're uh
things are going well
in the other room and
we only got the
seven questions which is the new low in
the first half so we'll try and move a
little faster i can't imagine why it
went that slowly i mean
who's who's doing all that talking okay
station four
hi warren and charlie
i'm jeff mcmalloy
shareholder from san francisco
in recent years
american companies have taken on a more
active role in the political realm
whether it is speaking out against
specific bills
or promoting
various
social causes
often at the behest
of shareholder
or employee groups
while the goals of these movements
can be laudable
they risk alienating significant
portions
of customer
and employee
bases
how should ceos
decide
which issues to take a stand on
or whether their companies
should engage
in the political realm at all
thank you
that's a terrific question
and that is one obviously
i've had to think about
plenty
and at one point
i said i don't put my
citizenship in a blind trust
i want to take the job as ceo of
berkshire
but
i've also learned
that
you can make a whole lot more people
sustainably mad
than you can make temporarily happy
by speaking on any subject
and on certain subjects
they will
take it out on our companies and that
means that the people that
are employed by us
some of them we would end up letting go
it means that the shareholders get hurt
and
do i really think
that
so important that i
talk on every
possible subject that
people can get very upset about
whether
they should be asked to pay that price
and i've come to the conclusion the
answer is no why why in the world
do i want to hurt the people in that
other room
that
do all kinds of things for berkshire
why do i want to hurt
you
because
i say something that
20 percent of the country is going to
instantly disagree with and sometimes
they will be
so upset about it that they will try and
take it out
and
since they can't scream at me
they'll
they may have campaigns against their
companies or anything else so i
i think it
surprised to me
i'm not going to go around and and
uh take positions
where
instead of saying warren buffett says
uh it will be it will say
you know berkshire hathaway or warren
buffett berkshire hathaway i get
identified and i i do not want to make
the lives of you and
i just decided
i'm not going to
be doing that if i want to do that i
should
i should quit my job
and i think i'm
my
citizenship
speaking out is that important
i'll give up what i love the most which
is having this job i don't want to do
that so
i've
decidedly backed off i i don't want to
say anything that'll get attributed
basically to berkshire
uh
and have somebody else bear the
consequences of
of what i talk about and that
so that's where i stand and i can tell
you that
at most companies
or many doesn't sir but in a great many
companies
you know the ceos
uh
they have to think about what their
board says to them and they
they've
made a point
of electing people to their boards
because it's
socially acceptable who represent
different
uh consistency sometimes very strongly
and if they think they're stakeholders
for this group and that group and that
group
uh
they're gonna they'll get pressured by
their boards to take positions and
and
it's it it's just the territory that
that we don't
we're not going to get into it
charlie how do you feel about that
well
i even more than you i have to be very
careful about what i say
now
and the difference between the two of us
i can't resist saying a little more
[Laughter]
i see
headlines and papers just time after
time after time
to say
buffett's buying such and such well
i'm not buying such and such
berkshire hathaway is buying it and it
may be the work of two other people who
work at berkshire and that people who
write the articles don't have the
faintest idea whether it was maya
my
at my instigation or whether i'd even
ever heard of it
and uh
but the headline says
the headline will attract more people if
it says buffett buying this and if it
says
berkshire hathaway and we don't know
whether it's just the people that work
for him or him
the headline is designed to bring people
into the story so it's
it's
the confusion is
is terrible uh
and
the easiest thing to do is to um
basically
shut up and
and
not not have a bunch of people have
facing consequences that they didn't ask
for in the
in the first place so
uh with that
uh i'm glad you asked that question that
is a good question and i probably
thought more about that question than
i think about
whether this stock or that stock is
cheap
but
and with that we'll go to uh
let's see that was station four we'll go
back to becky
uh on that note let's go to a question
from david cass
he writes in president biden's fiscal
2023 budget request would impose a 20
minimum tax on the unrealized capital
gains for households worth at least 100
million dollars
what are your views on this issue and if
you don't want to answer maybe charlie
does
well we'll find out
i i and we should in all honesty we
would we should both say that we we
would be affected by if it's 100 million
we'd both be affected so our point of
view is
and
and i have no point of view charlie i i
have no uh
no no point of view that i would want to
attribute it to i tend to stay out of
the
income tax things like this my policy as
i pay whatever taxes they
they pass and i don't want to engage in
lobbying about taxes
yeah
we
and i would
add one thing
lobbying is really distasteful
uh
i once did it for a candidate
and i ended up
in a room with a bunch of
lobbyists for
cigarette companies they didn't care
about nebraska they didn't care about it
and they didn't mean they just they were
there because
uh they were handing over a contribution
they didn't and i was a convenient
uh accessory and and
you know it made you want to throw up
basically
on the other hand
we operate in the
railroad business
energy business
insurance business and they're
extensively
regulated and
i don't also
want to be the
only railroad that stays out of the
railroad group the only
only insurance company says insurance
groups you know other people can rightly
figure
that we're a free rider under those
circumstances so
i
i tell the
the managers generally
don't spend berkshire's money
on candidates that you like don't
pressure suppliers to do what i mean
berkshire is not a weapon
to use which and it's been used by
certain people in the organization but
don't don't use it to muscle money out
of anybody else for
who you like or what school your wife
went to or whatever it may be
and
some of it goes on anyway but
i
i don't tell our people
that don't belong to any trade
associations charlie wrote one of the
great letters of all time and if you go
to search
type in i think 1989
monger
savings alone or something
we resigned
from the u.s savings and loan league i
guess it was
and we warned them we said we just
cannot stand
you know what you're doing to the
country
and what a bunch of very nice people get
together
but they decide it's in the interest of
their savings alone didn't get through
this or that
and we warned them and finally charlie
wrote a letter which is like i say
available on search
and it's one of the
should be one of the proudest letters
certainly one of the proudest letters
has ever come out of berkshire and he
just said we can't stand it anymore
and we're resigning and
but that's that's a very tough thing to
do you can
you can't
it's it's it's a tough way to live just
around criticizing the people you work
with and the neighbors and
and they're perfectly decent people but
they're running into institutions that
are doing things that
are very
distasteful to them and
and
we
belong
support
uh some of our subsidiaries
uh
in energy and
and you know we
i don't want to find people who are
doing it for personal reasons i mean in
that case they're in trouble but i don't
say they can't do it because
i don't want their
hands tied if something comes up
and
essentially they're either their
competitors within the industry or the
industry versus this
uh
we're not gonna
stand alone and say well
we're morally superior to us so you put
your money up and buy it so that's
that's that's where i end up charlie
i've got nothing to add okay
never bothers me when i don't have
anything to add but he he seems stuck on
that and i
anyway
um
becky did that come from you it did yeah
okay then station five
oh
thank you warren and charlie my name is
hong yao
i'm from china and now studying in the
university of chicago
i really admire you too
especially charlie you are my adult
since i was a child
and my question is also for charlie
my question is
how to practice
the
multi-disciplinary framework
in making investment decisions
and in life
like how to make it more practical thank
you
charlie
well obviously it it
it helps you to know more than one
discipline
there's an old saying you know the man
who carries only a hammer thinks
everything else is a nail
and
if you make a lot of wrong decisions if
you don't have the
some command of all the disciplines
that's all i ever said
and
but you do irritate people terribly when
you come into their territory
you say i'm a multidisciplinary you're
the expert and i know better than you
they hate you for it
i contest to do it i've done it several
times
and
you know china
well
there's a certain degree in the cult
they have a culture that
that
to some extent
revere's age so charlie's got me beat
i don't even try and compete with him on
china
i can't catch him on age
okay
i'm gonna try to though
uh
let's see we've got becky coming next
this question comes from philip king
he writes in the 70s you wrote an
article entitled how inflation swindles
the equity investor you said that stocks
cannot keep pace with inflation because
companies cannot increase the return on
equity do you believe that this is still
the case
yeah and i
of course bonds can swindle the equity
investor to everything
inflation i should say swindle's the
bond investor too
and
they
it swindles a person who keeps their
cash under their mattress it swindles
almost everybody
and
um
the problem if you have a business that
doesn't take any capital
and
let's just say the
dollar depreciates 90 or something so
things cost 10 times as much it doesn't
take any capital you can charge 10 times
as much
and you've kept your
relative position but most businesses
take some capital
if our utility business
if
just say that
the dollar is
worth one tenth
uh
some years hence from now
we have to have 10 times the capital
investment basically and we get paid a
return on that but we have forced
capital investment
uh
to essentially keep them in the same
place and
uh
i wrote an article
that uh
related to that and
i will tell you a very one famous story
which you will all sympathize with
in that i wrote that story for fortune
and when i finished it
it was about seven thousand words
and fortune doesn't didn't like
publishing
seven thousand words and
they had my friend carol willis explain
that to me
knowing that i would pay more attention
to her than anybody else but
being stubborn and male i said
uh you know every word is precious then
they can either run it or not so then
they sent an editor a very nice guy out
to alma
and this guy explained to me that
this wasn't right to use that many words
and
i said well that's fine but
if you don't do it i'll write it
someplace else whatever you very
disgusting
behavior on my part and
then
i sent it
it was it was beginning to bother me a
little
so i sent it to my friend meg greenfield
and meg was a great great great editor
at the washington post and we were very
very good friends
wonderful woman
and
meg
who was tough as nails with most writers
but
she was kind of nice she was she didn't
want to really hurt me too much
so
she said i said well mate what do you
think
and she said well warren
she says you don't have to tell
everything you know in this article
and
it uh it made
it made the point and so i write that
letter i write that article shorter
and uh
but i'd say more or less the the same
thing no and
you're better off
if
if you really could have a totally
stable
unit of
of of of uh a monetary
use
uh
for the next hundred years
it would be
better better for
better for uh
business and investors in general
charlie
well
we will go to
station six
inflation inflation is
the question is how much and the
question is whether you can
you can decide that
two percent and keep it
the answer is nobody knows you know i
mean
you you do not know
and nobody
knows
you listen to all kinds of stuff but
they don't nobody knows what the
how much inflation there will be over
the next 10 years or 20 years or
or 50 years or next month and and people
talk about it all the time because
because you're interested in knowing the
answer to your question and they don't
know the answer but
but
there are a lot of people that will tell
you
they know the answer
if they
if you pay them enough
and other people that will tell you for
nothing because i think it enhances
their prestige and makes them more
valuable but the answer is they don't
know and we don't know either
the best protection against inflation
though still is your own
personal earning bar
if you if you play the violin very well
you will do reasonably well
during inflation i mean it's to play it
better than other people people will pay
you for
doing that if you
you know all kinds of things so your
skills
can't will not be taken away
and your money may be
okay station six
oh wait a second
was that
that's right is it becky next becky
it's station six yeah station six okay
my name is martin wigand i live in
nashville tennessee
mr buffett and mr munger
thank you for your lifetime of teachings
and for hosting us back in omaha this
year
well thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
you have mentioned that companies get
the shareholders they deserve
and in this year's letter
you mentioned a great satisfaction of
yours
is working for the individual
long-term
[Music]
shareholders with the growing influence
of institutional index funds
how can management teams
foster a shareholder culture
like the one we have at berkshire
thank you well fortunately we have it
and we know more about how to keep it
than to
to to
institute one and it's very interesting
uh
we have we have a million hundred and
seventy thousand
uh class a shares outstanding today
that's fewer than we had a year ago in
there
the those seats are filled i mean you
are
the shareholders in place
we like the group we have so why in the
world
when we got a fixed number of seats
which if we
should we go out and recruit other
people
to replace you yeah i mean the ideal
shareholder is the group serial group we
can have is the group we have today
and
why you know we had a church we'd want
the people to keep coming back week
after week after week if we had a
limited number of seats and we had some
wonderful parishioners
and
we would not go out and recruit another
50 or 100 of them and have to throw out
50 or 100 of the ones we already had
we've got
and
every company i know virtually you know
is wooing
new people to come in and whether
they're improving the group they get or
not
is another i mean
it strikes us
that's basically crazy we we don't want
anybody different
than we have now and
and uh
you know we're not going to get rid of
the index fund so
uh we have to get rid of
of people like you and we don't want to
get rid of people like you
and
i
i just don't understand why if you had a
neighborhood
and not and the size of the
terrain or whatever it was would be such
that you could have 10
neighbors and they were all great
neighbors
why in the world would you go out and
say
to a whole bunch of people going up down
the street you know why don't you buy
the house of the guy next to me you know
[Laughter]
it is it is weird but there's an awful
lot of people who make their living
by doing that and they never really
question them uh i would i would sort of
ask any companies making animals
uh
presentations every month or something
which of the present ones are you trying
to get rid of you know basically because
you're not gonna have more i hope you're
not gonna have more shares outstanding
at the end of the year than you have now
and and uh
am i supposed to
you know get out of the way so
some some other
fun that is thinking about what your
soccer is going to do next week replaces
me it is a very very very weird
situation and of course
the really
uh
crazy process
that has developed
is people talking
to we'll say
analyst group you know the
sort of the high priests of finance
you know
some companies are doing it more than
once a month
we'll just imagine
if you if you work for that company go
to work for that company
and
every month people are repeating these
things about their company that
it's important that we
have
more
services per customer it's 6.2 and we've
got to get the 7 or something like that
and they'd say that month after month
after months it becomes a catechism
and
ceo says it earth
his or her representative says it and
goes
how do you go on
the next month and say by the way
we were really wrong
and this is what we should be working on
you don't say that and it's a terrible
problem
the new ceo has
coming in
after a previous ceo as of the important
thing to do is to hit your earnings
targets well you know you have to he's
been meeting him
in all probability by cheating from some
time to time and this guy hands you the
baton
and
are you going to come out and say
well we've really been cheating a little
and it's really counter-productive to
the development of the company
you know companies not to make earnings
projections and just to give you the
results as they come rather than
than making up a few things
and the accounting department you know
they can't do it you can't it's not
human nature
and besides you wouldn't get a point as
a successor but you just don't go in
and
say
we've been perpetuating these myths
that we can always deliver eight percent
growth or we can do this or do that or
the most important thing is this you
can't go in and change that
if every month
you've been preaching to people that
this is what we stand for and just ask
another question and carry this message
out to the masses to the analysts and
all that
and it it's it's a totally destructive
uh
policy i mean i can
you know i can within
gap accounting
and uh
i i can play a lot of games with numbers
we have never
we've done a lot of dumb things at
berkshire
we have never
told anybody
that
the number had to be
this or that or to change anything i
mean it just
uh once you start it
it's all over you can't quit it's like
taking five dollars out of the cash
register
you know the first time you take the
five bucks out
you say well i'm going to put it back
and then
do it a few times and you all ever stop
in fact do it once and you probably
never stop but it
it's
if something is going to be destructive
the
thing to do is not start it
and
forecasting earnings i can't imagine
anything
more destructive i got 360 000 people
out there and they know whether i'm
lying or not good many of them
and they know if they send in figures
and they get changed
you know but what message are you
telling we've we've got one dramatic
illustration of that within
sure and
it
uh
it's it
it's just
you know we
we want to if you start lying you got a
big problem it's that simple and
uh and if you start
saying
to your
team that somehow you've got a job
you've got you've got
shareholder relations your job is to
go out and tell everybody that
our stock is the best thing among
thousands of choices to buy every day
well that's crazy and
and uh so what do you tell them well
they they try to
you know see which way the wind is
blowing and figure out what they have to
tell people and then they go out and
tell them and
and then if you're a human
and you've said we're going to earn
3.59 cents a share
you can get to 359 and get there quite a
while
and you know you can have all the
committee you have all these processes
but if you have
a culture
of lying
the processes really don't
they just
disappear but and
charlie and i have seen it
well every time we've gone on a board
trying to tell them about it
well
i think berkshire's
culture is going to last a long time
after we're gone
and
i think it should and i think it'll
prosper pretty well
the rest of corporate america is quite
different
and it gets
more different i think with each passing
decade
and it's getting very peculiar
pretty soon they're going to hold all
the shareholders meetings online and
and the shareholders won't even come and
it's just it's getting very peculiar and
the index funds get more and more
important in the voting and
it's like everything else in life it
changes and not always in ways you like
and it ends up for selecting different
ceos and all kinds of things i mean
you're not going to appoint a successor
ceo
that's going to come in and said
everything that's been done before has
you know it's been kind of fraudulent
you know i mean if we needed to book
books an extra sale after the end of the
quarter if we needed to adjust the
reserves and
it's just
it's
once you start lying it's all over and
uh
i just don't know any way around that
except to try every way you can
uh
to not you sure can't if you set the
wrong example at the top you got a real
problem
we don't we've never told
we never told anybody to change a figure
we never will
and
if they had been changing figures
you know we'd be in all kinds of trouble
because
they know it and i'd know it and
the next person would know it and it
just deteriorates and we've
we've we've really seen it
we've already seen it time after time
board
the way boards operate
um
you know it's it has to be process
oriented i mean i understand the
problems
that delaware has in writing a statute
that judges face when they look at
things
but
it's extraordinary
uh
it's just
extraordinary what
uh an emphasis
on process
can do to an organization because they
think they can do anything if
if it's
allowed and
you know eventually the foundation
crumbles um
okay
all right i should make a little news
here so
uh
you've come you've all come and
you may or may not see this
but it's very possible
one of the things we bought
one of things i bought
it was bought
for a different purpose by a different
manager months earlier
he bought
um roughly 15 million shares of
activision
and i never
paid i knew about the company but i
would just see it at the monthly report
but then on january i don't know 17th or
18th something like that microsoft
announced they were going to buy
activision for 95 a share
now when they announced that
at that point activision becomes
a different kind of security it becomes
what
charlie and i used to call
well everybody did
50 years ago
we call them workouts or something like
that and they become known as arbitrage
well they're not really arbitrage but
they're
their securities they're
those kinds of common stock
whose
value depends not on what the market
price does but whether a given corporate
event occurs an announced corporate
event occurs
well
microsoft wants to buy activision let's
say well they said at 95 a share
and they've got the money
and obviously mergers and big mergers
tech companies all kinds of things
have got all kinds of problems
uh
with the world generally in terms of
opinion
so
you don't know what the justice
department will do or you don't know
what the eu will do and all kinds of
things
but at that point it becomes a different
security
and charlie and i
uh 50 years ago we used to
do a lot of that sort of thing and uh
and we
and
dust levy did it at
goldman sachs and
we even went back one time i think on
british columbia power didn't we charlie
yeah
a guy named bennett was up there and we
were trying to figure out whether
some
some uh takeover
of the power business i mean we spent a
lot of time
analyzing the probabilities of announced
deals going through and we call them
workouts now the
term became arb
and it hasn't worked where overall too
well in recent years
now every now and then
i see something
that i want to do in that field
and but very seldom because
they got to be big
the profit is limited
you know if they say you're going to get
95 you're not going to get 96 and you
may the deal blows up you may have a
stock that's at 40 or something so it's
a but we did it with uh
monsanto
five or six years ago
uh when bear was buying it we got very
lucky because
it
turned out to be a terrible acquisition
for bear but but it it did go through
because bayer had the money and they
they went through the deal even though
monsanto
came with a problem that nobody uh
really understands to the
extent of
and we did it with red hat when
ibm bought it so
in any event
on september whatever i mean on january
whatever it was 17th 18th 19th
microsoft announces it
and the stock which had been that's 60.
let's see what it
i may have a slide here which i'll find
but in any of the stock which had been
in the 60s
uh
went up
to the 81 or two
and that looked like
not a big enough spread to me for a few
days and then to settle back a little so
anyway we now own
uh nine and a half percent not
something like nine and a half percent
of activision if we
went over 10
we would file a report so
uh
in order that the news people don't feel
that there's no news there i can tell
you that
as of
uh
yesterday we only about nine and a half
percent if we go past ten percent
there'll be a form file with the sec and
so on but it is it is a it is my
purchases
not the manager
who bought it some months ago
uh
and
if if the deal goes through we make some
money and if the deal doesn't go through
who knows what happens uh but that's
i just want to be sure that
if we do
file that report
people understand very clearly because
there's been some very mixed up stories
on that in the past uh we want to be
very clear that
that it was
warren buffett's decision in that
particular case
and uh
and he doesn't know what the justice
department's gonna do he doesn't know
what the eu is gonna do he never talked
to anybody microsoft about anything he's
just read a document he's made his own
assessment
and it can change
and uh
at
one time
i think we sold a few shares even
when i thought it was a little higher
than it should be and turned out those
sales were not bad sales
and so i just want to i want to create a
little news for you
and uh
i want to
if possible
head-off stories which have been
incorrect in the past
and which can then get picked up by
other media and corrections never get
written uh
that all the corrections were written by
uh one inaccurate story
and they apologized even to me uh
both the reporter and the ed and the
editor
sent me a personal
note of apology and they didn't expect
to make a mistake but
uh
but when the other publications
picked up the story
they didn't bother to pick up the
correction and
and millions of people
were misinformed and probably
uh
literally by the time it gets spread
around and
this one i will attempt to head off by
telling you exactly what the facts are
right now and we'll see whether we go
beyond 10
but if
you know it could easily be that it went
up a few dollars
it's still a 95 deal it's still
the we don't know what the justice
department will do we don't know what
but the the eu we don't know what 30
other jurisdictions we
will do one one thing we do know is
microsoft has the money so that takes
that one risk out of it
uh so anyway
charlie do you have any news to break
no
yeah and
and instantly i don't even i don't talk
this over with charlie i mean you know
he knows he knows what i
that occasionally i'll see an arbitrage
deal and do it
and
you know 50 years ago we were doing it
together and
his general feeling is why is warren
fooling around with this kind of stuff
even but but uh
um
it's
the old fire horse but
occasionally it looks like
the odds are in our favor but
absolutely we could lose money
on that company and uh
you know
fairly large sums of money depending on
what happened if the deal blows up
and there will be a lot of people that
want the deal to blow up
but microsoft doesn't want it to blow up
souls i have to see what happens okay
enough becky
um
you know charlie just mentioned index
funds and passing so let's go to this
question from matt feigel
his question is related to the growth of
passive investing through index funds
and etfs he says
passive investment vehicles now control
upwards of 50 of the united states stock
market the actual owners of these
passive investment vehicles decided
passive investing makes the most sense
for them
yet in doing so passive investors have
empowered the large index funds to
become the biggest activists in the
market
these passive managers now enjoy
enormous and i would argue undue
influence over corporate governance do
warren or charlie see any benefit or
logic to a rule that would prohibit
passive investment vehicle managers from
voting the shares they control for their
passive investment clients
well i'll take that
i think the guy's right i think any good
thing is out of control
and counterproductive
and
and uh
i don't think it's
good for the country to have
three passive investors with bright
young men from harvard or whatever
telling them what proper governance of
corporations is
it's not a good development
and it is and i think indexing if it
gets to 90 then it won't work very well
at all
but at the moment it's worked fine
um well the one you can count on too is
that if it does look like it's
going to
uh
if if the public opinion shifts over to
the idea that it really is a good idea
to let three people
decide the fate of every company in
corporate america
the three people
and they won't collaborate or do
anything they're
now they're evil people the least i mean
they're just doing what you and i would
do they would figure
we don't care that much about voting
what we do care about is getting a lot
of assets that are valuable so we'll
we'll figure out something that ends up
reflecting public opinion and then
politicians won't get mad at us and our
only threat really is the politicians
get mad at us and regulate us in some
ways so
we'll head it off
and i i would
predict fairly confidently that if the
american public doesn't like the idea of
three people controlling things the free
people
and their organizations and everything
but the three they're
what they want to do is they want to get
bigger
and they wouldn't be where they are in
life if they hadn't wanted to get bigger
those that don't happen by accident that
it doesn't mean it's the only thing they
want they want their investors to get
good results and everything but they are
certainly not going to follow a policy
which is going to cause a backlash
that
causes them to be a lot smaller then
they can figure out their self-interest
i mean
and it's and it just so happens that in
this case
it would achieve the right result which
is that they would not
control america but
the uh
they
they'll do what's good for themselves
and
and what they have to do
what's politically
acceptable
the only thing that really can mess up
what is a very good deal for them
is to have
congress change the rules and
and
rules were
the investment company act of 1940
really
changed how people
behaved and
and it's governed things
uh in a big way
for a very long time and and
uh
anybody that takes on the federal
government loses him and they're still
trying to do that sort of thing and they
don't need to do it and they just just
say well we'll
we'll give up voting or we'll vote our
shares as the rest of people do and of
course if you vote your shares of the
rest as the rest of the people do
then if the passive if the
if the index funds at 90 of the country
you could take take over a company by
uh somebody else buying three or four
percent because you'd automatically get
the
the funds to
follow your very small little percentage
you'll see it all play out i mean it's
it's not a
it's a big case but it's not an unusual
case
okay station seven
uh yeah
eric erda and i live in albuquerque new
mexico
so i wanna first say thank you so much
for a lifetime of knowledge you both
graciously shared with all of us
you've contributed greatly to push our
species forward
moreover you've taught all of us here
along with many many millions not here
how to behave more rationally
treat one another with more love
and lead more fulfilling lives and for
that i want to say a very a very sincere
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
as for my question i want to ask about
berkshire hathaway energy and the unique
structure that has evolved there given
that berkshire doesn't own one percent
of the company
the first part of that question
is related to greg's ownership and his
corresponding incentive alignment
with overall berkshire
now there's a wise man named charlie
that in 1995 at a speech to harvard
taught us how important incentives are
to human behavior
i would conservatively say that greg's
stake in bhe
is worth more than 500 million at
present and i'm curious if you if you
can share any plans that you have to
convert his berkshire hathaway and
energy ownership to berkshire stock
and if there isn't a plan to do this can
you please explain why we shouldn't be
concerned about greg's incentive
structure going forward
the second part is about leverage at the
entity you've always said that bhe
operates with an appropriate amount of
leverage given its earning power
with that said it's still a very very
large debt figure
in relation to current earnings
especially uh with what we have become
accustomed to at berkshire and i'm
curious if berkshire owned 100
of berkshire hathaway energy would you
still operate the business with the same
amount of leverage
okay
thank you the second the second part is
the easiest one to answer so i'll take
that and i'll throw the
first one back charlie
but the uh
uh berkshire hathaway energy actually
is
required
with its regulated utilities and it
basically started pretty much with
regulated utilities and
and still is
dominated by that and we're interested
in buying more regulated utilities
it's required
in different ways
by different states
and by different regulatory authorities
to have a large amount of debt because
the
regulatory authorities will say
in iowa
or to pick any state
uh the regulatory authorities are going
to say you can get that money cheaper
then you can get equity money
which historically has largely been
almost always been true and though they
say that since we're going
to allow you
every turn on
equity we'll say just pick a figure but
let's say they allow us to return on
equity of nine percent
and we can borrow a lot of capital
at three percent those they say it'll
result in higher rates to customers
if you use it put in all equity we would
love to have
all equity in in our utilities
uh but we wouldn't
the regulator wouldn't stand for it
because it would result in
under the
traditional system it would result in
higher prices to consumers so
that's built into the system and
uh
we would
well our regulator wouldn't allow us
uh essentially to get the same return on
equity and and
and
have an all-equity structure
uh
they and the answer is
you know
we
we put
well he actually saw in the in the film
earlier which the people that are
listening
were
hearing the webcast didn't see but but
just in iowa
you know we recently got approval
to spend
and a fraction billion dollars but but
they want us
iowa
has a history in like every other state
in the union
except nebraska which is all public
power
but
every private powers you know they have
a history
of wanting
x percent
to be
in in debt
they want you to raise a lot of money in
debt because it's cheaper
means cheaper
power for the consumer so
the answer
is if we owned 100 of berkshire
uh energy
we would be
we would absolutely be
following the same
we would be operating pursuant to what
the utility commissions tell us they
want us to do that they represent the
people of those states
now charlie do you
well the other one's simple too it's a
historical accident
it's not causing any big tension
or breaches of fiduciary
duty we had the same problem with walter
scott who was the director for years and
years known stock in the same company
also an historical accident
i just don't think it's a big problem at
all
i see no no behavior from greg ever that
isn't in the best interest of berkshire
yeah
and
we we've had various percentages of
berkshire hathaway energy
uh ever since we bought it
around 2000
and it happened
we were my
sister who's here we were at our house
and it was a party going on
and
20 or 30 probably 30 people
and waller said to me
if you've got a minute or two i'd like
to
talk to you about something we went in
the library or some place and walter
says you know
we've got this company and it doesn't
seem to fit the public mode very well
and
would you line would you want to buy in
go private i said sure
you know depends on the price
and
when we got back to omaha i was out on
the west coast we got back to omaha
and we met
with david sokol
who was the big holder aside from walter
and uh
um
we
agreed on a prize
and i remember walter saying to dave
don't negotiate with warren
he'll tell you he'll tell you to forget
it and he'll do something else and uh
uh
so
we bought it and at um
so it was
it was kind of a weird structure from
the start and we had a public utility
holding up any act deal with all kinds
of things
and
it's evolved
it now has
us with 91 roughly and it has
walder's estate and i don't know
where that goes and uh
uh
at all and walter never talked to me
about it and i never asked him about it
uh
but it's one way or another interests
connected with them
uh in the in the estate now
close to eight i guess
and and and and greg's got one and in
the e
you know from our standpoint
if we made a
a deal with
with
if they ever came to us
and the
sky that just wanted to do something
you know we'd
we'd say find one we'll do the same
thing
with greg if he wants someone he
probably wouldn't want to win i mean
but from our standpoint
i've never seen any decision remotely if
i thought
that would make a difference
you know he would not be
it just wouldn't be the right kind of
person to run
um berkshire and and
the problem of course is that
you've got lots of process that can be
involved with insiders and everything
and i've got no interest in as long as
i'm alive you know my interests are 100
with berkshire
and
the board
and probably and to some extent a little
relatively but they just say well if
warren thinks the deal's okay i must be
okay which is true
and
uh so i could make a deal
uh
with anybody and it doesn't get all
messed up with process but other than
that if i'm not around
you know the pressures are
the directors to do whatever the lawyers
tell them to do and the lawyers tell
them to do this and that and then they
want to bring in investment bankers to
make a value and the whole thing is a
game
from that point forward
and uh it's expensive it takes a lot of
time the people
so it would be better if it happened
while i'm
alive and around
but there's no reason
we'd rather have a hundred percent than
91 obviously because
more earnings for berkshire but there's
no reason to
try and do anything with either the
scott interests or or or greg unless
they want to do it and the logical thing
is if
if if anything happened with the scots
we'd certainly
offer to greg but that who knows what
happens in the future the one thing i
guarantee you berkshire hathaway holders
will never
be taken advantage of
and
you know you can
you can sue my estate or something like
that but
if anybody felt differently about that
it didn't going to happen
but
it's a lot easier
if it's done while i'm around actually
than if it's done later but i wish we
had 20 more
complex events just like it yeah
that's exactly true yeah
it's it's
it's an it's it's a it's a it's a
it's a perfectly logical question i mean
but
it uh it is not a problem
and
any answer that's arrived at
will be good for all concerned
and
right now i've got no
i've got no feeling that
that why do i have no
no knowledge at all of
um where the stock
that the scots have goes or what they
how they feel about it or anything and
and
and that's up to them
they're you know the water was our
partner and as far as we concerned we're
concerned we
treat anybody connected with them as our
partner and they know that
they don't have to worry about us taking
advantage of them and
and
we can understand what if they don't do
anything we can understand that if they
want to do something we can understand
that
it's a good question though thank you
okay becky
this question comes from steve blackmore
in bozeman montana
this is to charlie he says in the past
you've made favorable statements about
investing in china in part based upon
valuation metrics
what is your opinion now and how much
weight do you put on the actions of the
government in your analysis
do the recent communist party activities
in china including human rights
violations blatant cyber theft from u.s
companies and others crackdowns on
speech from business and media etc cause
you to change your opinion on investing
in china and how do you evaluate the
clear dangers of investing under
authoritarian regimes as recently
evidenced by russian atrocities in
ukraine
well those are good questions and
there's no question about the fact that
the government of china has worried the
investors
from the united states to invest in
china
more in recent
months and years than he
did in
earlier periods
so there's been some tension
and it's affected the prices of some of
the chinese stocks particularly enter
internet stocks
just in the last day or two the chinese
leader
as sort of reverse coursed on that and
said he went too far and he's gonna pull
way back and so on and so on
so we're having some hopeful signs
but yes there are more difficulties
investing i mean of
dealing with the regime in china than
there are in the united states
and it's different it's a long way away
and they have their own culture and
their own loyalties and so on and so on
and
the reason that i invested in china is i
could get so much more
so so much better companies
at this at so much lower prices and i
was willing to take a little political
risk
to get them to get into the better
companies the lower prices
other people might reach the opposite
conclusion and everybody is more worried
about
china now than they were two or three
years ago
so that's that's just the way it is
i have nothing to add
okay
[Applause]
station 8.
hi warren and charlie my name is tom
rindge i'm from wayne pennsylvania it's
great to be back here after two years
thank you very much
thanks for coming
in this year's letter you talked about
insurance float
the evolution of float
the per share float
the effect on repurchase
to increase the per-share float
and in
regard to the repurchase i would say
thank you as
your partner for your careful repurchase
as well as careful issuance of our
shares
um
my question is
about your expectation for the
likelihood that float will be stable
and the cost
will be zero or close to that over time
with
adverse years from time to time
what about
berkshire's insurance businesses
give you the confidence to make that
statement when your competitors are
trying to do the same thing
but haven't been able to come close to
achieving
berkshire's record in cost and growth of
float thank you yeah well they they
really aren't trying to do the same
thing which is kind of interesting
uh
the
um
the answer to your question
is
we wouldn't be in the business unless it
was my judgment
that
the likelihood
the weighted probabilities
are
higher
that
that the flow will be useful to us
rather than costly to us and
uh
nobody will know the answer to that for
a very long time
so far so good but but it is a judgment
and
absolutely i could be wrong about it but
you know the
the
i think both charlie and i would say
that
we think the odds are that
it's a winning bet and the odds are
pretty good and that we're
quite well positioned to do it
if anybody does it
but
you know did we know 9 11 was coming
here you know i mean
okay i mean
it is not a sure thing
just think of what the potential is
though when you're reviewing it
if we could buy common stocks we were
virtually sure would give us eight
percent after taxes
with our whole float that would be a
hell of a lot of money
billions i can tell you what it would be
and 100 or 12 billion yes it's an
enormous amount of money annually yes
and and the float has been growing
so
relax
we're glad to have the float
but charlie charlie's stuck in a couple
of this there if we could earn it and if
we could the answer is you know
that it's our job
and we think we can do it as well as
anybody or we wouldn't be doing it but
it's our job
to figure out what businesses
we want to be in and
and when they don't make sense
reluctantly occasionally to give up on
them like the textile business but
that those are the those are the hard
decisions and
and and insurance
didn't have the faintest idea
back in 1967
when jack ringwell stopped by the
opposite a quarter he stopped by at
about a quarter of 12
and charlie hydra set him up
and jack about once a year
he'd get mad at the regulators he just
didn't like being regulated and it
he'd say to himself you know i'm going
to sell this damn thing
and charlie caught him one day and he
he said jack was in the heat you know i
said bring him wrong so he came up and
quarter 12
and
jack
said he wanted to get rid of this damn
business the regulators were driving him
nuts or something i said fine i'll buy
it
and uh
i said what what price do you want and
he said
i think 50 a share then i said fine
we've done we've done it we don't we
don't need an audit we don't need
anything
and then jack started and he said well
he says
immediately he really changed his mind
but he was too honorable to back out so
he said well i suppose you'll want me to
sell you the agencies and i said
and of course if i'd said yes and then
he said well then we can't do it. so i
just said no yeah you keep him jacked
you know and he said i suppose you'll
want me to do this i said no no i won't
want you to do that he was hoping i
would just give him an out
but after after doing that for 15 or 20
minutes
he saw that i was going to read
everything he said and he said he'd sell
it to me at 50. so
he followed through and that was that
and
you know it's pure luck and now because
we really like our float don't we
barbie we really like our float oh yeah
we love it no we we we made the most of
it but we didn't make the most of it
till a gene came along
and
uh
you know
who knew that the guy was going to walk
into my office in 1986
and and uh
you know i would decide that
he was the guy to make this damn thing
work but i hadn't been able to make work
the way i wanted it to
and who knew that geico would come along
later and who knew it there's just all
kinds of things the one thing you have
to do
is be prepared
when opportunity comes you really do
have to just you just move
and
fortunately
i operate in an environment and i
wouldn't operate in any other
environment i get out of there but i
operate an environment where i can do it
and it'd be crazy of the board to say we
want to set up a committee
to
review every acquisition and all that
and i would say that that's fine but
you can work with somebody else because
i just don't like to go through all that
stuff
you know i've got other things to do the
rest of my life as a so it
there's so much
so much luck but there is that
you do have to be
mentally prepared and
to
do something when it makes sense and do
it big time and do it instantly and then
you got to be sure you've got the
resources to do it and i mean
the relative absence of bureaucracy at
berkshire unbelievable has made the
company a lot of extra money
for a very very long time
and it's made my life happier and yes
but that that that's ideal
um
but in the end
we are
extraordinarily well positioned
to do exactly what we want to do with
float while at the same time never
putting ourselves in the position never
coming close
to making a promise we can't keep
we had two
small
insurance subsidiaries
uh
before well before a jeep
the two companies i bought
one i really didn't know that much about
the other one i did it all by myself
uh
they were disasters
and left alone
which they could have been
they'd have gone bankrupt
and
we just didn't want to do it so
you know we
we
we could pay the liabilities
and if the parent company got involved
and or we put in another insurance
company or something
and we just we did it i mean it's uh
for sure
you know in a crazy way
i look i look at berkshire
as a painting
you know
and it's
it's unlimited in size it's got an
ever expanding canvas and i get to paint
when i want
and if somebody wants to paint something
else
then i'll go someplace and i'll get a
smaller little thing and i'll paint away
and
uh
you know
i
actually
you know i'm no good i don't know
anything about paintings take me to an
art museum and you know all everyone
knows where the men's room is but but it
it's you know i'm just not interested
and other people look at
pains
and they see something and then they see
something additionally later on
and i mean they really have a different
sort of perception
ability in relation to that and to me
berkshire's a painting and i get the
paint
and
you know the object
obviously i want my partners to come out
well with them but the real thing i i
like is the painting and
as long as you know it's in my head and
i see different things in it as i go
along and
and you know it's uh
it's you know the closest thing i can
come
to enjoying myself every minute of the
day and
it's not i don't prescribe it for other
people and
occasionally i
i'm not so occasionally i see things in
the painting you know i think well i
should have done that differently and go
back and paint it over and
uh
it's
it's satisfying
and
who knows why human beings react in that
matter but i i do know what makes me
happy and what doesn't make me happy
and
i found what makes me happy so why in
the world will i change it
so that's um
has a short answer to a question that i
can't remember what it was
okay uh
becky
this question comes from andrew kesau
from minneapolis minnesota he says last
year warren mentioned that inflation had
noticeably impacted the prices that
berkshire's businesses were paying and
charging
given those inflationary trends have
continued and in some cases accelerated
since last year's meeting could you
comment on how this particular
inflationary period ranks among previous
such periods in the united states like
the 1970s and 1980s and what can
american businesses and citizens do to
reduce the negative impacts that
inflation brings about
well we've sort of attacked them
what you do yourself and and
you know you develop skills that
that people are willing to pay for
in the future regardless of what
the unit of exchange is but uh
but
in terms of inflation in our own
businesses
it's extraordinary how much we've seen
you know
uh
the
i think you interviewed
irv blumpkin at the furniture mart and
for two years
uh
you know the prices have just
kept coming in higher for these things
and with
and
we sell them for higher prices and
people have more money than they've had
before
and uh
they like to buy and there are certain
things they can't buy it like during
world war two he had a lot of money
created and people couldn't buy cars and
they couldn't buy refrigerators and they
could couldn't even buy as much sugar or
coffee or things as they wanted they had
little stamps and gasoline and all kinds
of things
well
eventually
if you get a lot of money in people's
hands
and you don't have very many goods
prices go up now you can do all kinds of
things
to
you know
try and
talk it down and of course
inflation
is never the same
nothing in economics is the same the
second time after it happens in the
first because the first affects people's
attitudes in the second and this their
attitudes always influence the
the the activity itself i mean it is it
is an interesting
phenomena there are
people write a textbook and they've
really done it based on the last
experience and people read the textbooks
so they behave differently next time and
they then they wonder why they get
they're getting a different result when
they got the time before so anyway we
have
we have sent out
lots and lots and lots when i say we i
mean the united states government
we've
the government has sent out lots of
money to people
and at some point
you know that
the money can't be worth as much
as it was when there was less money out
here's an um there's an interesting
figure that i think probably will
astound you sounds me anyway
the federal reserve every thursday
puts out a balance sheet and the federal
reserve and
trader they're complicated institutions
but they do put out this kind of
consolidated statement of all the
various federal reserve banks all these
things that have entered into
legislation over the years and
and but there's a balance sheet
and
years ago roughly
um
if you look
you know the federal reserve
issues those
notes i talked about
uh
a while back
and uh
that's the one
there's the current one
and they print these pieces of paper
and
they one way or another
they got it on the hands of people well
the interesting thing is people said
cash is dead and all that sort of thing
you know cashless society
well
there were 800
billion go back 10 or 15 years but there
was about 800 billion of currency in
circulation and if you look at last
thursday's report
you'll see there's something like now
2.2
trillion dollars
of currency in circulation 2.2 trillion
now there's about um
there's
300. there's 300 there's 100
there's 330 million people in the united
states let's look at it that way
and with 330 million people
and you have
almost 2.3 trillion of currency in
circulation
that's 7 000
per person every man woman and child in
theory has seven thousand dollars
worth of currency well you know that
isn't
right but you but you do know that
the federal reserve's bookkeeping is
essentially right they've got that much
that's out there i don't know whether
where it is i mean i don't know whether
it's in
russia i don't know whether it's in
south america i don't know where
you know i don't know whether charlie's
got it all i mean
[Laughter]
it's
it's a staggering something you know
cash is dead and yet we on average have
seven thousand dollars for every person
in the united states
now
uh
while you're absorbing that
think for a moment
what would happen
if the u.s government
said
well they work it out in private
and
they decide that they're going to send
federal reserve
and i'm not going to blame the federal
reserve somebody back in washington
decides they're going to send out a
million dollars
to every household
in the united states
and
uh
there are
130 million households in the united
states or something like that you know
and
and they're gonna mail you a million
dollars in cash
and there were a couple provisions
attached to it
um
one is
if you talked about it in the next 30
days
the money disappeared
so
it was like in one of those old tv shows
or something and poof
disappears
and
uh after 30 days
uh
you could spend it
well
all of a sudden
you've
the household wealth of the united
states federal reserve puts out an
estimate
it's 130 trillion or something like that
so basically you've doubled the
household wealth
and
all you've done is mail out
people
but then you don't tell them you're
doing it with everybody you just say
they won the lottery or whatever it may
be
and now you've got an amount equal to
household wealth
uh that
on average people have doubled it
they've got they've got this extra 130
um
trillion of wealth and uh
in a month i can spend it well what's
going to happen
well
that
prices are going to go up but they're
going to go up immediately you know
uh
well you don't know the other guy got it
you just know you've got it
so you don't really feel like you gotta
rush out and buy things but as soon as
word gets around
what we've mailed out
if you look at
the
amount we've distributed the federal
government
i'm going to talk about i'm just talking
about the distribution of resources
we're talking numbers like that and and
it affects prices it has to effect
prices
and they had 10 times as much
if you want a home and you find out 10
times the net worth you had yesterday
but everybody else did the same thing it
doesn't increase the amount of
bread in the economy or the number of
cars that
it just means that the price
the value of this is going to go down
and
and uh and and it's purchasing power you
can't buy more than exists so
it's a very
strange period where we had lots of
money
sent out to people
one way or another we're getting it that
that
they didn't find as many place things to
buy
as before and we had supply chains we
have all these things happen but the end
of it is they go out to the nebraska
furniture market and they start buying
things
and they do it with our other companies
and they do it
uh in very peculiar ways
and
now they're buying
i mean one thing
you know
jewelry stores were
generally speaking not a very good
business and
and two years ago
every landlord that had a
jewelry
store
or multiple jewelry stores in their mall
you know was wondering how they were
going to get their rent
and
now
every jewelry store virtually is
is doing
incredibly better than they ever dreamt
with way less inventory because people
are just come in and buy
and they don't wait for sales
you know when they walk in the store
they're going to walk out and they're
going to bought something
and
they pay for it they got the money
so
we are seeing
an unleashing
of the fact that we've just mailed a lot
of money to people one way or another
it's very indirect and it all gets
complicated when we talk about a big
system but this is what's happened
and uh
i will guarantee you that
if we just
if we mail out a million
dollars to every household in the united
states tonight
and you don't know that it's happened
you
you know
you don't really expect much
to happen in behavior tomorrow but
somehow at some point and then if you
start doing it every month you will say
and people really know you're doing it
then they start anticipating and buying
at a time and forward i mean there's a
million things that happen in economics
but the
the answer is we've had a lot of
inflation and it was almost impossible
not to have if you're going to mail out
the kind of money we've built up
and
it's probably a good thing we did it in
fact i think
there was
one point when the
federal reserve
which in fact creates the money
uh the
if they hadn't done it
their lives would be a lot worse a whole
lot worse
now and that was an important decision
and uh
that's the way that
that's the uh
that's why you've had inflation and
heaven knows i mean
it could end
you can throw the country into recession
you can do all kinds of things the
country's going to have recessions
incidentally and it's going to have
depressions periodically and
things don't
things will happen differently and
you'll read a newspaper today and wonder
a year from now why was i reading the
newspaper a year ago i mean it it it's
it's just the way it works i mean when i
bought the
first stock in 1942 did i know
everything was going to happen
afterwards of course not i didn't know a
damn thing
but uh i just needed to have one idea
and that idea wasn't really well formed
it was just
it was just probably the way partly
every kid
fell about the country
when we just gone into a war you know
we thought america was going to win and
america was going to win then it was
going to win
just generally and
and
savings bonds were
paying 2.9 percent i learned that
because we we bought them they called
them war bonds originally and they
called them to the fed response and they
called them savings bonds but they were
the same thing
and uh
it's
you print loads of money and money is
going to be worthless not worthless i
got in trouble doing that one time with
cnbc because i said it was going to be
worth separately less but got contracted
down to worthless
so i i took me a few years to learn
to separate those words somehow uh
anyway
that's everything i know about economics
and more and charlotte can probably
improve on it
well it happened on a scale of stem
we've never seen before
those checks that were just mailed out
to everybody who claimed to have a
business and claim to have employees
they
they probably drowned the country in
money for a while and as you say they
probably had to do it but it it was
something that had never been done on
that scale before
but we had a problem we hadn't had
before yes no i'm not i'm i'm not saying
it wasn't a good idea
i mean
in my book jay paul's a hero i mean it's
very simple i mean
he did what he had to do
you know when when uh
if he had done nothing
it would be i mean he would be
uh you know
be very easy to engage in what you would
call thumb sucking then
and plenty of
i shouldn't say plenty of but there are
other fed chairman that would have been
sucking their thumbs
and
the world would have fallen around them
and nobody would have exactly blamed
them they would have blamed the the
virus and the chinese and all kinds of
things well the really interesting
company is japan where they
first they buy back all the debt and
they start buying back all the common
stocks now that's really weird
and what did they get 25 years of stasis
who would have predicted that
well nobody preached with anything i
mean
there's nobody's predictions that we're
interested in including our own i mean
it's very simple
what we do know
is that
we can
we can we can deserve your trust
uh
and there's no reason to do things that
don't deserve it
and
we can't tell what
but basically we think
we're trying to build a berkshire that
cannot
can't withstand a nuclear exchange
but it can withstand
just about
withstand as much as then
anything we can
that
we can do anything about and
and
that leaves us feeling good it doesn't
leave us feeling perfect that we'd like
to even promise you more than that but
we can't promise more than that so it's
very simple but uh
uh
and with that we'll move on to
18.
let's see that's
station nine
dear mr buffett and mr monger i'm ili
abushakra from montreal canada i would
like to thank you for everything you've
done for us your fellow shareholder
my question is regarding the gaap rules
if you were to change it what would you
change and what it would look like
thank you
well i would resign the job what would
you do charlie
now it's an impossible problem
because
first of all you have to decide whether
what gap is supposed to reflect
and it doesn't reflect value
but in certain cases of course it is
important to say that this is value and
so on i mean it is
it's
it's it's a convention
and
it is
done
so that
the auditor
generally is protected because otherwise
everybody sues everybody in this country
for anything
and it's designed
to uh
cause people
who want to report a given amount of
whatever is desired by the market
to largely be able to do it i and i i
don't know how i would write the rules i
mean i've watched
people
who
i would be delighted to have lived next
to me
you know if i was going away for two
weeks and my kids were
to stay at somebody's house it'd be fine
with me if they
they stayed there
if i lost my wallet someplace and they
found it they'd they'd return it to me
but they play it they'd play games with
any number that came to him
and of course
it's a very awkward thing to be
on the
audit committee of a company where
people are playing around with the
numbers and and that
and they don't want you if you raise a
stink you've got all kinds of problems
and i actually wrote something
some years ago
up for
i was kind of anticipating your question
about 15 years ago i guess and i uh
i wrote four suggestions
for questions to be asked
of the audit committee
and uh i don't know whether i was on the
audit committee then of course but
anyway let me just clear to me what was
what was happening but you had to you
really had to follow the charader you
got in all kinds of trouble for doing
that too
and so uh i just put four questions out
that
that i would want to know
and they were perfectly logical
questions and
and then nobody adopted them i mean
it
the system was fine as it was the
auditors got sued but not that often and
and uh the sec had lots of rules and i
admired the sec enormously i think i
think the country is better off because
the fcc but
but it is a hopeless question as a
question or problem
to
devise rules that
that
people can't get around i mean it's uh
it's
it's not
i think it was who was it that uh
my friend that was a writer said it's
not the
it's not the
illegal things that are outrageous it's
the legal things
uh it's just
it's very hard
you try and it's worthwhile you need an
sec but
the sec
can't really stop the stuff that
that
you know
you would find outrageous
now
that
explain then the auditors have the same
the same question i mean the auditors
uh
really want to they want rules and they
want processes and they want it to be so
they can operate charlie found a
he was on the audit committee of
solomon
and
we had
probably literally millions of contracts
where people put numbers in
and uh
and he found that 20 million we had the
largest
auditing firm in the country that arthur
anderson as i remembered they're gone
now yeah they're gone now but they were
but they were the largest
and charlie found a 20 million dollar
error i think one type of they call it a
plug
when your accountant starts talking
about a plug it's not good
well i'll tell you a story i haven't
told before
you saw in that movie people over here
saw me testify
in august
before
a subcommittee
who were out to
you know
get their way
and
and uh
uh
and i
i just decided i was just gonna answer
every question honestly and i was not
gonna try and draw up anything
so i just sat in front of him and uh
and said well i knew it didn't know
and one of the things i said which was
absolutely true
is that
i'd only been there
10 days or so with solomon but i said i
really haven't seen anything yet
that
strikes me as
terrible and
accounting
uh but i've been there 10 days but but
but this guy who
got us in all this trouble so far he's
the only thing i found i don't know what
else was going to be found how in the
hell could i know
what to go on in a place that was doing
you know incredible numbers of
transactions and everything well
uh
but i said you know what i've seen
the accounting strikes me as as legit
uh
about a month later i was so happy i
testified earlier not later
uh
a very fine
cfo
and these are decent people they're very
decent people
and he comes in and he said
warren there's there's probably
something you should know
and i said well what's that he said well
12 years earlier or whatever it was
solomon merged with fiverr which was a
huge trading company solomon was a huge
investment banking company it became a
huge powerhouse
and he said
12 years ago when we merged with him
uh
we sort of couldn't find
exactly
they were on a trade basis and we were
on a settlement basis and
and they said we've never really figured
out how to put the books together this
is the largest
uh audit company in
the united states arthur anderson that's
responsible for signing this thing so we
have this number
and every day it moves around and it's
just put in there to make assets equal
liabilities
and and you know today it's 173 million
four hundred and twelve thousand you
know it's not a penny and tomorrow it'll
be something different you know
and i thought to myself i am sure glad i
tested my work congress a month ago and
i did not know then but uh if they ever
asked ask me again
i'm gonna
i'm gonna tell them exactly what
happened we just got this number that
floats around every every day
and we haven't found it in 12 years and
arthur anderson doesn't know where it is
and
you know
you got to make the assets equal to
liabilities right so what else do you do
and that's exactly what happened
and
strange things happen in this world
there's one i think my name was the
floating plug
yeah
yeah and charlie's on the audit
committee now
yeah the one thing i've always suggested
nobody ever wants to do this and i can
understand why
but you've got
trillions
of dollars worth of contracts and
everything
that people are putting down little
numbers for every day
at banks and investment banks and all
over the world i mean commodity traders
and at berkshire we we stick down
something you know there's certain
hedging that even the regulators want us
to do in terms of giving utilities and
we put a little number in
and
i've
i've made the suggestion once or twice
that
if you really want to do something sort
of interesting
you know just get some young guy
that
uh give him a couple of weeks
and pick the
100 most
kind of complicated
long-term
you know
lots of wording
derivative contracts
and look at what one side
who promises to do something
values of that and look at what's the
other side who also reports um and and
just let them do it for a hundred
operations that random i just like to
know if somebody's valuing some we're
buying a contract with 28 million the
other guy's valuing it at 33 million you
know and you've got the same auditing
firm on in both cases and there's
they're they're signing their name going
nobody ever
i don't think anybody's ever done
anything with that suggestion
and
it's you know that would be the first
thing i would do actually if i really
wanted to sort of dig into
what was happening in accounting but
but there's a lot of things in life you
can't change and
and uh
nobody is going to go looking for ways
to
create lawsuits and
newspaper stories all kinds of things
and i don't blame them
i did
i said i brought one thing
i just couldn't resist
i was hoping i'd get a question so i'll
ask it myself uh
i was hoping to get a question that
how could these some guy be so
idiotic
as to
propose
a price
uh
that of
848 dollars and
two cents or whatever it was
or is for allegany court and i mean that
isn't that getting a little scientific
at
and
and of course i did provide when i made
the offer that
it'd be
eight hundred and
fifty dollars less whatever was paid to
whatever investment banker
they wanted to
select allegheny's case
and and they're bound to have to do it
because
delaware law is developed in such a way
that the directors are protected if they
get expert opinions all that sort of
thing so i i don't i don't fault anybody
in the system but i just thought
it might be useful
actually
um maybe the delaware judges someday
that or
delaware
statute makers maybe people
that are writing papers who knows
but i suggest that
that
we just
since i'm willing to pay 850 dollars a
share for the place as is you know if
the auto fees are i mean if the
advisory fees are
10 million or 40 million that it makes a
difference to someone
and
it's always made a difference to us as
the buyer
but that's just the way the game was
well
there's a little history to that
and
i went back
and there's been twice
in the nobody's ever paid attention to
this but but it
had been twice in the history of
berkshire hathaway 57 years
twice that berkshire was required
to get a fairness opinion
and it was perfectly logical
that we'd be required to get a fairness
opinion
in those two cases
because in one case
diversified retailing which was a
company i was invested in
in both of them that came out of our
partnership but one had a group of stair
holders that were different
than the other group of shareholders at
berkshire and the two one one emerged so
you have two companies
with
me being the biggest beneficiary in
between and
uh
and
it really it wasn't up to me to
determine the ratio i mean even though i
had the most involved but but i had a
little more of one company than the
other so anyway
a fairness and opinion was required
and this has only been twice in the
history of berkshire that one was
required
so naturally i went to charlie
and i said charlie
you know we do have to i mean charlie
told me he knew what better i did we
need a fairness opinion in this case
and uh
i said
you know
i know it's fair
you know what's fair sandy's
knows what he thinks is fair if the
three of us owned it
in 10 minutes we could have worked out
a deal
that all three of us regarded despair
but because there were public
shareholders and everything
it wasn't right to do it that way and
and the first time the first one we have
two of these but the first one
was november
27 1978
and i told the shareholders
essentially that
my personal belief is that both
diversified and berkshire shareholders
will benefit from the merger but i will
not i will i will vote for the merger
only if a majority of the shares which
are voted by other shareholders of each
company are voted to support it so i
which was fine i committed myself
you know that
that
let the other people decide whether this
was fair but on top of that
we needed to get a fairness opinion from
an investment bank with a
big name and everything
and so
i said to charlie
i said you know
these things are going for
a million or two million bucks
where they get some guy that they hired
last week and he writes up
a little thing and
and then we get a bill for
a million or two and they really haven't
done anything they don't they don't know
either company and you know they there's
a million things they're not going to
know about it but but they're going to
write an opinion and uh and we need the
opinion
i said so what do i do
i go to charlotte with these kind of
problems i said
warren it's very simple
he said
pick out 10
prestigious
investment banks
and do exactly what i say
so
okay charlie uh
what do i do when i call and get these
ten
he says well put him in order
one through ten
and he said
call the guy at the top of the list
and tell him you'll pay him sixty
thousand dollars
for doing a fairness opinion
and you know that it's an insulting
price
and it's ridiculous for him to do it
because it'll affect what he can get
from other people down the line they'll
look back and they'll say well buffer
only paid 60 000 why should i pay
2 million and it's it's
but he says just tell them
that that's what you'll pay
and if
if they're insulted by it which they
probably should be
and then you'll go to number two
and they'll offer them the same deal and
you'll just keep going down until you
get to number 10.
and if you don't have anybody by number
10 you've told the other people you'll
come back to number one again and you'll
say well i'll pay 80 000 and then you'll
go down the list and everything well
so
i picked
10 names out
and number one name
was jack shad
and jack shad was
a friend of tom murphy's in front of
bill rewains and he was running ef
hunting and he was
he he was a very very very successful
investment banker i didn't know him as
well as the others but i met him from my
friends i called up and i said jack
i said i've got this crazy request
he says only because everybody admires
you so much my friends are your friends
and blah blah blah and ef hutton is so
well regarded i said i'm going to do
something that's i'm going to ask you
something that is totally against your
interest and i fully understand the fact
that you're going to say you're an idiot
to call me on this and slam down the
phone but i said jack here's here's our
procedure and i describe this procedure
that
he gets called first and if he turns it
down then i go to payne weber and then i
go to the controller i tell them there's
these 10 people
and if we don't get any yeses i'm going
to come back to you again and
i'll offer you 75 and we'll do the same
thing till somebody says yes
uh
and i said jack you know
but you are the first caller so
um
sixty thousand dollars and it's going to
screw up your business
if you do this because every client you
get in the future is going to say well
you did it for diversified retailing and
berkshire
and why in the world should we pay you 2
million when he paid you 60 000.
and jack said
don't worry about it warren i can take
care of that
he says we're in
and uh
so
we got a fairness opinion but
but for one side now the next call i
made was the payne webber and i
gave him the same story
and uh
uh
i said ef hutton
was dumb enough
to take the one side for sixty thousand
bucks
you know
i don't know why the hell are doing it
you know they're destroying their
reputation and all that and payne webber
said
we'll take the other side for 60 000.
so we have a perspe we have a thing here
that describes the whole process
and
they got well low
they sent out an amiable alcoholic
they had to do something with
well what they did
was they each billed us for 60 000 bucks
and we paid it that's what you get for
60 000 bucks no no no
we we got the same thing everybody else
got charlie and
and
and of course jack shad
uh
this is 1978.
he was appointed chairman of the fcc
seven years i mean jack jack likes to do
business and
and it's true it didn't hurt him they
paid us 60 000 and they went back and
charged somebody else 2 million
you know the next week and
those guys it's all play money
and uh
so
we did the same thing when we got to
blue chip stamps
where we were similarly conflicted
four or five years later
we went back to the same two guys
and there'd been a lot of inflation and
everything like that so we we said 110
000 then i've got the perspectives for
that and
both of them said you know send it in
don't worry about our other clients we
can
we'll figure out some story to tell them
you know whatever it may be
but
i just
thought it would be interesting
to at some point
have people realize that it's not play
money somebody pays it and it's a game
and
you know it
but it's it's it's what passes
muster
in delaware and the directors will
have it explained to them by the lawyers
that
they're not going to get sued if they do
it in a certain kind of way and you know
it
it's uh
uh
so i just decided that
somebody at some point i'll
point out what that actually is
happening in the situation
and that's why we did it that way and
and uh
you know
they go down with our earlier
attempts to educate the world on the
realities of
finance and it's various interactions
and
why it's better to teach your son to be
an investment banker than
to be an electrician you know or
something but
it's uh
you've got an eccentric chairman and
that's what he did
charlie how do you feel about this whole
matter
it was your idea originally
well
it's we're a little peculiar
and
it's not all all the peculiarities are
not bad
i talked to charlie before and i didn't
talk to charlie before i did it
this time but yeah
but
charlie has given me four ideas
and together that on
extremely practical matters
was so much
uh
i mean
they just changed everything
i i think you really ought to talk about
the experience with the fraud
well what on the fraud claim it
you know that
the fidelity claim with the guy you know
yet he had a very well known insurance
company that you don't have to name
names but uh
well then
you know you basically told them just
raise the stakes
to make
the game fair this was back in the 1960s
do you remember that i don't remember oh
well
i do i remember it well tell it then
[Laughter]
charlie had this tiny little operation
which he ran his fund
also
had a seat on the pacific coast soccer
chains the firm was called wheeler
monger it was called wheeler margaret
first later changed itself to mugger
wheeler and jack wheeler said well
pretty sure it'll be a buggered company
but that's okay they jack wheeler was a
very interesting guy and he had the
specialist position in general motors
and a few things
and some employee
stole like
i don't know twelve thousand bucks or
something like that from yeah
hit i remember he had the trading
tickets
yeah some guys some guys steal some
money
and
charlie's firm wheeler marker was
required to have a fidelity bond and all
these things that
covered
dishonest employees and all of that sort
so
this guy is clearly dishonest he's
clearly stolen the money so charlie puts
in a
claim for twelve thousand dollars or
something like that whatever the loss
was
and sends it to this very big and
prestigious insurance company
and of course
the insurance company
denies this claim they say you know the
guy really wasn't an employee doesn't
exist you don't have a dog you know i
mean the whole thing
and charlie gets this letter back and
they're not going to pay the claim
and uh
so charlie writes a letter to this very
well-known
big name
person that runs the insurance company
and he said look at
he said
we have this 12 thousand dollar claim
and he said
this guy stole the money
uh
and we thought we had a insurance policy
against people stealing the paid us
people stole money and he said
he said we're in this very interesting
position because
you've got a bunch of people on the
payroll and they're going to get their
weekly check
or monthly check whatever they do
so they just say
we're not going to pay
and life goes on
whereas
i'm sitting here
and i've got my time i gotta work on
this thing
and
it isn't worth the twelve thousand
dollars
for me to
fool around with this
claim
against the company and they'll appeal
it and all these things so he said
i know that you would be offended
by the thought
that you might be using
this
inequality
a bargaining position
to avoid playing at the claim and that
never could be your intention
so what i suggest
in order to
really live up to your code of behavior
is why don't we make the twelve thousand
dollar claim which is we'll just
multiply it by 10 and call it 120 000
either way and if you lose
you pay me 120 000 if i lose i'll pay
you 120 000. now it's worth my while
and
he presses the letter to the chairman
and says that's
the guy he gets a
12 000 check by return mail
[Applause]
it's not a bad lesson
he's told me two others but the tricks
are too good
i don't even want to share them now i
may use it myself someday
okay
uh let's go to uh
becky
uh we got a lot of questions on this
topic i'll ask this one that came from
raj
he says have you changed your views on
bitcoin and or cryptocurrency in any
respect
i'm conflicted about this because his
own views have slightly evolved during
the past two years from bitcoin as a
fraud and waste to bitcoin is in a
speculative bubble but might have some
uses
well
i shouldn't answer any questions on the
subject but i will
you know there's
there's all kinds of people watching
this that are long bitcoin and there's
nobody that's short and nobody nobody
wants their windpipe
stepped on i don't blame them i don't
like people to step on my windpipe
but i would say this
that
if all the people list if the people in
this room
owned all of the farmland
in the united states
and you offered
me a one percent interest in it
and you said from one percent interest
in all the farmland in the united states
uh
pay me uh
pay our group
um
well let's see 10 million
pesos bargain price 25 billion dollars
i'll write you check this afternoon 25
billion now i own one percent of the
farmland
if you tell me you own
one percent of the apartment houses in
the united states
uh
and you offer
me
uh
a one percent interest so i'll have a
one percent of all the apartment houses
in the country
and you want
whatever it may be
for
another 25 billion or something
i'll write you check you know it's very
simple
now if you told me you owned
all of the bitcoin
in the world
and you offered it to me for 25
i wouldn't take it because what would i
do with it
i have to sell it back to you one way or
another i mean maybe i have the same
people but it isn't going to do anything
the apartments are going to produce
rental and
and the farms are going to produce food
and uh
if i've got all the bitcoin
you know
i'm back where whatever his name was who
may or may not have existed was you know
15 years ago
if i've got it all he could create a
mystery about it but everybody knows
what i'm like i mean so if i'm trying to
get rid of it
you know people will say well
you know why should i buy some bitcoin
i mean why don't you call it buffered
coin you know make your own or something
what do something but uh
i'm not going to give you anything for
it and you'd be right incidentally but
that explains the difference between
productive assets and something that
depends on the next guy paying you more
than the last guy got now
net
if you look at it
a lot of commissions have been paid and
there's i mean there's all kinds of
frictional costs that are very real
that somebody has paid
to a bunch of people who facilitate this
game
but
whatever
one group of the public has taken out or
one group of owners has come in from
other people i mean other people have
entered the room and they've moved money
around but
but
no money has there's no more money in
the room it's just changed hands with a
lot of maybe fraud and
costs involved and
you know a whole bunch of things you
lose you know you forget the numbers and
forget the equation and they uh
you can do that with a lot of things i
mean it's been done throughout history
certain things
have value
that
don't
produce something
tangible i mean you can you can say a
great painting
that probably will have some value
500 years from now may not but the odds
are pretty good
that if it was a big enough name
at some point there will be a few things
i mean
you know you can uh
you can find something for
if somebody wants to sell you a pyramid
or something and you can charge the
viewers or you know it'll be around a
long time and won't produce anything but
but but uh
people will find it interesting to go
there because they're better about the
parents but basically
uh
assets
to be
that value
they have to deliver something
to somebody and uh
and there's only one currency
that's acceptable and i'd say i mean you
can
come up with all kinds of things
we can put out berkshire coins or you
know we put up
berkshire money or anything like that
but uh we get in trouble i guess if we
call it money but uh
in the end
this is money
and
and there's no reason
in the world
why
the united states government
whose currency people prefer
literally there's 2.3
just under 2.3 trillion just of these
little pieces of paper floating around
some places 7 000 for every man woman
and child in the united states and of
course most of them probably are in the
united states who knows
but
this is the only thing that's money
and
anybody that thinks the united states
is going to change
to where they let
berkshire money
replace theirs you know it's out of
their mind i mean
so anyway
uh
with those few deficiencies
you know
you can whether it goes up or down in
the next year or five years ten years i
don't know
but
the one thing i'm pretty sure of is that
it
it doesn't it doesn't multiply it
doesn't produce anything it's
it's uh it's got a magic to it and
people have attached magics to lots of
things i mean the gold on wall street
create magic you know
we are not an insurance company we're a
tech company well they're an insurance
company but a dozen people ourselves
raise a lot of money they just say just
don't pay attention to the fact that we
sell insurance
we are a tech company well
in the end they brought insurance and
overwhelmingly they've
lost a lot of money since that
you can
you can make up things that
work well and
getting money from other people and
that's why
well i have a slightly different way of
looking at it
i'll sell you something well i the
in my life i try and avoid things that
are stupid
and evil
and make me look bad in comparison with
somebody else
and bitcoin does all three
and
in the first place
it's stupid because it's very likely to
go to zero
the same way it's evil because it
undermines the federal reserve system
and the national currency system
which we desperately need to maintain
its integrity and
government control and so on
and third
it makes us look foolish compared to the
communist leader in china
he was smart enough to ban bitcoin in
china with all of our
presumed advantages of civilization
we are a lot dumber than the communist
leader in china
yeah and when 25 of the people of the
country get mad because we've said what
we've said today just remember charlie
spoke last it was the most
[Applause]
the one development
that i really do think is actually
important but i don't know anybody to do
anything about it
but i would
my general assessment and there's no way
to prove it but i essentially
believe
people are now behaving somewhat more
tribal
than
they have for a long time
and
i mean people are always going to be
partisan and they're they're going to
have
religious beliefs they're going to have
all kinds of things but
but it gets pretty
it gets pretty tribal
and i want to
tell you i speak from experience
because i've been tribal
and you know we're confessing today uh
and
uh
you know
nebraska football is tribal
and
when i watch a television set
and i see
our guys step
nebraskan
step
out of bounds
by a foot but somehow the ref misses it
and calls it in
and then they show six replays
i'll continue to believe it was in even
though it's right in front of my eyes
and they stepped out you know that's
tribal behavior and
and it's fun i mean
participated
but it gets it can get very dangerous
when
people
one group of people say two plus two is
five and another says two plus two is
three you know and they're going to give
you those answers if you call them and
the interesting thing is
to me
at least and partly because of my age
but
i actually
think
that just from memory
that the last time that
the country was
seeing this tribal
was actually when i was a kid and
roosevelt was in either you hated
roosevelt
or you loved him i mean nobody cared
about the fact alflander was running or
wendell wilk he was running against him
they just had these feelings they either
had
roosevelt's picture on the wall and
named their kids after roosevelt
or they hated him and uh and they
thought he was going to
you know no third term and you know i
mean a million things
and
the country was very very tribal
in the 30s
but
roosevelt's tribe was bigger
and
in my opinion they did some wonderful
things
but i happen to grow up in a household
where we didn't get
served dessert until we said something
nasty about roosevelt i mean
and believe me if you don't get dessert
you're going to say something nasty
about roosevelt
and so you train them young and you know
all kinds of things
and
so i've been
i've seen it i i think i've seen
a period that it wasn't that way when
you know
if
eisenhower was running against
stevenson or you know or whatever it
might be i mean uh
you know people
they didn't they didn't just
they had a partisan behavior and they
had
a certain amount of tribal always but
i i think that i don't think it's a good
development for society generally when
people get tribal regardless nobody is
[Applause]
[Music]
charlie what tribes are you a member of
them
[Laughter]
well in california we have a legislature
which is completely gerrymandered so no
nobody can ever be thrown out by the
voters
and therefore
the only people in the legislature are
insane rightists and insane leftists
they get together every 10 years and
they're usually six moderates somewhere
in the legislature and so they rejigger
all the districts to throw them out
because neither party can stand them
now that is government in california
and
and you live there and you have to go
back
yes
i'm sure you'll have a wall and i prefer
living there they're living in russia
[Laughter]
[Applause]
okay who who haven't we gotten in
trouble with him no
what was it lenny bruce that you say is
there anyone i've forgotten to offend
you the
uh section
10 i believe
uh hello mr buffett and mr munger my
name is sahej i'm from new jersey and
i'm currently a freshman at rutgers
university
you knew quite early on that you wanted
to be investors and you've obviously
been amazing at it
what advice would you have for someone
who's still trying to figure out what
they want to focus on and find their
calling
well that is
it is a very interesting question
because i got i was very very
lucky
in that
i um
i found what i wanted to do
because my dad happened to be in a
business that he wasn't interested in
but that some books down there and i
loved my dad and i go down
read the books
and they interested me
and
you know
i'm i'm glad he wasn't a
a professional professional
boxers i mean i you know i wouldn't have
any teeth left or anything
it was it was accident just
totally accident
but
i do think
i do think you know it
when you see it and it doesn't mean you
can
follow i
i would tell the students
wrote in the report i mean
you know
find out what you love doing and you
spend most of your life doing it and
that uh why in the world would you want
to be
around for a lifetime
uh
working with people that you didn't like
unless you had to which sometimes
happens and
just
work for whomever you admire the most
and
i gave the talk at stanford one time and
somebody showed up at
tom murphy's office i think a couple of
days later i mean
that person was right and of course it's
what i did when i got out of school i i
wanted to work for ben graham i mean
that was i just
i didn't care what i got paid
it didn't make it you know
it just is i just knew that that's what
i wanted to do and then i
pestered him for three years and he
finally hired me
uh
and then i found somebody else that i'd
even rather work for than
ben
who happened to be myself and
so so so i've been working for myself
ever since but
i worked for i had about four bosses in
my life
uh
you know i
had done the lincoln journal with uh
name slips my mind at the moment his
wonderful boss it was cooper smith at
jcpenney's here in omaha and they all
were wonderful people
but i still prefer working for myself
and of course charlie and i both worked
for my grandfather
and
we just didn't
we didn't find it
that interesting that uh
uh i i never i don't remember how why
did you ever decide to go to work at the
store apparently charlie worked there in
1940 i worked
i worked just for the experience of
working i didn't need the money my
father gave me an ample allowance and i
also had a private business
so
i was kind of working as a lark in your
grocery store
12 hours a day yes as for lauren yeah as
a lark yes
do you consider that a good investment
of your time i'm looking back on it well
i'd never done it before and i wanted to
have a little of that experience and i
wasn't going to do it very long
that sure as hell wasn't the reason i
worked
well
but i could give that young lady the
advice
figure out what you're bad at and avoid
all of it
yeah
that's the way warren and i found our
provision absolutely we yeah we failed
at everything else we worked at
everything until we found the ideal
employers ourselves
you know and that that was an organ that
was something we really admired was
i know the ones that work for somebody
you admire
the only one he knew was the one he was
shaving
you
[Laughter]
but it isn't bad advice
it isn't bad advice
i mean
who
wants this
if they've got an option i mean if
you're
you know
charlie went into the
service and
whatever year was in the 40s and
he didn't really have a choice of
who he was going to work for and as i
remember
it didn't really work out that well who
worked for charlie did it
well
if you stop to think about the two
things that neither one of us has ever
succeeded at
one we've never succeeded anything that
didn't interest us right right
and we've never succeeded in anything
that
was really hard where we didn't have
much aptitude for it
yeah and we've been doing whatever we
played yeah
i mean
and we get you know we have fun in our
way and i'm just amazed you'd think if
you're smart you could do things that
don't interest you well but you can't
well
i've certainly got a lot of examples in
my own case but we won't get into them
here
and we will go to
becky
this question comes from foster taylor
in tulsa oklahoma he said he recently
listened to the berkshire hathaway 2008
annual meeting where you talked about
global oil production
at the time you talked about major
ramifications of global oil production
went below 85 million barrels in 25
years
we are at the 14 year mark in global oil
production looks to be 79 million
barrels at the same time we're depleting
our strategic oil reserves should the
united states be doing something
differently and do you see consequences
to these actions in the next 10 years if
we do not become more proactive
well charlie's the expert on oil
well
i bet
only compared to me
samuel johnson said it's harder hard to
determine the order of presidency
between a louse and a flea
it's hard to tell which of us is more
incompetent than oil
the
yeah we're still competing
i have a different view on this subject
i like having big reserves of oil
if i were running the
benevolence by the united states i would
just leave most of the oil we have here
and i'd pay whatever the arabs charge
for their oil and i'd pay it cheerfully
and conserve my own
i think it's going to be very precious
stuff over the next 200 years
and so
and nobody else has my view so i it
doesn't bother me i just think they're
all wrong
well but at any rate i that is not the
normal view and we've been pretty
flexible in our own view i mean actually
the
the uh
you know the federal government is
serving up over many billion barrels of
of the stuff that that ended into the
economy
and you know it wasn't that long ago
that you know the idea that
anybody produced a barrel of oil was
somehow
uh
something terrible i mean
just try doing without 11 million
barrels a day and see what happens
tomorrow it it is it is something that
everybody has a feeling on
immediately and and uh
you know this gets into
uh
a whole bunch of different
uh tribes of sorts and and you offend an
awful lot of people if you talk in any
way about it but
in the end i think at the moment at
least
most people feel that
it's nice to have some oil in this
country than not have it and uh
and
we're using a lot of it
if we were to try and change over in
three years or five years
nobody knows what would happen but
but the odds that it would
work well are
extremely low it seems to me
charlie why don't you say something more
dramatic so you'll be the one that
offended the most people
well if you
if you stop to think about it
the aerial industry is being so vilified
now
i can hardly think of a more useful
industry more and
i don't know about wildcatters but
certainly the petroleum engineers i i
know and the people who design our oil
refineries and pipelines are some of the
finest and most reliable people they
know
and i see very little trouble with the
oil supply thing in the united states
so i'm basically in love with standard
oil so and i i don't have this feeling
that it's an
evil crazy place
uh
i i wish the rest of the world worked as
well as our big oil companies
well we better move on to station 11.
i'm not sure whether station 11 is
operative
well we're here
greetings from the overflow room
my name is glenn tung i'm a shareholder
from new york this is my 20th berkshire
annual meeting and i'm delighted that
we're able to once again be here in
person you two have brought tremendous
joy to all of us through the years and
speaking personally your wisdom has not
only made me a better investor but more
importantly a better happier person
it's a privilege and honor to thank you
so warren and charlie thank you
well that's my kind of a question yeah
that
that's fine
let's have more of those
yeah
or you might say it again i mean
maybe you could sing it
[Laughter]
maybe i should quit at this point then
go do it my question relates to share
repurchases
since you started buying back berkshire
shares in size two years ago the
repurchases have ranged between 1
billion and 3 billion per month
by my estimate it appears that the
buyback rate is about 3 billion per
month when berkshire's trading at a 20
or so percent discount to intrinsic
value 2 billion per month at about a 10
discount and a billion per month at a 0
to 10 value do i have that about right
and approximately
approximately right and do any other
factors influence the rate of share
repurchases
well
uh
after you're so nice in your
introduction i have to say that yeah
you're actually wrong in the
in our
if somebody offered us
50 billion dollars worth of stock
uh at a certain point in the last
three or four
five months
uh we'd have taken it you know it's that
simple and as i mentioned earlier we
haven't bought any stock in april
it uh
it's something
that when we can do it
and we know
at least we think the probabilities are
very high we certainly believe it
in terms of our own
evaluation and our own investment
uh if we think that we're improving
things
for the remaining shareholders
uh
we'll buy it back
and if we don't we don't buy it back and
and
if we have the choice of buying
businesses that we like
or buying back stock
controlling factors how much money we
have
we'd rather buy businesses and
so it isn't
you know we don't
don't stay awake at night
working out formulas or anything of the
sort
but we don't ever do it if we think
that we're not doing something at the
time if we had a lemonade stand and
charlie and i and you
owned it
and the lemonade stand was
making us about a buck a week or
something and we divided it up
and you said you wanted to get out
and uh
if you said one number we'd
we'd
have the funds in the our little
lemonade company
and we'd buy you out and if we didn't
like the price
we wouldn't buy you out
but it's uh
it's the same way we feel we don't
but we do feel an obligation
to do things
that we think
are intelligent
and in no way risk
absolutely
no way and
present any risk
of
financial problems under any
circumstances we
we can envision except maybe something
like nuclear war
uh
you know we will we'll we will do it but
uh it never can be that big a factor
certain companies well
charlie
i think spoke the other day
and got actually henry singleton
uh i think he bought back 89 percent of
the the company over time and he sold
stock
like crazy or issued it
much earlier when it was overpriced and
they bought it back under priced
but the key to that of course is having
people think you're wrong in doing it so
he was able to buy a ton of it
and
there's some other companies that have
bought a ton of it
and
berkshire isn't going to get the chance
to do that because
we uh if people think we're buying them
we've got sensible shareholders that's
what it amounts to if we had the same
group of shareholders that own
two-day puts and they were our
shareholders we'd buy back the whole
company you know
and
in a very short period of time
but
it's such an easy concept
to assess i mean the second
stock i bought
what city service preferred that was the
first one second stock i bought was a
company called texas pacific land trust
and that came out of the bankruptcy of
the texas and pacific railroad back in
the 1880s or nothing like that
and they had three million
some acres and they owned the minerals
and they owned the surface and
everything else but it was
it was terrible land in the 1880s but
they
had some kind of a charter that
said
use the proceeds from land sales
whatever it was they were going to buy
in stock every year
and uh
and
you know i sat there when i was 13 or 14
and i figured if i lived to be 100
i would own the whole place well
i haven't lived to be 100 yet and i
didn't buy the whole i wouldn't have
bought the whole place so both
calculations are
so far perfect but it
it's
been a remarkable company
just plain remarkable because
they would talk about raising fees of
six thousand dollars a year or something
like that you know maybe when they had
three million acres and then they kept
finding oil and more oil and more oil
and
and they've changed the form and all
kind of things but they bought in
stock
week after week after week
and i
sat there and figured out how long it
would take until i owned the whole
company and
and i obviously made some improper
calculations because it wouldn't work
that way but uh
it still was apparent to me
it would be a very good idea if they had
three million acres down there that they
got all through with and they kept their
mineral rights and all kinds of things
which they were doing
uh
you know you know
at a very cheap price it ought to work
out well for anybody who's sat around
for a long time and it has worked out
extremely well for anybody
sat around a long time but
but nobody knew that they were going to
find a lot of oil and eventually el paso
would grow out far enough so that the
the surface lands became worse some
money that they were
somewhat near el paso then you had to go
a couple hundred more miles to find the
next person but that was another problem
so uh
it's it's just so some of the stuff is
so simple
you know but
but
you know people want to get their phd or
something so they
they
work out hundreds of pages and have lots
of greek letters in it and all that sort
of thing and
and you know either you're buying buying
out your partner at an attractive price
you're not buying a monitor you're
pricing if you've got the money around
to do it and the price is attractive you
don't have some other opportunities
you know why not i mean you got to come
out ahead by doing it
and if certain other
you've got other things that are more
intelligent
you you don't do it and and it
and if it isn't intelligent on an
absolute basis you also don't do it then
charlie have you got anything to
add to the
what were you doing in 1940
three we're in the in the service and i
warned we'd we'd be crazy if we didn't
rather enjoy having come a considerable
distance from small beginnings
and to do that in good company
it's it's a favored life
yeah we've been very fortunate
yeah
and
tomorrow
[Music]
monday i can tell you it's almost
certain that if anybody offers us well
they'll be shared straight a berkshire
and we won't buy any but
but it's also
a pretty fair chance someday a lot of
shares quite a few share not a lot
berkshire's got the
our shareholders are too smart that's
one of our problems that we want to
repurchase shares but we really don't
want to squeeze it we don't want to
squeeze out anybody but
but we also are here to do things that
increase the value for the people who
stick with us i mean it's not very
complicated and and
we'll get we'll there'll be times when
we'll do it and there'll be times when
we won't but it won't
there won't be any formula but there
will be the principles that i've just
expressed and and uh
and my guess is that
my successor and their successor will
have a similar calculation because we're
looking for people that are
rational and devoted to berkshire
so
glenn thanks for coming and uh becky
here next
this question was sent in by dave shane
from brooklyn new york he's responding
to something he heard earlier today
he said in the future will greg be able
to act with the same spontaneity that
you mentioned earlier and make immediate
multi-billion dollar decisions without
board approval
well my guess is
that
the board
it's just
the responders people do
they'll be
they'll put some more restrictions or
they'll have
some more consultation on a lot of
matters that
that uh or some matters
uh
than they
they do with me i mean that
uh they won't need to
but
they'll feel that they haven't had the
experience they haven't seen them as
long and then a whole bunch of things
and they'll feel that the delaware laws
protects them better
and incidentally they don't have
directors and officers liability
insurance i mean
virtually every company on the new stock
exchange has it
and
we just don't buy it i mean to
come on the board and you're a trustee
for a whole bunch of people that trust
you and me uh i'm talking about the
directors and me
uh
you know
finding it
but
it's it
it's very interesting people people go
on museum boards
you know and they're expected to
contribute people go on college boards
and they're expected to contribute money
and
it's they say it's a great honor to be
on a university board or museum board or
whatever it's a great on earth and
therefore you should raise money for us
well
frankly i think our board's more
interesting than being on a university
board or
you know a hospital board or something
i wouldn't know what they were talking
about anyway and on museum board or art
board and so
and uh
in uh
you know
but
people have found that they can make 300
000 a year
uh
you know
which is way more which is enormously
important to some people and it's
meaningless to others
uh
and
i mean
chances are
if somehow they'd arranged it so that
directors didn't get paid at all
there'd be plenty of people wanting to
be directors and that'd be a prestigious
sort of thing and all that but
but
in effect it's
it's money i
that
comes very easily
i did
the whole idea of the independent
director
frankly is
it just doesn't really make any sense
you don't think a director is
independent who needs three hundred
thousand needs the money yeah
i mean
he's independent of the way a slave is
independent
i am
i am going to read a few sentences which
are absolutely the case
except i'm doctoring there's just
i don't want i don't want anybody to be
identified obviously with us and these
are just but these are word for word
excerpts
was and i'm not i'm not telling whether
it's a
a woman or a man i'm going to use a male
pronoun because it's just because it's
easier but i picked out a few sentences
from a letter i received many years ago
and
this letter
said i'm writing to you with a great
deal of reluctance
and a sense of personal embarrassment
i have tried all of the conventional
means of raising
the money this person needed a couple
million dollars
and
i wouldn't have known the person
if i saw him on the street you know but
but uh
but it
wrote this letter and
said i need a couple million dollars
and uh
and then this is the item
that i think you might find interesting
and i've kept the letter
my income
has composed 100
of my board fees
well
yeah i just
looked him up and the time
he was a director of five prestigious
companies
and had been directors of others and
directors and he was going to be
directing a whole bunch of things
but
he was desperate for money
and he says
he's getting 100 of it for board fees
and he was an independent director
classified as an independent director
at every one of these
companies
uh
and
it's just astounding to me
uh
that
uh you know we're gonna have a feral
remaining just a couple minutes we're
gonna we're gonna start it and uh
um
it's just astounding to me that uh
uh
in 2006
we we own nine percent of the coca-cola
company
i mean maybe they gave me a free coke
i mean
but
we own nine percent at berkshire
hathaway we
obviously cared about the future of the
coca-cola company and
and uh
uh
just so happened in
in that year
calpers and a few others have
recommended
that
we be voted against or something or
other and
and at one time there were
two big institutional ambassadors
voted because they didn't think i was
independent because dairy queen
bought some coca-cola
uh for the
or actually the
people that had our franchise want some
coca-cola i mean
do they think i can't add things and
if we've got billions and billions and
billions of dollars
that i'm going to be compromised and but
it's it's just nutty and
so one year my my my vote fell from 90
maybe it was 98 vote approval to 84
because uh
i'd figure whether it's 2004 to
somewhere along the line they just
decided that
that i wasn't
the right sort of person to be able to
handle these responsibilities
and uh
um
you know
the idea
that somebody
it's an important part of their income
i mean what they want they may want to
do a lot of other good things it doesn't
it doesn't mean they're terrible people
but
if the if the difference is whether you
how you live
in this case whether the person might go
broke
uh
how in the world you can call somebody
like an independent and say that anybody
owns
a lot of you know women walter scott's
been not independent or maybe
it's just ridiculous
but
it's the way the
the rules are and
we
we will
we follow the rules but
well they don't want them just
independent now they want one horse one
rabbit one cow one whatever um
i mean i
you know i feel like galileo
independence is not enough
you gotta have a very diverse kind of
independence yeah
yeah
and
and if you if you desperately need the
money in this case 100 of the income
coming from it
uh you're on five of the most
prestigious boards in the
in the country and
and
and classify as independent on each and
other
other and all you're hoping is that well
if your ceo gets called by another ceo
and says is this guy okay and you say of
course he's okay which means of course
he doesn't cause trouble and so he gets
on a sixth board anyway i know
oh he says it's it's not our idea of an
independent director
it's all a little
crazy which brings us the fact that
we're not going to have our annual
meeting here
and
about 15 minutes we'll
we'll we'll reconvene it
3 45 and then we'll do the
the business of the meeting
that is required and
you're all welcome to stay here and
it's very
we'll now come
to the moment you've all been waiting
for
we'll all we will have the annual
meeting uh
charlie doesn't join me for this because
once or twice
in the past he was caught on camera
sleeping so
we've solved that one and
and
we're now going to have a an annual
meeting where i follow a
script
and
you may think that's impossible but i'll
do it
so the meeting will now come to order
i'm warren buffett chairman of the board
of directors of the company i welcome
you to this 2022 annual meeting of
shareholders
mark hamburg is secretary of berkshire
hathaway and he will make a written
record of the proceedings
rebecca hammock has been appointed
inspector of elections at this meeting
and she will certify the count of votes
cast in the election for directors and
the motions to be voted upon at this
meeting
the named proxy holders for this meeting
are greg abel and mark hamburg
does the secretary have a report of the
number of berkshire shares outstanding
entitled to vote and represented at the
meeting yes i do
as indicated in the proxy statement that
accompanied the notice of this meeting
that was sent to all shareholders of
record on march 2nd 2022
the record date for this meeting there
were 614
shares of class a berkshire hathaway
common stock outstanding with each share
entitled the one vote and motions
considered at this meeting and 1 billion
633 million
719 shares of
class b berkshire hathaway common stock
outstanding with each share entitled the
110 000 of one vote on motions
considered at this meeting of that
number 423
7719 class a shares and 759 million 159
354 class b shares are represented at
this meeting by proxies returned through
thursday evening april 28th
okay
and uh i will interrupt this meeting for
one second to announce that we're still
selling things next door and we've sold
15 votes
so
with that
brief commercial
and uh
uh and if anybody leaves i will not be
offended uh thank you
the number represents the quorum and we
will therefore directly proceed with the
meeting
the first order of business will be a
reading of the minutes of the last
meeting of shareholders i recognize mr
decker who will place motion before the
meeting
i move that the reading of the minutes
from the last meeting of shareholders be
dispensed with and the minutes be
approved do i hear a second
i second the motion the motion is
carried the next item of business is to
elect directors if a shareholder is
present who did not send in a proxy or
wishes to withdraw a proxy
previously sent in you may vote in
person on the election of directors and
other matters to be considered
at this meeting
please identify yourself to one of the
meeting officials in the aisle so that
you can receive a ballot
i recognize miss sue decker to place a
motion before the meeting with respect
to election directors
i moved that warren buffett charles
munger gregory abel howard buffett susan
buffett stephen burke kenneth chanault
christopher davis susan decker davis
david goddessman charlotte guyman ajit
jain ronald olsen wallace whites and
merrell whitner be elected as directors
i second the motion
it has been moved in second another the
15 individual named in miss decker's
motion be elected as directors the
nominations are ready to be acted upon
there are shareholders voting in person
they should now mark their ballot
on the motion islamic when you are ready
you may give your report
my report is ready the ballot of the
proxy holders in response to proxies
that were received through last thursday
evening cast not less than 449 thousand
190 votes for each nominee
that number exceeds a majority of the
number of the total votes of all class a
and class b shares outstanding the
certification required by delaware law
of the precise count of the votes will
be given to the secretary to place with
the minutes of this meeting
thank you miss amick the 15 nominees
have been elected as directors
the next four items of business relate
to four shareholder proposals that are
each set forth in the proxy statement
that can be accessed at
berkshirehathway.com
the first proposal requests that the
company adopt a policy and amend the
bylaws to require the chair of the board
of directors to be an independent member
of the board the directors have
recommended that the shareholders vote
against the proposal
i will now recognize peter flaherty a
representative national legal and policy
center to present the proposal
good afternoon i am peter flaherty
chairman of the national and legal and
policy center
i'm from washington d.c
but please don't hold that against me
our proposal would separate the roles of
chairman and ceo sorry charlie
but i would take it one step further and
suggest that berkshire remove itself
from corporate america's assault
on american institutions and culture
i'm proud to say i'm a capitalist
but it is obvious to me that capitalism
is failing to deliver for the american
people
real wages have been falling for years
wealth disparity has never been greater
and right outside my hotel window here
in omaha is a homeless encampment an all
too familiar site in american cities
we don't have a free economy we have
bailout capitalism
when small businesses lose money they go
out of business but when billionaires
bet wrong government steps in
money printed by the federal reserve and
irresponsible debt-fueled spending by
politicians what they call fiscal
stimulus have artificially inflated
asset values
so those with the most assets benefit
the most
wage earners get ruinous inflation
but even worse than the wealth gap is
the values gap
the top one percent now seek to impose
their corrupt morality upon the rest of
us
whether it's in the form of critical
race theory
transgenderism
and or the myriad of other woke causes
that permeate corporate advertising and
messaging
why has corporate america embraced both
economic and cultural radicalism
it's pretty simple
when you have so much money your fortune
is going to come under scrutiny
the best way to insulate yourself
and keep anti-business off your back
is to embrace their causes
even if in the process you undermine the
system that produces your wealth
that is what allow mr buffett to
advocate for higher taxes even though
they will fall in the middle class
the federal reserve has offered free
money to corporate america for over a
decade now
creating a class of oligarchs and
greatly enhancing corporate political
power
executives now believe that they can
tell elected governors and legislators
what to do
as we've seen in indiana
georgia
texas and florida
last year coca-cola ceo james quincy a
british and citizen sought to kill
george's new voter integrity law by
making inaccurate and inflammatory
statements about it
he also instituted diversity training
whereby white employees were encouraged
to try to be less white
despite being coke's most celebrated
shareholder
warren buffett is nothing about quincy
in fact mr buffett jumped on the america
his racist bandwagon by signing a
statement by corporate leaders
suggesting that republicans seek to
restrict
ballot access based on race
all this did not prevent ko from
sponsoring the winter olympics in china
which has never had a free election and
where minority communities are the
victims of genocidal policies
and what about apple a large part of
apple's supply chain is in china
the company removes apps from the app
store at the request of the chinese
government because they are used by
human rights activists
and of course apple is the world's most
successful corporate tax minimizer
famous for routing profits through
offshore tax shelters
over at american express the company
instituted an anti-racist initiative
for employees that teach us that
capitalism is fundamentally racist and
requires workers to engage in an
exercise to determine whether they are
the oppressor or the oppressed
activism by woke ceos may be reaching
its limits
the people of florida are fighting back
against disney's robert chapek
who not only embraces the view that
gender is a form of oppression but that
kindergartens must be forced to confront
it
mr buffett has praised the brand
endurance of disney's characters
in the trust parents place and its
content to be safe and appropriate for
children
but now the company is adding warnings
to dumbo
peter pan and aladdin about the
stereotypes they allegedly portray
and poor prince charming has been
excised for kissing snow white
quote unquote
without consent
warren buffett has yet to address the
crisis drip in corporate america and i
fear he never will
yes berkshire may be a holding company
and mr buffett may stay out of the way
of managers but what happens when these
executives use their companies to wage a
social revolution that most americans
don't want
is he not responsible
he can't have it both ways
in this country wealth has been admired
and even celebrated because our system
allows anyone to become rich
but what happens
when americans suddenly find their
history and future under attack by
corporate america
the social compact that permits such
affluence will be broken
mr buffett if you are the face of the
capitalism
why don't you do something to save it
thank you okay
thank you mr flaherty
yeah
uh
if there are any shareholders um
voting in person they should now should
mark their battle on the motion
islamic when you're ready you may give
you a report
my report is ready the ballot of the
proxy holders in response to proxies
that were received through last thursday
evening
cast 72
298 votes for the motion and 421
181 votes against the motion
as as
as the number of votes against the
motion exceeds a majority of the number
of votes of all class a and class b
shares properly cast on the matter the
motion has failed the certification
required by delaware law of the precise
count of the votes given to the
secretary to be placed with the minutes
of this meeting
thank you zamik the proposal fails
[Applause]
the second proposal
second proposal
requested the company published an
annual assessment addressing
how the company manages physical and
transitional
climate-related risks and opportunities
directors are recommended the
shareholders vote against the proposal
i now will now recognize
tim
humans a representative federated
permission to present the proposal
i thank the chair the board and fellow
shareholders i'm tim yeomans lead north
america eos at federated hermes here
today to talk about ballot item three
a proposal that is co-sponsored by
brunell pension partnership limited
represented by eos caste depot placement
du quebec
california public employees retirement
system and state of new jersey common
prevention fundee on behalf of their
combined millions of ultimate
beneficiaries
eos calpers and cdpq co-sponsored her
similar proposal last year
asking the company to commence
climate-related risk reporting which the
company has not started the context for
this year's parent company climate
reporting proposal is however different
in three ways
first we've added new jersey common
pension fund d
second we stand before this annual
meeting of shareholders
backed by in our estimate the majority
of non-insider votes cast at last year's
annual meeting
we provided the company tallies showing
that the majority of non-insider votes
cast
supported last year's proposal as and
glass lewis has also corroborated this
result the company disagrees but has not
shared its reasoning
third the parent company began engaging
with the co-sponsors this year and the
company recently published a supplement
to the chair's letter
from vice chair abel discussing climate
change matters in the company's energy
and rail subsidiaries
also the parent company's audit
committee has amended his charter to now
include climate risk oversight
we welcome the company's new engagement
approach vice chair able supplement and
the revised audit committee charter
however these changes do not address in
any meaningful way
what last year's non-insider majority
supported shareholder proposal asked for
and what this year's ballot item 3 asked
for which is that the parent company
should
a commence annual climate-related
financial reporting for its subsidiaries
where material and for the parent
company as a whole following the
recommendations of the task force on
climate-related financial disclosures
b explain how the board oversees
climate-related risks for the combined
enterprise
and c explore the feasibility of the
parent company and its subsidiaries
establishing science-based greenhouse
gas reduction targets
here is why all shareholders including
the non-insider shareholders who
supported last year's shareholder
proposal should once again this year
tell the board to change course and
support
parent company climate risk reporting
vice chair able supplement talks about
emissions reductions
we ask the parent company to report on
climate-related financial risks not just
emissions reductions as these risks may
be material
abel's letter also talks about emissions
reductions in rail and energy two of the
four giants
of berkshire hathaway as they are
referred to in the chair's annual letter
what about climate risk and insurance
the company has 60 subsidiaries and more
than a few large investment holdings the
company should disclose material
climate-related financial risks beyond
rail and energy in a composite parent
company picture
we asked the company to allocate a small
portion of its more than 100 billion
dollars in cash equivalents to climate
risk reporting at the parent company
level
climate financial risk may be
significant even material at the parent
company
on page k-26 of the 2021 annual report
the company states that climate-related
risks could produce losses and
significantly affect financial results
the company audit however is silent on
climate risk we have asked the auditor
deloitte to explain its inconsistency
we asked the audit committee to explain
why deloitte has not disclosed how it
considered climate-related risks in its
review of financial statements when the
company itself disclosed this is a
significant risk
investors representing 68 trillion
dollars in assets make up the climate
action 100 plus collaborative engagement
on climate change
berkshire hathaway is the only major
public company in the u.s
the only one
to earn now for two years in a row a
score of zero on the ca 100 plus net
zero assessment of climate progress
the undisputed worst performer
this stands in stark contrast to
berkshire hathaway's track record of
usually strong long-term financial
performance
in response to last year's non-insider
majority shareholder vote
the company has made a start towards
climate action
much more is needed vice chair abel is
the name ceo successor his annual
meeting remarks both in 2020 and last
year and his recent letter show he has a
solid grasp of climate risk we asked
vice chair able to commence climate risk
reporting at the parent company level
this would give the company a head start
in complying with the sec's new proposed
climate disclosure rules that ask for
more disclosure than we asked for in
item three we ask all shareholders both
non-insiders and insiders including the
chair
to cast their votes for item three in
support of parent company climate risk
disclosures starting before the 2023
annual meeting thank you
thank you
um
i i do think it's
worth discussing
just a little bit
uh
who the actual
um
the actual constituency
is
of public pension plans
that uh
generally speaking
we hear from various
pensions it's not limited to california
in the least
uh
but saying you know they're protecting
their
the holders of the pensions and the
retired people and all of that
and
therefore they're
they're usually suggesting that
something that
we may or may not agree with in terms of
whether it's actually in the economic
interest but but they do
and they honestly feel incidentally
that they are representing
the pension holders people are getting
going to get these checks every month
now they're getting them now they may
get them later it's a very
understandable
position
but of course in essence
that's not who they represent
uh
the people
that are promised the pensions
whether it's in california
or any other state in the union
they're going to get their checks
it's obvious the united states
american people
people of california
are simply not going to stand
for the fact that people don't get their
checks so one way or another
they're going to get their checks
and
the
to the extent possible
the states
will attempt to realize
from the taxpayers of the state in the
future
enough money so they can pay the checks
i mean that's
why as states have adopted pension plans
and that sort of thing and many of the
states upon their taxes to go up i mean
in effect
no state
government
public opinion in the united states
they're not going to allow people not to
get their pension checks and
the state
does have the right
to tax income and property and various
things
of people
within their
state
and they'll exercise the power or
they'll look to the federal government
for grants so they'll do anything
but the one thing they aren't going to
do is stiff the pensioners so
you're probably representing
if you're
uh
on a public pension where you're
you're as you essentially
are
are representing
the
the future taxpayers of the state now
there's one problem about
future taxpayers
they can leave the state
and it gets awkward
in certain states
particularly when people start leaving
the state
because the revenue that goes with those
people from income taxes and sales tax
and so on so people have a fair amount
of freedom and wounds they don't feel
the same way about
u.s taxes not very many people are going
to move from one place to another but
they may even be in the united states
they move
and it's gradual sometimes it isn't so
gradual and of course as the tax base
goes down the past pensions stay so they
become kind of like an aging steel
company or something of the sort that uh
whatever it may be
uh or the pension pens
may become insolvent but they're gonna
keep paying the people
just like
we're paying on
you know we've adopted certain policies
on on multi-employer pension plans and
so on in the country the united states
is not going to stiff a bunch of people
particularly people that vote but
they're
the moral feeling is to do it so
uh
the real the people that are
that
that the trustee should be
worried about because they of course is
the
future taxpayers
and if they really mess things up
uh
those taxpayers become more and more
likely to leave and it has
a lot of effects interestingly enough
you know one of the calculations
that might go on in berkshire's mind if
we're going to build a plant someplace
it's going to sit there for 50 years
is whether they're going to be any
people around they're going to pay the
tax and we can't move our plant
so all these invisible decisions go on
all the time and uh
it
i don't think there's anything wrong
with representing the
the taxpayers of the future i don't
think there's anything wrong with
uh
sitting on a pension board but i do
think they ought to
actually figure out
who really
is uh
they really are representing and they're
representing
future
taxpayers and in some cases they're
creating some tremendous problems
for
future taxpayers because like
politicians i mean
you know they've got promises they're
going to fill fulfill but they've got to
do it from revenue that comes in in the
future
and they can't print money
and people can leave their state so it's
it's an interesting set of
set of problems and uh
i can't resist
mentioning in 1991 you've seen that
solomon tape
uh
when
solomon essentially
might or might not have gone down
the drain and uh
and had a bankruptcy which
was in my opinion would have spread like
wildfire and uh
and uh
um
who knows what would have happened just
like in 2009
you know when lehman fell on a few
things i mean who knows what's going to
happen after something like that so
solomon was bigger relatively by far
than lehman was in 2009
on a sunday in august
the treasury department
the securities exchange commission
the federal reserve
all decided on a sunday
that something they did on sunday
morning
really was a mistake
and that they better change it on a
sunday
or the whole economic system
might go down the tubes and in this book
which we have for sale on here the other
trillion dollar triage
in the first early pages it describes
that period i didn't know some of the
stuff that's in the book even that was
going on but
essentially
the federal reserve
alan greenspan was brought at one time
uh
jerry corrigan was there nick brady was
secretary of the treasury
they
decided
with various degrees of conviction but
they did decide because they had to
decide
by
roughly 2 30 in the afternoon whether
something they did at 10 o'clock which
was kind of
unprecedented they were going to reverse
themselves
now can you imagine
trying to get
institutions like federal
and treasury department to reverse
themselves but they did realize
that
they had probably done something that
was going to cause
a huge bankruptcy which could turn into
a whirlwind
in wall street
so they reversed themselves and tells
the story in this trillion dollar triage
and
i knew some of what was going on there
was other parts i didn't know what was
going on anyway
all of those institutions
reversed themselves very reluctantly
big institutions do not like to reverse
themselves and particularly not four
hours later and
when some guy from almost
if they if they if they do this
we're going to declare bankruptcy in in
tokyo because we're going to have a
multi-billion dollar
run and we can't pay it and
directors who
who approve preferential payments when
they know the place is going bust up all
kinds of legal liability and the whole
thing was falling apart and
and and to their credit enormous credit
you basically had
the fed in the sec
uh
mostly it was the fed in the treasury
and they they said
we just can't have this happen it could
be producing
uh
a national catastrophe
and
for some weeks
we had about a hundred and
or 40 billion dollars
of
funding and 130 or 40 billion dollars
was a lot of money in those days we were
the
one of the three or four largest
borrowers in the united states and we
borrowed daily
and we borrowed against government bonds
we had
inventory there but we only had 4
billion of equity and we have 130
billion
and there was a guy
a wonderful guy
john mcfarland he was the treasurer he
slept down at the
downtown
uh
offices right near their offices of
solomon for days and days and days and
days because a billion dollars a day was
draining out there was a run on solomon
and it was a run that the treasury and
the fed
in the sec did not want to have happen
and reverse themselves and everything
and
a few days into it
uh
for whatever reason but
calpers was a big lender to us
and they decided they weren't going to
do business with
with uh solomon anymore so they were
going to precipitate them
they were going to accelerate the runner
and
they announced one day that they kind of
approved of everything was going on but
they just didn't want anything to do
with us even though we were giving them
government bonds of security
and
this was
accentuating
the problems for the federal reserve the
u.s treasury at scc
and
no one knew how it was going to come out
but they pulled and other people pulled
and john mcfarland
stayed downtown and kept trying to raise
a billion dollars every day to
pay all people in terms of ruin that was
occurring and
the fed did not want this run to get out
of the hand but they couldn't give us
the money and the treasury didn't want
the run to get out of hand but they
couldn't give us money and so on and it
was it was a terrible problem
and uh
uh
calpers like they say they
they said well we don't want anything to
do with these guys so we won't land on
government securities even though the
loan is good
and then
uh
a little later
it was sent they sent word to me
uh
that
if i would come out
to california
and talk to the people the trustees
that they would reconsider so
that was that was what they wanted
uh as
part of their deal not to cause
keep participating this run and and take
a different position
and i never would have done this for
anything except for the fact that
it was solomon i mean so basically
i got on a plane
and i flew to california
and i met with the calipers people and i
wasn't charging them anything if i'd
been charging them a lot of money they
would have paid attention and
they still paid attention they were very
nice to me when i went out there and i
talked to him
and
and they were happy and they clapped
and they paid didn't pay
attention to what i said because i
wasn't charging a big fee or anything of
sort and i went back to new york
and then they started doing business
with us and announced that really
they had
decided solomon was fit to do business
so
i have a little bias
in terms of when they come around and
they
they presented
set a proposal and
and they say that
in their proposal and this is in our
proxy statement we file this with the
fcc we're not going to say it if it
isn't true
and basically they they make a mistake
they and some other people that
that
they make a mistake and say something
about
the shareholders voting
uh
it says 2021 annual meeting this is part
of their supporting proposal where a
significant
majority
of non-inside shareholders supported the
similar version of this real solution
well
we say in our response
the proponents assertion that at the
annual meeting is a significant majority
of non-inside shareholders
supported
a similar resolution is incorrect and in
fact a significant majority of such
shareholders did not support the
proposal that's either true or false
and you know i have the
the last report submitted by that
same firm and
that handles our
material and
at
roy moore is a broad bridge
and it reports the number of
shareholders it's
the last day before the voting or
something like that and it's got
the number of
of
shareholders
that
support us and against us and it's it's
four to one in our favor and something
like that and and
it just doesn't make any difference to
them i mean it it's fascinating to me
that
um
[Applause]
and you know it it uh
i i would i would be willing to wager
somebody if we could find an impartial
judgment if you go to
any group you want to pick let's take
the
ceos of the five leading utility
companies in the united states the ceos
of the ten league and ask them
you know whether
whether berkshire hathaway energy has
been a
a leader in
in the field of renewables and so on and
they'd all say yes but but
essentially
you've got a
a group of people
that
that uh
write us letters and say we want to be
we want you to do things our way and we
got three million other shareholders but
forget about them and spend some money
on this and
and have a meeting with us
and here's our way of measuring it then
and
admittedly we've got all kinds of
information up about what we've done and
they can come out to iowa and look
around and it is
it is the
it is the renewables capital of the
world practically and we're the ones
that have done it
and
they just that isn't what they want
so
i like
you know i'm first shareholder democracy
and all that sort of thing but the
answer is
that
the resolution
you know
they pay lots of money to somebody that
probably works in these groups and
they've got groups of the you know
they've got their way of doing i get
letters from
from institutions in europe and they say
well
you know you've got you may have 40
pages or a history of going back to 2006
of explaining what you're doing but
here's what we the way we want you to do
it and you know and
you know how much energy is garanimals
which we own this i think
it's just it
you have to think
you know as a
person
sitting here and
you know it's it's it's it's it's not a
but it's these are the rules you get on
the proxy statement under certain
circumstances most companies they don't
want a lot of resolutions so it's just
easier for them
to
you know
set up a department
and uh
you know
pay a bunch of people to
pay attention to him just like warren
did when he flew across the whole
country because he had it wasn't money i
just i was worried about a company
surviving that that the people in
washington the supervisor were about to
survive again and uh
and uh
if i came if i flew across country and
paid them sufficient respect i mean it
was
kind of like the godfather or something
you know i just bought out and
then flew back that uh
so i
have a certain reservation
about
about uh
shareholder proposals should have some
meaning i mean i it's kind of thing i
argued for when i was younger but you
know basically it's become
uh in my opinion
uh there's certain items that you can
put on the ballot certain that you can't
and practically every executive in the
country
now the chief executive wants to have a
virtual meeting the last thing you want
to have shareholders and people stand up
and propose things
and we'll just keep talking about it the
way we see it is
and
in the end
we will have a report as to the boat and
uh
this time and and i can assure you we're
not we're not stuffing the ballot boxes
we're not doing anything i mean voter
fraud you know it
it's not like
chicago in the old days where you waited
for the cemetery vote to come in and
that sort of thing
we
we don't count the votes
you know we don't say where they come
from we don't know where they come from
but we can tell
when two or three institutions have got
huge amounts of shares but they're one
one over and they
they vote a certain way and then
they feel pure
and they don't really
what they care about is whether we check
their boxes and the people that work for
them
a certain number of people are getting
employed by them and
and their hearts are pure
uh
but ours aren't impure
and uh
with that
i think we ought to uh
well and i won't do this again but i i
it just uh
it it's uh
it's a really interesting
uh
development
in terms
of getting more
a rules-based
type of situation where basically every
you know no company
almost every company figures out how to
negotiate with the people later and they
all have con
a good many of the ceos i mean
they don't they just figure it's
something that they endure in the
business and they
set up a department
to
answer the questions and meet with the
people and show them the proper respect
and
so on and and
uh you know it's
it's um
being done
to uh
carry through on something which
i think the uh the substance of is is is
pretty similar i thought
if i thought berkshire hathaway
energy was behaving
in a way
that was
bad for society
worse than other utility companies but
no company
and the reason of course is that we
don't take dividends out so we we plug
tens of billions of dollars into the
business most fact every utility pays
out the dividends and it's not the fault
of the utility management that's just a
policy that's been the case in the
utility industry but they don't really
have much cash left over
and we have plenty of cash and we'll put
in more cash and we'll we're willing to
build
you know whatever amount
of transmission lines and all kinds of
things
that would be helpful
to the country and and uh and we're
doing a fair amount of that we could do
a whole lot more and we're better
positioned to do it
really than
than any utility company in the country
and i think if you talk to other utility
executives i don't advise you to go and
put them on the spot or anything but
they would agree
but they also know that
their life is easier if they
just have somebody
to take care
of uh
people that want to be
catered to basically and i catered to
them in the time of sullivan
in 1991 because 8 000 people
were working there and and and john
mcfarland was trying to raise a billion
dollars a day and
the treasury and the fed and
sec wanted us to stay alive and
in fact uh
that caused me to
go and
pay my respects to the godfather and i
came back but i do think a little
background is kind of interesting on
this and with that we'll
we'll ask miss hammock
uh
[Applause]
can you give your report
my report is ready the ballot of the
proxy holders in response to proxies
that were received through last thursday
evening cast 127 thousand two hundred
fourteen votes for the motion and three
hundred seventy thousand four hundred
fifteen votes against the motion as the
number of votes against the motion
exceeds a majority of the number of
votes of all class a and class b shares
properly cast
on the matter the motion has failed the
certification required by delaware law
of the precise count of the votes given
to the secretary to be placed with the
minutes of this meeting
yeah and i will just add that
you know i got a report a day or two ago
the last report they sent me from from
this firm and
it's poor to wonder if i they want to be
glad to share it with anybody
but in terms of number of shareholders
that are a number of shareholders
that based on what these people in new
jersey tell me the boat was
uh
we're against it and uh
you know
it's
and if they would reintroduce the
proposal next year
i just hope they leave that line out
because
i would just uh
uh
suggest that
somebody read what the proposal is
or what the facts are before they they
they spent
they announced their
proposals and all that sort of thing
okay well the third proposal requested
the company issue report
addressing if and if and how it intends
to measure and disclose and reduce ghg
emissions associated with
underwriting insuring and investing
activities the directors are recommended
the sheryl would vote against the
proposal
i will now recognize jalen spann
representative of whistle stop capital
to present the proposal
chairman mr buffett and board members
good afternoon my name is jalen spann
and i want to first thank you for the
opportunity to present proposal number
four on behalf of shareholder
representative as you saw
this proposal asked berkshire to measure
disclose and begin reducing the
greenhouse gas emissions supported by
its insuring underwriting and investment
activities
in its most simple terms the proposal
asks berkshire to take responsibility
for its contribution to climate change
the u.s commodity futures trading
commission has acknowledged that climate
change can impair the productive
capacity of the national economy
the litany of national and global events
associated with climate change
the fires in california and colorado
the floods across the midwest
the growing strength of hurricanes
the deep freeze in texas to name just a
few
demonstrate the growing risk and costs
of climate change
2021 was the second most costly year on
record for the world's insurers with
insured losses totaling 120 billion
dollars from natural catastrophes
significantly these losses can no longer
be categorized as simply a bad year
as noted by munich re
economic losses caused by natural fast
catastrophes are trending upward
the insurance industry faces year on
year growth in insured losses related to
climate change
mercure is not only exposed to
climate-related risks but it is actively
amplifying these risks through its
continued investment in and underwriting
of high carbon activities
berkshire is one of the largest
providers of coverage to the oil and gas
industry surpassing peers such as chubb
and liberty mutual
its shareholdings in coal alone amounts
to 5.1 billion dollars once again
far surpassing its american peers
a financial institutions investment and
underwriting activities are by far the
greatest source of its total carbon
footprint highlighting the need for
berkshire to measure disclose and begin
taking responsibility for the emissions
it enables
the global financial sector is rising to
the challenge of meeting the paris
agreement's goal to maintain global
temperature rise at 1.5 degrees celsius
the net zero insurance alliance has
grown to 22 members seven of which
are in the top 30 largest global
insurers by market cap
all members have committed to reach net
zero emissions from their insurance and
reinsurance underwriting portfolios by
aig and the hartford have also recently
committed to reach net zero emissions
from their underwriting and investment
portfolios by 2050 or sooner
berkshire is lagging both its american
and its european peers
a position that increases climate risk
globally and to its own portfolios
the insurance industry in berkshire
specifically has a key role to play in
the ongoing low low-carbon transition
and we believe berkshire has the ability
to become a climate leader on this
critical issue and the first steps are
to quantify the emissions associated
with its underwriting and investing
activities
disclose those emissions and begin
developing plans to reduce those
emissions in alignment with the
periscope
to ensure global success in protecting
this planet and its inhabitants every
business must take responsibility for
its own contribution to climate change
and we look forward to working with
berkshire to address this vital issue
thank you thank you miss spence
[Applause]
the um
motion is not ready to be acted upon if
there are any shareholders voting in
person mission now
how about a little light up here they
should not mark their proposal
uh they're battling on the on the motion
missamic when you are ready you may give
your report
my report is ready
the ballot of the proxy holders in
response to proxies that were received
through last thursday evening
cast one hundred twenty seven thousand
sixty five votes for the motion and
three hundred seventy thousand six
hundred thirty votes against the motion
as the number of votes against the
motion exceeds a majority of the number
of the votes of all class a
and class b shares properly cast on the
matter the motion has failed
the certification required by the
delaware law of the precise count of the
votes given to the secretary to be
placed with the minutes of this meeting
thank you miss amick
proposal fails
the fourth
proposal request the company report to
shareholders on the outcome of the
diversity equity and inclusion efforts
directors have recommended the
shareholders to vote against the
proposal
i will now recognize jalen spann
representative whisselstop to present
the proposal
hello i'm jalen spann
i'm speaking on behalf of the non-profit
advocacy organization as you saw and
whistle stop capital
i formally move proposal number five
asking for berkshire hathaway to report
on the outcomes of their diversity
equity and inclusion efforts by
publishing quantitative data on their
workforce composition
and recruitment retention and promotion
rates of employees by gender race and
ethnicity
warren buffett once mentioned that he
had grown up with two sisters who to
quote mr buffett are absolutely smart as
i am and better personalities
he also bravely admitted that he only
placed women on his board
after his wife suggested it in
2003 40 years after he started his
company
it's one thing to know that people of
all genders races and ethnicities can
contribute to berkshire hathaway
it is another thing entirely to
intentionally and proactively create the
space opportunity and training needed
within a company for those people to be
able to contribute without facing
harassment and discrimination
in the absence of data we must instead
assume that berkshire hathaway companies
are no better nor any worse than any
company in america
the statistics for american companies
are unacceptable
particularly when we consider the strong
link found by the wall street journal
mckenzie
credit suisse and others between
diversity equity and inclusion programs
and corporate outperformance
42 percent of americans have witnessed
or experienced racism at work
64 percent of black employees say that
discrimination is an issue in their own
workplace
many people of color are barred from
entering the workplace at all
a meta study reviewing data from 1989 to
2017 found that on average whites
received 24 percent more callbacks than
blacks and 36 percent more callbacks
than latinos
if we take a look at berkshire's
executive team
we can see that headquarters should be
proud of the gender and racial diversity
present in its leadership team
the culture that exists at berkshire
hathaway headquarters appears to be one
that recruits hires promotes and retains
diverse employees
mr buffett stresses the importance of
culture and the value that it has on the
long-term success of a company
he said that culture more than rule
books determines how an organization
behaves
investors are looking for assurances
that this culture is successfully
implemented within the famously
decentralized berkshire hathaway
companies as well
in order to allow their investors to
understand their workplace diversity 87
of the s p 100 companies have released
or have committed to releasing their ee
01 form which is a standardized
government mandated accounting of gender
race and ethnicity breakdown by
employment levels
by contrast
of the more than 60 companies berkshire
owns
only one has publicly released this form
one company
this is not the leadership that mr
buffett is known for
the company's inclusion data the hiring
retention and promotion rates of diverse
employees must also be shared for
investors to have a full understanding
of the actual experience of not only
berkshire's employees but of its
portfolio companies employees as well
the board has released insufficient
information to assure investors that it
is attentive to diversity equity and
inclusion at berkshire hathaway
companies we encourage transparency even
in the face of imperfection
in order to show that the company's
leaders are truly committed to change
and to attracting retaining and
promoting the best possible employees
thank you
[Applause]
i certainly agree with you that
that
my sisters were
better looking
smarter
had better personalities
and
in 1930
uh
they had a father
and mother
teachers
who love them
like
they love me
and if i've been born
female
black
in various other countries
i would not have had
remotely the life
i've enjoyed
but
i uh
if
what the people at the top believe
is important
in terms of how our subsidiaries behave
they certainly there's everybody that
runs any one of our subsidiaries
knows how i feel they also know that
they're in charge of their own business
and uh
that
we think we've got great leaders in
every
virtually every company we have every
now and then
we find we've made a mistake obviously
but
uh
if uh
the idea
that i should replace any of
the people that run from the businesses
and they're doing i i i
i just don't think that's the way to to
operate and
i will
tell you just so that the question
doesn't come up later
in terms of our shareholders
by
again a four or five to one
boat
bonus so the owners of the berkshire
company whether
not forgetting about forgetting about a
or b shares
you know basically the big funds
that
uh
are
worried about what their perception is
and but also may well believe it who
knows what people's motivations are
somebody said that the word motivation
should never be used in the singular
because
we don't know but the one thing is that
it's very hard to find people
that
are running big institutions
that uh
you know are
acting
against
their self-interest now it doesn't mean
they're acting for their self-interest
necessarily they're acting for a lot of
reasons
but uh
uh
it
it's uh
it's something that
i could
if you could change that in people it
would do a lot more from american
americans in the future but you can't
basically can't change that i mean it's
a situation of how
people behave and protecting
essentially their own interests and
and their own interests
uh
40 or 50 years ago
was uh
essentially the regard
corporate america is a boys club and
and that's not acceptable anymore so
they changed but they haven't changed as
much
by a substantial margin in relation to
to uh to blacks and that uh
that's where we are as a society
but
overwhelmingly
uh
our shareholders don't
don't agree with you even
though they had a chance to
uh you gave them a chance to express
their view on it so
miss amick when you're ready you may
give your report
my report is ready the ballot of the
proxy holders in response to proxies
that were received through last thursday
evening
cast
614 votes for the motion
and 373
925 votes against the motion
as the number of votes against the
motion exceeds a majority of the number
of votes of all class a
and class b shares properly cast on the
matter the motion has failed the
certification required by delaware law
of the precise count of the votes given
to the secretary to be placed within
minutes of this meeting
thank you miss amit proposal fails
i move that this meeting be adjourned
i second the motion to adjourn
motion adjourn has been made and
seconded
the meeting is adjourned
thank you all for coming